DO NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM THERE
ARE FOUR OF US HERE.
THANK MY COLLEAGUES -- FOR FOR
JOINING US IN A TIMELY MANNER --
AND WILL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND THEN AS SOON AS WE
HAVE OUR FIFTH AND SIX MEMBERS
WILL -- CALDERON ESTABLISH A
QUORUM -- FOLKS TO PLEASE TURN
OFF YOUR CELL PHONES AND TAKE
ANY CONVERSATIONS -- OUTSIDE SO
AS NOT TO DISRUPT THE HEARING.
WITH TWENTY ONE BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA -- SO WE'RE GONNA BE
LIMITING WITNESS TESTIMONY AT
THE TABLE -- TO TWO PEOPLE ON
EACH.
SIDE TO FOR SUPPORT TO FOR
OPPOSED THREE MINUTES EACH -- IF
YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE THREE PEOPLE
THAT'S FINE BUT THEN IT'S TWO
MINUTES EACH SO TOTAL OF SIX
MINUTES -- FOR YOUR WITNESSES ON
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH WILL
TAKE UP ONCE OF A QUORUM.
CONSISTS OF FIVE BILLS AB FIFTY
EIGHT SB SIX THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN AB TEN TEN AM
E. BE. FIFTEEN SIXTY SO THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO AND FILE ORDER AND I SEE THAT --
MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOME NUMBER --
TWO THE AUTHOR OF ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB TENNIS HERE SO.
SHE WILL COME UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AB -- TEN THIS
IS A BILL THAT IN THE MIDST OF
THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY WOULD EXPAND ONE
OF OUR STATES MOST EFFECTIVE
HOUSING FINANCING TOOLS WHICH IS
OUR STATE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TAX CREDIT.
THE BILL WOULD PROPOSE TO
INCREASE THE TAX CREDIT -- BY
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH WOULD IN TURN LEVERAGE AT
LEAST ANOTHER BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS LOCAL AND
PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT.
THIS BILL IS VERY SIMILAR TO
PREVIOUS BILLS I'VE AUTHORED AND
I WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE SUPPORT
IN THE PAST -- I'M EXCITED TO
SAY THAT THE BUDGET THAT WAS
JUST APPROVED A FEW DAYS AGO
DOES INCLUDE A FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN THE
TAX CREDIT.
WHICH WOULD BE A CAN TO HELPING
TO FUND THIS YEAR FOR THIS
PARTICULAR BILL -- BUT UNLIKE AB
TEN THOUGH THE INCREASES ONE
TIME IN ANY FUTURE INCREASES
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS SOON AS THE HOUSING TRAILER
BILL THAT IS UNDER DISCUSSION AT
THIS MOMENT IS PASSED.
OUR PLAN IS TO CONTINUE TO MOVE
THIS BILL AMEND THE LANGUAGE
FROM THE TRAILER BILL THAT ALL
OF US WILL VOTER ON AND TO
PROPOSE AT THIS INCREASE BE MADE
FOR FIVE YEARS.
WE BELIEVE THAT A STATUTORY
INCREASE IS IMPORTANT RATHER
THAN RELYING ON ANY WILL BUDGET
APPROPRIATIONS WE KNOW THAT FOR
A HOUSING DEVELOPERS LINE UP
FUNDING SOURCES YEARS IN ADVANCE
INVESTORS ALSO NEED CERTAINTY.
AND PART BECAUSE THE PURCHASERS
OF THESE CREDITS ARE TYPICALLY
MAJOR BANKS AND CORPORATIONS WHO
DO TAX PLANNING OVER A LONG TIME
HORIZON -- AND WITH THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR SUPPORT
TURN OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU AND THERE WILL BE TELL
ME WITNESSES. TO TO GRADE THREE
MINUTES IS PLEASE THANK YOU.
MARINO WHITE WITH A CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M JUST WHAT
TO ADD ON TO WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM MENTIONED -- IN ORDER
FOR THE STATE TO TRULY INCREASE
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON AN ONGOING BASIS
INSTEAD OF AND SORT OF BACK
FILLING PIPELINE PROJECTS.
THERE IS A NEED FOR THIS PROGRAM
TO THIS ALLOCATION O BE ON
GOING -- WITH AT LEAST SORT OF
THAT FIVE YEAR COMMITMENT -- AND
WITH THAT I WILL TURN OVER AND
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY.
A MISTER TURN MEMBERS JULIE
SNYDER WITH EQUITY ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING HOUSING CALIFORNIA
WE ARE PLEASED TO BE ONE OF THE
FOUR CO SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE --
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
CONSTITUTE THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY IN THE
NATION -- AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED
THAT AB TEN DIRECTLY RESPONDS
DIRECTLY WHEN WHEN EMPHASIZED
AFTER A NUMBER OF BILLS GOING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE OF MANY
OF THEM WILL HAVE GREAT IMPACTS
THIS ONE WILL DIRECTLY RESULT.
IN NEW HOMES THAT ARE AFFORDABLE
TO THE VERY LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
CURRENTLY ARE PRICED OUT OF THE
MARKET -- IT'S A BULWARK AGAINST
A SCENARIO FOR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
FALLING INTO HOMELESSNESS -- ONE
MISFORTUNE THEIR LIVING ON THE
EDGE AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD THE
RENT ANYMORE -- THIS BILL
DIRECTLY AFFECTS THAT -- IT IS --
A SUSTAINED INVESTMENT WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU
FOR HIS PERSEVERANCE AND WE ARE
DRIVE VOTE ON AB TEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IF YOU
COULD JUST SAY YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION WILL START WITH THE
FOLKS AT WHAT JOHNSON HIM
BACKSTAGE IS A FEW ANIMA HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
VETERAN CURE ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE MARIN COUNTY COUNCIL OF
MAYORS AND COUNCIL MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
TO MEGAN REPRESENTS OVER
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS AND SUPPORT.
JANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AT
THE MENTOR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT.
RUGOVA HOME FOR THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA AS A CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
ANI LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT.
MARYLAND A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
MALLORY SOCCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVID ON THE F. THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION AND
SUPPORT.
BRIAN GUEST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR RURAL
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS MONTANA BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA INDIANS TRANSPORT.
BUT FORGET TO YOU ON BEHALF OF
BURBANK HOUSING NONPROFIT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
CINEMA NAPA COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF TESTIMONY --
SING NINE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD
.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DAVE ALL
ROUTES FOR PRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PART OF A COALITION
LETTER THAT WAS SENT.
IN OPPOSITION.
OUR OPPOSITION IS BASED ON WHAT
IS REFERENCE IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
ON PAGE EIGHT POINT.
NINE THAT BECAUSE OF THIS IS A
TAX CREDIT TO RETREAT WE TO
STATE GENERAL FUND REVENUE.
BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE FUNDED.
FORTY TWO CENTS ON THE DOLLAR.
FROM STATE GENERAL FUND
EFFECTIVELY A TAX CREDIT REDUCES
SCHOOL FUNDING.
BY 40%.
A BACK TAX CREDIT ABOUT AT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION A YEAR. FIVE FOR
YEARS MUCH USING A SIMPLE -- ONE
THAT WOULD BE -- APPROXIMATELY A
LOSS OF EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO SCHOOLS. FORTY FIRST
IN THE NATION AND FUNDING.
WHAT TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
BELOW ADEQUACY FUNDING LEVEL?
WE WOULD URGE CONSIDERATION OF A
DIFFERENT WAY OF LOOKING AT HOW
THIS IS FUNDED.
RATHER THAN PUTTING AT RISK
FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NINE WILL BRING IT
BACK -- TO SUBCOMMITTEE STILL
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM -- OUR
CULTURE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR YES CENTER MORE LAW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'M JUST.
IF YOU MADE AN INTERESTING
STATEMENT TAT MOST OF THE
CREDITS FOR YOU USED BY BANKS.
AND COULD YOU EXPLAIN THAT.
SURE THE PURCHASE OF THEIR TAX
CREDITS ARE TYPICALLY BANKS AND
CORPORATIONS AND THEY'RE THE
ONES WHO.
WORK WITH THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS TO FUND THESE THESE
PROJECTS.
I'M HAPPY TO EXPAND A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN IT BECAUSE THE MAJORITY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
ARE NON PROFITS THEY THEMSELVES.
DON'T NEED THE TAX CREDIT AND SO
THEY PARTNER WITH INVESTORS
OFTEN IT BANKS WHO ARE TRYING TO
MEET THEIR FEDERAL CRA
REQUIREMENTS.
INVEST THEIR DOLLARS INTO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING -- TO ENSURE
THAT THAT THEIR MEETING THAT WAS
THOSE GOALS IN IN IN THE DAY WE
USED TO SEE.
PARTNERSHIPS OF INVESTORS THAT
WOULD.
THE BILL THAT WE STILL HAVE IS
INDICATORS THAT ARE SORT OF
COUPLE INVESTOR GROUPS AND TO
INVEST IN PROJECTS WE KNOW WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF OF THE BUILDING
THAT [inaudible]
THEY REPRESENT.
YOU MEAN LIKE HOW MUCH MONEY
THEY MAKE.
NO NO JUST A YOU KNOW HOW HOW
MANY PROJECTS ARE DOING BECAUSE
IT BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE MUCH
WHEN I WAS IN MY CPA PRACTICE I
DIDN'T SEE A LOT OF IT.
THERE ARE TYPICALLY FIRMS THAT
SPECIALIZE SPECIFICALLY.
I THERE'S A HANDFUL I CAN.
MEET WITH YOU HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT IT MORE NOTE FIND A WERE
JUST.
CHAT AND IT JUST ASK SOME
GENERAL QUESTIONS BECAUSE WE'RE
INCREASING THIS TO FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION.
HOW MUCH OF THAT WILL BE USED?
EVERY EVERY PENNY THANKS SO
ABSOLUTELY THIS THIS CURRENTLY
THE CURRENT TAX CREDIT IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED BY SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT AND I'VE NO DOUBT THAT
THIS WILL ALL BE PUT TO USE
GIVEN THE CRISIS WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW.
SO THEN WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
FARM WORKER HOUSING AREA BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT ASKING FOR THE
CREDITS.
WE THREE HAVE A LONG HISTORY
YOUR OF OF IT BEING UNDER
UTILIZED A COUPLE OF TECHNICAL
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE TO THE
FARMER TAX CARE PROGRAM I
BELIEVE LAST YEAR -- THAT WAS
GOING TO ALLOW RIGHT NOW THERE'S
A SUCH A SMALL ALLOCATION ON
ANNUAL BASIS THAT IT CAN FIND
LIKE ONE PROJECT AND SO
INCREASING THAT ALLOCATION
ALLOWS.
MORE THAN ONE PROJECT RIGHT NOW
YOU HAVE TO WAIT SEVERAL YEARS
TO KIND OF CAPTURE EACH FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OR FIVE YEAH -- TOGETHER TO THEN
FIND ONE PROJECT AND SO BY
INCREASING AND THE SET ASIDE
WHICH THIS BILL DOES IT WOULD
THEN ALLOW MORE FARM WORKER
PROJECTS TO BE ABLE TO FIND BE
FUNDED ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
INSTEAD OF COBBLING OVER SEVERAL
YEARS THIS TO BE SPECIFIC ON
PAGE TWO OF THE ANALYSIS --
UNDER THIS BILL NUMBER TO
REFERENCE IS THE FACT THAT THE
CURRENT AGGREGATE AMOUNT FOR THE
SET ASIDE FOR FORMER HOUSING IS
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
WE WOULD LIFT THAT TO TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DLLARS OF THE FIVE
AND A MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
SOMETHING WE DID AND DEEP
DISCUSSION WITH FORMER COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU SIMILAR VIRTUES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
OKAY THIS SIDE OF BILL DOES
ENJOY A AND I RECOMMENDATION OF
ONE THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR HIS PERSISTENCE I THIN
YOU'VE BEEN DOING THIS SINCE --
TWENTY FIFTEEN AND IT LOOKS LIKE
WE FINALLY HAVE SOME MOMENTUM SO
CONGRATULATIONS -- AND WE WILL
TAKE THIS UP FOR A VOTE WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM -- BUT WITH THAT --
YOU MAY CLOSE AGAIN RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR SUPPORT THIS IS THE ONE
AND ONLY BILL I'VE INTRODUCED
EVERY YEAR FOR FIVE YEARS IN
PART.
BECAUSE IT'S INCREDIBLY BORED IN
THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS WE HAVE
IN PART BECAUSE THE TOOLS BEEN
SO EFFECTIVE IN PART BECAUSE OF
THE STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
FOR THE IDEA AND OUR HOPE IS.
FIFTH TIME IS THE CHARMSO
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE
WILL TAKE UP OF ONLY OF A QUORUM.
OKAY I SEE THAT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- THREE OF US SAYS HERE
WHO HAS TWO BILLS IN ADDITION TO
THE ONE ON THE CONSENT AGENDA SO.
SOME REMEMBER [inaudible]
THE REGULAR [inaudible]
OKAY.
THERE'S THREE CONES OKAY.
OKAY SO MEMBERS SO WHY DON'T WE
START WITH ITEM THREE AB SIXTY
SEVEN THAT'S THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS FIRST I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THE BILL I'M TO ADDRESS
PRIVACY CONCERNS.
AND MAKE CLEAR FINE AND
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS OB THAT
PROVIDE FURTHER DIRECTION TO DSS
REGARDING FOSTER USE DATA.
I'M ACCEPTING THOSE AMENDMENTS
TODAY I'M ALSO WORKING TO
ADDRESS ANY PRIVACY CONCERNS
THAT MAY ARISE.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB SIXTY
SEVEN BECAUSE THIS WILL
ESTABLISH A STATE DATABASE TO
COMPILE AND CENTRALIZED DATA
FROM STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES ON
CALIFORNIA'S HOMELESS POPULATION.
AND THE SERVICES PROVIDED AND
USED BY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS.
THIS COMPREHENSIVE DATABASE WILL
ALLOW FOR AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
COSTS OF HOMELESSNESS TO THE
STATE IDENTIFIED GAPS IN
SERVICES.
DISK DISCOVER HOW PATTERNS OF
SERVICE USE RELATE TO PATTERNS
OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND ENHANCE PLANNING AND POLICY
EFFORTS TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR STATE.
YOUR CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN THE COUNTRY.
IN ORDER TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS
AND THE PUBLIC COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH SUCH EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE NATURE.
OF OUR HOMELESS POPULATION AND
BE ABLE TO EVALUATE WHAT
STRATEGIES WORK BEST -- TODAY I
HAVE SANDRA BUT A LITTLE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL [inaudible] THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CENTER BARRERA ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB.
SIXTY SEVEN CSA MEMBERS SERVE
HOMELESS STUDENTS SUMMER HOME
WAS THEMSELVES AND OTHERS ARE
JUST ONE PAYCHECK AWAY.
WE KNOW THE HOMELESS POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA IS GROWING IN
ORDER BEST SERVICE POPULATION WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND WHO THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE IN WHICH
SERVICES THEY ARE ABLE TO ACCESS.
AB SIXTY SEVEN WILL COLLECT THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO BEST
SERVE THOSE THAT ARE HOMELESS OR
AT RISK OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
AND HELP GUIDE OUR FUTURE POLICY
DECISIONS AS WE WORK TO AND THIS
CRISIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. TO THIS
LETTER AGAIN HERE AGAIN
REPRESENTING HOUSING CALIFORNIA
ALONG WITH THE NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
ADVANCING CUTTING EDGE SOLUTIONS
TO ENDING HOMELESSNESS -- ON
BEHALF OF THOSE GROUPS WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOT NAME
AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
MALLARD FILLED WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MARKETERS ARE GONNA KICK THE
DIRECTOR OF MICHAEL BUT IF YOUR
COMPASS ENOUGH REPRESENTING
SERVICES FOR FARMWORKERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THREE NINE WILL MOVE.
ABOUT THE COMMITTEE -- COLORS
AND QUESTIONS -- CENTER MORE
LOOK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANT TO GET A CLARIFICATION
IN ORANGE COUNTY WE WE USE HM AT
H. M. I. S. THE HOMELESS
MANAGEMENT INFORMATION SYSTEM.
TO KEEP TRACK OF OUR HOMELESS TO
TO HIDE REQUIREMENTS.
AND I'M JUST KIND OF WONDERING
IF.
WHAT MAKES THIS DIFFERENT?
AND WHY AREN'T WE JUST USING
WHAT'S ALREADY BEING ASSEMBLED
OR ACQUIRED BY COUNTIES AND JUST
GET THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES.
TO YOUR COUNTY USES THE SAID
THAT H. IT'S A FLAT HEAD
REQUIREMENT RIGHT -- I THINK
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT REPORTING
THAT TO THE STATE THEY'RE JUST
REPORTING IT DIRECTLY TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND NOT TO WORST THAT THE
DOLLARS THAT THE STATE IS
PROVIDING COUNTIES AND CITIES.
ARE MORE NOT YOU KNOW GETTING
THAT.
THAT WHAT WHAT IS BEING SPENT ON
THOSE SERVICES BUT WE'RE GETTING
THE DATA SO WE HAVE THE DATA
WE'RE FACT WE HAVE NONPROFIT IN
AN ORANGE COUNTY THAT'S
COLLECTING IT.
THOMAS AYE FOR SOMEONE LOOKING
FOR MY BILL AND RESPECTIVE SO
I'M THINKING OH MY GOODNESS WERE
WERE ALREADY DOING THAT WHY
WOULD I CREATE THIS IS CREATED
STATEWIDE HOMELESS INTEGRATED
DATA WAREHOUSE.
WHEN WE ALREADY HAVE AT LEAST
THAT THAT DATA?
SO WHY DO WE DO DO THE BILL SO
THAT WE SAY LET'S WORK WITH HUD
TO GET THE DATA AND THEN.
DO A STATEWIDE DATABASE.
NO I UNDERSTAND OKAY -- YEAH I
KNOW I HAVEN'T BEEN AWARE OF
WHAT COUNTIES ARE DOING YOU KNOW
IN TERMS OF REPORTING TO HIDE
AND I KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
REPORTING TO OUR STATE AND I
DEFINITELY CAN LOOK INTO THAT.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
OKAY THIS DOES -- ENJOYING AYE
RECOMMENDATION ALL WE DO NOT
HAVE A CORN SO WE WILL TAKE IT
UP FOR A VOTE ONCE -- FOR MORE
COLLEAGUES MANAGE TO MAKE THEIR
WAY DOWN HERE -- AND WITHOUT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- THANK
YOU AND YOU KNOW WHEN THE TIME'S
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
HEY WILL NOW GO TO ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN AB SEVENTY NO -- TO AND
I JUST -- THIS DOES ENJOY A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB --
SEVENTEEN OH TO BECAUSE THIS
BILL PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
STAFFING POSITIONS FOR THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL -- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND FOR SEEM
VALUE IN OUR LEGISLATION BY
INCLUDING THE POSITIONS IN THE
BUDGET.
OTHER POSITIONS ARE INCLUDED IN
THE STATE BUDGET AS A RESULT OF
NEGOTIATIONS AND THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHICH RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE WILL BE PULLING THE POSITIONS
OF FROM THIS BILL IN FISCAL
COMMITTEE -- WHILE IT'S TRUE THE
COUNCIL IS ALREADY DIRECTED TO
LOOK INTO POLICIES THAT COULD BE
STREAMLINED TO BETTER INSURANCE --
DELIVERY EFFECTIVE DELIVERY OF
HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS OF THE
BILL ESTABLISHES A TIMELINE OR A
TIMETABLE FOR GETTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE COUNCIL
TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
OF I HAVE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL -- MARTHA GUERRERO
WITH THE LA COUNTY CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICE -- TO SUPPORT
AB.
SEVENTEEN OH TWO GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARTHA
GUERRERO REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTEEN OH TWO WOULD LIKE
TO THANK.
THE AUTHORS IN THE MEMORY OF US
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL AND ALL
THE WORK SHE'S ACCOMPLISHING.
THE HOMELESS FROM.
CORE NEEDING A FINANCING COUNCIL
WILL HELP LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO
ADDRESS THE RISING -- THE POINT
IN TIME COUNT THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED 12% UP TO FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED -- HOUSING ABOUT
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND BUT THERE'S
AN INFLOW AND THERE'S A NEED FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO STUDY AND
EVALUATE THAT IN THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IN THIS BILL -- TO
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND AND
STREAMLINED -- AND AND OF THE
FINANCE ALL THE SERVICES FOR
HOME TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
WOULD REALLY HELP US THEREFORE
WE URGE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
HUNTINGTON SHARP FROM THE HELP
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HOUSING CONFERENCE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
CAN LIVE CALIFORNIA COALITION
FOR YOUTH AND SUPPORT.
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OR
THE CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARKINGS ARE GONNA GO BUT IF YOU
ARE COMPETING IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLUTION ON BEHALF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA AND SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IF SO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CASING NON CENTER MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
CATION.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RIVAS YOU YOU
MENTIONED THAT THIS WAS ALREADY
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET YES
JUST LIKE LAST WEEK WAS INCLUDED.
THE POSITIONS WERE -- SO WERE
YOU TO THE WHICH IS PART OF THE
BILL AND WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THAT OUT AND LIKE I SAID AND
MENTIONED FISCAL COMMITTEE --
BUT WHAT THE WHAT WILL REMAIN IN
THE BILL IS THE TIME TABLE THAT
THE COUNCIL.
OF EUROPE WILL THEY'LL BE A
TIMETABLE ESTABLISHED SO THAT
THE COUNCIL COULD REPORT BACK TO
THE STATE LEGISLATURE THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS -- I'VE SEEN ON THIS
DOES ENJOY AND I RECOMMENDATION
AND BEFORE WILL BE TAKING THIS
UP ONCE -- WE HAVE A QUORUM --
SERVER YOU'RE WELCOME TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY. FIVE NEXT -- I SEE SOME
MEMBER QUIRK SILVA IS HERE MY
APOLOGIES SOME MEMORY SUMMER
FILE ORDER HERE EVEN VERY
PATIENT -- ITEM FOUR AB.
ONE THIRTY NINE AND THIS DOES
ENJOY -- SUPPORT SUPPORT BY BOTH
SIDES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH OUR
STAFF ON THIS BILL AND WE ALSO
ARE EXCEPT DEAN THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB ONE
THIRTY NINE THE MERCHANT SEE AN
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING ACT.
AS THE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES WE NEED
EVERY COMMUNITY TO ASSESS THE
NEED FOR EMERGENCY AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
THIS BILL UPDATES CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW TO REFLECT
THE STATE'S HOMELESS CRISIS AND
THE NEED FOR EVERY COMMUNITY TO
BETTER ASSESS THE NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
FAMILIES FACING HOMELESSNESS NET
HOMELESSNESS AND IMPLEMENT.
MORE TARGETED TRANSITION
STRATEGIES TO LONG TERM
PERMANENT HOUSING FOR THESE
CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO IDENTIFY IN ZONE
ENOUGH SITES TO ACCOMMODATE IT
IT'S EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS AND
REFLECT THE MOST RECENT HOMELESS
POINT IN TIME COUNT.
WITH ME TODAY WE HAVE NICOLE WAR
TO MEN ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
REBEKAH GONZALEZ WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS.
NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF AB --
ONE THIRTY NINE THIS MEASURE
PRIORITIZES LOCAL ASSESSMENT AND
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS IN A TIMELY MANNER.
LAST JUNE THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ADOPTED A
HOUSING FUNDING STRATEGY AIMING
TO CONSTRUCT TWENTY SEVEN
HUNDRED SUPPORT OF HOUSING UNITS
OVER THE NEXT FIVE YEARS.
THEY ARE.
THEY HAVE BEGUN PLANNING THEIR
PROJECTS AND ARE WELL ON THEIR
WAY AND AB ONE THIRTY NINE KEEPS
UPDATED DATA AND LOCAL NEEDS ON
THE FOREFRONT OF DISCUSSIONS OF
HOMELESSNESS THERE FOR THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS OR JUST AN AYE
VOTE ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS REBECCA GONZALEZ NAME
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER AND WE REPRESENT TEN
THOUSAND SOCIAL WORKERS IN THE
STATE WITH THEIR DEGREE IN
SOCIAL WORK -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE THIRTY NINE WHICH
UPDATES THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOUSING PLANS
TO BETTER ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS HOMELESS
POPULATIONS.
OF FAILURE TO BILL SUFFICIENT
HOUSING FOR LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS IS ONE OF THE
PRINCIPAL CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS.
WE NEED MORE COORDINATION AMONG
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ADDRESS
IMMEDIATE NEED -- FOR SHELTERS
AND TRANSITIONAL HOUSING AS WELL
AS PERMANENT HOUSING TO
ALLEVIATE THIS CRISIS.
THIS BILL AMONG OTHER THINGS
WILL UPDATE THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING ELEMENT WANT TO ASSESS
THE CAPACITY OF OUR HOMELESS
SHELTERS BY USING THE MOST
RECENT HOMELESS POINT IN TIME
COUNTS WHICH HAVE RECENTLY
REVEALED AN INCREASE IN
HOMELESSNESS BY 19% IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. 16% IN THE
CITY OF LA AND 17% IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ACROSS OUR
NATION.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME 222% OF ALL
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVING IN THE U.
S. WHICH IS THE LARGEST SHARE BY
STATE.
THIS CHANGE IN LAW WILL HELP
COMMUNITIES TO BETTER ASSESS THE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES FACING HOMELESSNESS AND
IMPLEMENT MORE TARGETED
TRANSITION STRATEGIES TO LONG
TERM PERMANENT HOUSING. FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
CITY GEORGE REPRESENTING
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
ALRP SPOKE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY -- THIS DOES ENJOY AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS --
WE STILL DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM
AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE IT SOON
WILL TAKE UP FOR VOTE AS SOON AS
OUT.
HAPPENS AND FOR THE RECORD THE
LAST PERSON THE LAST NUMBER WHO
ARRIVES WILL RECEIVE A MICHAEL
CHOIR OR HONORARY AWARD --
SOMEONE WHO'S OFFICIALLY THE
LAST PERSON TO ARRIVE IN
COMMITTEE SO.
HE STARTED HE CREATED AN AWARD
IN GOV AND FINANCE THAT WE
REPLICATED HERE -- SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST A
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY MISTER GRAYSON YOUR OP --
THAT WOULD BE ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
TO YOU ASSEMBLY BILL. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE TOO MUCH THE
HOUSING DATA COLLECTED AT THE
STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL LEVEL.
IS NOT ASSESSABLE STANDARDIZED
OR ORGANIZED IN A MANNER THAT
LEVERAGES THE EXPERTISE OF OUR
EXTENSIVE COMMUNITY OF HOUSING
RESEARCHERS AND ADVOCATES.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS RECENTLY
COMMITTED SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND NEW AUTHORITIES TO
TACKLE THE HOUSING CRISIS AND
ACTING POLICIES TO STREAMLINE
HOUSING APPROVALS.
PRESERVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
PROTECTING VULNERABLE TENANTS
FROM DISPLACEMENT ROBUST DATA IS
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
ENFORCEMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF THESE EFFORTS.
AND TO ENABLE SOUND EVIDENCE
BASED POLICY MAKING IN THE
FUTURE.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL
SUPPORT THIS MISSION IN FOUR
WAYS.
IT WILL REQUIRE THE COLLECTION
OF ADDITIONAL HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE DATA
INCLUDING THE TIMELINE FOR
APPLICATION APPROVAL WHETHER A
PROJECT WAS SUBJECT TO
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW UNDER
SEQUEL.
AND WHETHER A PROJECT RECEIVED
MINISTER REAL APPROVAL.
IT WILL REQUIRE CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO TRANSPARENTLY REPORT
ON FEES AND EXACTIONS THAT APPLY
TO NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
IT DIRECTS AGE CD TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE DATA STRATEGY
INCLUDING AN EVALUATION OF DATA
PRIORITIES AND AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE QUALITY OF DATA SUBMITTED
THROUGH ANNUAL REPORTS.
AND FINALLY IT WILL FACILITATE
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A
STATEWIDE GIS PARCEL DATABASE TO
ORGANIZE AND VISUALIZE THIS DATA.
I AM PLEASED TO BE WORKING WITH
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON OUR SPECIFIC
DATA REQUEST TO BE SURE THAT WE
ARE FOCUSED ON INFORMATION THAT
IS BOTH READILY AVAILABLE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
AND DIRECTLY PERTINENT TO
HOUSING POLICY MAKING AN
INVESTMENT IN OUR DATA CAPACITY
WILL NOT ONLY RESULT IN MORE
EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT OF OUR
EXISTING HOUSING LAWS.
BUT IT WILL DRIVE BETTER
DECISION MAKING AS WE CONTINUE
TO SEARCH FOR SOLUTIONS TO OUR
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS.
I HAVE THREE WITNESSES WITH ME
TODAY WHO WILL REPRESENT THE
BROAD RANGE OF SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL I'LL HAVE THEM -- WITH
CHURCH PERMISSION SO INTRODUCE I
THINK YOUR ANSWER BEFORE WE GET
THERE -- LIGHTNING HAS STRUCK ME
WHICH IS A QUORUM SO BEFORE WE
LOSE IT AGAIN -- WE'RE GONNA
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER PRESENT WINNER
PRESENT MORAL BATES.
BATES PRESENT [inaudible]
TOMORROW.
DORADO.
BROTHER PRESENT MCGUIRE MORE
LUCK.
MORE LIKE PRESENT ROUGH.
ROUGH PRESENT SKINNER AMBERG
CASKEY.
ACOSTA PRESENT OKAY WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. FIVE YOU MAY PROCEED
WITH THEIR WITNESSES.
WITNESSES IF YOU WILL PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARCHER WINNER
MEMBERS MY NAME'S LOUIS MONTAND
WITH CALIFORNIA BE.
A YOUNG THESE ARE SOME OF THE
MOST ENGAGE MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
ON LOCAL LAND USE HOUSING AND
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES BUT EVEN
TOO MANY OF THEM BASIC
INFORMATION ABOUT LOCAL PROGRAMS
IS OFTEN AND ACCESSIBLE.
EVEN TO THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
TECHNICAL SKILLS.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ADDRESSES THIS INFORMATION
CHALLENGE HEAD ON REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS REPORT AND PUBLISH
INFORMATION RELATING TO
IMPORTANT LOCAL PROGRAMS AND
ZONING IS A AS LIKE ZONING
ORDINANCES -- AND ALLOWS
VOLUNTEERS AND THE PUBLIC TO
MORE EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE WITH
THEIR CITY.
IT'S A SOUND GOOD GOVERNMENT
OPEN GOVERNMENT PROPOSAL THAT
WILL ALLOW BETTER SCHISM
PARTICIPATION AND LOCAL POLICY
DECISION MAKING.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY%
MEMBER GRAYSON FOR TO WORKING
WITH US SO CLOSELY AND CAREFULLY
CONSIDERING OUR MANY SUGGESTIONS --
THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO LOCAL ACTIVISTS
AND POLICYMAKERS ENABLING THEM
MORE THOUGHTFULLY ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS FOR
THAT REASON WE STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS RAN AWAY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM AS THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKS TO POLICY
SOLUTIONS FOR ADDRESSING OUR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS.
DATA LIKE THIS THAT THAT WOULD
BE PROVIDED FROM THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW US TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
POLICY SOLUTIONS ARE ARE
SPECIFIC TO THE PROBLEM.
AND THOUGH THERE AREN'T
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES FROM THE
HOUSING POP FROM THOSE POLICY
SOLUTIONS WHICH IS WHY DATA
DRIVEN BILLS LIKE THIS ARE SO
CRITICAL IN MY WHERE STRONG
SUPPORTERS.
ARCHER I SUPPORT TODAY.
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS ANGEL BECAUSE IT -- AND I THE
SCIENTIST LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING AND
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION CBA IS
PLEASE IN ORDER TO SPONSOR.
EIGHTY FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD BRING
TRANSPARENCY TO FEES TAXES AND
PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS ASSOCIATED
WITH HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS BY
POSTING THIS INFORMATION
PUBLICLY.
ACADEMICS CAN STUDY THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN FEES TAXES
IN HOMEBUILDING.
CITIES CAN COMPARE THEIR FEES
AND HOME BUILDINGS TO THEIR TO
THEIR PEERS ELECTED OFFICIALS
CAN MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS
DECISIONS AND A DISCUSSION ABOUT
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION CAN BE HAD
BASED UPON CLEAR DATA.
SO IN ESSENCE EIGHTY FIFTH
FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE HELPS TO
COLLATE VALUABLE DATA IN ORDER
BRING CLARITY TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION AND THE ASSOCIATED
FEES TAXES AND PROPERTY
ASSESSMENTS FOR THESE REASONS.
SEE I A RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
TERRIFIC ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THIS IS YOUR MEMBERS YELEY GARAK
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
DATA BASED DECISION MAKING.
MARILYN CHECK CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL HOUSING
FINANCE AGENCIES [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO FOR ANY
HAVE A FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
LEADING AGE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON EVANS
ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY TMG PARTNERS AND
SILICON VALLEY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MALLORY SPOKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MOST ORDER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SIR GOV I'LL.
BUT A DOUBLE WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS -- IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SEE
NINE OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED TO THE BILL I'M
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO DOING SOME
ADDITIONAL REPORTING BUT WE DO
HAVE A STRONG PREFERENCE.
THAT WE DO THE DATA STRATEGY
THAT'S OUTLINED IN THE BILL
INCLUDING A STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
THAT CAN REALLY LOOK AT THE COST
AND BENEFITS.
OF REVISING LOCAL PROCESS SEES
AN EXPANDING REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS BEFORE WE DO THE
EXPANSION THE WAY THIS BILL
WORKS RIGHT NOW.
IS IT ADDS A LOT OF NEW DATA
INCLUDING TWELVE INDIVIDUAL
PIECES OF DATA THAT'S NOT
CURRENTLY REQUIRED FOR EVERY
SINGLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT IN THE STATE.
AND THEN ADDS THAT TO THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND WITHOUT REALLY HAVING A
CONSIDERATION OF OF BOTH WHAT
ARE THE COST OF COLLECTING THAT
LOCALLY TO CHANGE THOSE
PROCESSES ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
GET PASSED ON TO DEVELOPMENT
APPLICANTS IN THE FORM OF FEES.
AS WELL AS THE CAPACITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSINGAND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. TO PUT
THAT INTO A USABLE FORMAT FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SO WHAT WE
WOULD STRONGLY PREFER TO DO THAT
FIRST AND GO WITH THAT SECTION
OF THE BILL THIS YEAR WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT ADDITIONAL ELEMENTS
OF THE APR.
MIGHT BE SORT OF LOW HANGING
FRUIT THAT WE CAN ADD AND I
THINK THAT'S A CONVERSATION WE
CAN HAVE.
AS THE BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE
THROUGH THE PROCESS -- ANOTHER
ELEMENT OF THE BILL THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT I A LITTLE BIT
OF A TREND THAT WE'RE SEEING
THIS YEAR WHICH IS ADDING THINGS
TO THE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT.
BETTER REALLY OUTSIDE OF THE
CONTEXT OF THE GENERAL PLAN IN
THE HOUSING ELEMENT SPECIFICALLY
IN THIS BILL THE INCLUSION OF
THE ASSESSORS PARCEL DATA.
IN THE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORT
YOU KNOW -- WE CAN TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE I THINK IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE ABOUT WHAT ARE THE
COST OF THAT WHAT IS THE EXTENT
TO WHICH THAT DATA IS AVAILABLE
IN A STANDARDIZED FORMAT.
AND IS THERE A NEED TO REPORT
THAT TO EACH CD.
BUT AT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING A
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER WHO
DOESN'T REPORT TO THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- ADDING THEM TO
THIS APR PROCESS WHICH IS
INCREASINGLY BECOMING A
REQUIREMENT FOR ELIGIBILITY FOR
SB TO HOMELESSNESS FUNDING. FOR
HOUSING BOND PROGRAMS AND THINGS
OF THAT NATURE SO REALLY IN
GENERAL -- WE WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
A BROADER DISCUSSION ABOUT
REALLY COSTS AND BENEFITS WHAT
IS THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL DATA
IS EVERY PIECE OF DATA REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL.
GOING TO BE HELPFUL AND THEN
PROCEED FROM THERE BUT FOR NOW
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
ANY GEORGE OF THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION WE REALLY
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
STAFF AND SPONSOR AND THE AUTHOR
ON THIS BILL -- WE HAVE SIMILAR
CONCERNS TO SEE SACK AND WE
WANTED ALSO WOULD SAY THAT THE
AND REPORT WAS NOT MEANT TO BE
LIKE A MINI HOUSING ELEMENT BUT
THAT'S WAY IT'S GETTING TO BE.
AND WE REALLY LIKE TO STEP BACK
LOOK AT ALL OF THE PAGES AND
PAGES OF ANALYSIS AND
REQUIREMENTS NOW.
AND DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE EVEN HELPFUL AND THEN
FIGURE OUT THE FORMAT THAT WOULD
BE EASILY ASSESSABLE BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S THINGS IN THERE
NOW.
THAT REALLY ARE NOT PROVIDING
ANY INFORMATION TO ANYBODY BUT
IT'S TAKING A LOT OF STAFF TIME --
SO WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE STAFF -- AND THE
SPONSORS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS TO SEE IF WE CAN DO THAT
EXERCISING CAM.
ON A VALENTINE.
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED FOR ALL THE REASONS
ENUMERATED BY MY COLLEAGUES
APPRECIATE THE WORK TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR GOOD AFTERNOON
THREE ZERO COUNTY REPRESENTS OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO POSE LAST MINUTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE XIN OPPOSITION.
THIRTY NINE WILL BRING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE COLORS OF ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AND MORE
LOOK.
IT'S MISTER JR A SERMON GRAYSON
AYE AYE.
I FORGET I SEE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I SEE THE VISION.
MOSTLY -- BUT I SEE LIKE MAYBE
ONE CITY PREPARES IT AND YOU
LEASE HAVE A TEMPLATE OR MODEL
AND THEN OTHERS COULD FOLLOW.
OR DO YOU HAVE A TEMPLATE THAT
YOU HAVE ALREADY.
SORT OF IN MIND.
I I I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
CURRENTLY AT THIS MOMENT A
TEMPLATE I THINK IT WAS ALL I
THINK WAS EXPECTED TO BE IN
PARTNERSHIP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
WITH EACH CD.
COMING UP WITH SOME TYPE OF
UNIFORMITY OF OF THE WAY DATA IS --
PUSHED OUT OR A RECEIVED FROM A
CD SO -- WITH THAT I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA AND A
SUGGESTION THAT WE WOULDFORWARD
TO EIGHT CD AS THEY REACH OUT TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO COLLECT
DATA.
AND THEN I I JUST GOING TO SOME
OF THE DATA YOU WANT --
COMPLETED APPLICATIONS PERMITTED
UNITS.
AND CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY
WHICH IS ALL AYE DADDY A MEASURE
THAT SHOULDN'T BE TOO DIFFICULT
THAT THAT'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
THE DATA WERE ASKING FOR ALREADY
EXIST ON A LOCAL LEVEL -- IT'S
JUST SCATTERED AND ALL WE'RE
ASKING FOR THEM TO DO IS TAKE
MUCH OF THE DATA AND PUT IT INTO
A BUCKET AND FORWARDED TO EIGHT
CD SO IT'S IT'S REALLY ABOUT.
JUST GATHERING IT AND FORWARDING
IT AND THEN IT SAYS.
AS WELL AS PROJECTS SPECIFIC
DATA WHAT DOES THAT MEAN -- THAT
CAN GET INTO -- US WELL SPECIFIC
SUCH AS NUMBER OF UNITS -- OF A
PROJECT AND THERE ARE DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS WHETHER IT BE AN
INCLUSIONARY PROJECT YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT -- ITEMS THAT THE CITY
WAS ACTUALLY PLACING ON THAT
PROJECT TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD SO YOU'RE BUILDING A
HUNDRED UNIT APARTMENT BUILDING
AND FIRING YOU'RE PRODUCING HOW
MANY SQUARE FEET OR BUT TO ME I
HAVE A LESSER BUT IT COULD BE --
IN FILLED IT COULDBE EITHER A
MINISTERIAL APPROVAL IT COULD BE --
WHETHER REQUIRING INCLUSIONARY --
JUST DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE
WOULD PUT ON THERE MAY BE SOME
PROJECTS REQUIRE COMMUNITY
BENEFIT.
IN ORDER TO GET THAT THROUGH TO
AN APPROVAL PROCESS.
WHATEVER.
WHATEVER ATTACHMENTS THE BECOME
WEIGHTS -- WHAT TO MILLENNIAL
GONNA DO WITH THAT INFORMATION?
TALK A LOT ABOUT IT.
I DOUBT IT.
HELP ME OUT I'M.
NOT A MILLENNIAL ANY PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
THINKING I'D SPEAKING TO THE
MILLENNIAL GENERATION -- YOU
KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT HAS US REALLY EXCITED ABOUT
THIS IS THAT.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE MORE DATA
ON THE STATE'S EIGHTY YOU AND JD
YOU LAWS AND THAT WILL ALLOW US
AS ADVOCATES TO HELP OUR CITIES.
MAKE THEIR PROGRAMS THEIR LOCAL
ORDINANCES MORE EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE WE CAN SEE BETTER WHERE.
THE PROGRAM'S WORKING OR MAYBE
NOT WORKING AND HELP POTENTIALLY
IDENTIFY BARRIERS SO THAT I
THINK THE STATE LEVEL TO THAT
DATA CAN BE VERY USEFUL FOR
IMPROVING THE STATE'S -- STREAM
MY MINISTERIAL EIGHTY YOU ANGIE
EIGHTY YOU ORDINANCES IN THE
FUTURE THAT'S A OBVIOUSLY VERY
HOT TOPIC THIS YEAR -- BUT GOING
FORWARD THIS WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER -- BUT BETTER DETERMINE
IF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE SUCCESSFUL
SO THEN YOU'RE KIND OF HOPING TO
SEE SOME TRENDS OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS BECAUSE A WHEN YOU'RE
REPORT.
THAT DATA IS WOULD BE KINDA
USELESS IF IT DIDN'T HAVE ANY
RELATION TO HOW MANY EIGHTY USE
YOU DID LAST YEAR OR HOW MANY
YOU ARE.
PROJECTED TO TO BUILD THIS YEAR
THAT'S THAT'S RIGHT WILL AT THE
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS START
COLLECTING THAT DATA HOPEFULLY.
AND AND HOPEFULLY DETERMINE SOME
OF THOSE TRENDS THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SO YET MAYBE NOT
NEXT YEAR BUT IN THE FUTURE YES
THE ONES THAT EXCITE YOU -- I I
I WILL PLEAD THE FIFTH ON THAT
ONE BUT I THINK MOSTLY IT'S A
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU USE THE
WORD SO I I I I THINK -- IN
THESE ARE ARE MAYBE TO ENGAGE
BUT VERY ENGAGED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL ON THESE TYPES OF THINGS
AND ARE VERY INTERESTED MAKING
SURE THEIR LOCAL PROGRAMS ARE
EFFECTIVE.
SO IF IF IF YOU PURCHASE TAKING
DATA.
AND AND JUST.
CONSOLIDATING IT FOR EASE OF
ACCESS.
TASK BUT IF IF IT'S A LOT A MAKE
WORK THEN I'M NOT EXCITED ABOUT
PUTTING THAT ON TO A CITY OR
COUNTY SO.
SO HELP ME OUT -- WE SHOULD DO
I'M LOOKING AT IT A LANGUAGE X.
I. B. R. L. A STANDARD.
WHICH WE KNOW YOU'VE PUT THE
DATA IN ONCE IN AWHILE YOU CAN
PROPAGATE EVERY EVERY REPORT YOU
WANT TO YOU ONLY HAVE TO PAY FOR
IT ONCE.
THEN I WOULDN'T MIND THISBUT
THAT ISN'T IN A PLACE YET I'M
TRYING.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO I HELP THE
PUBLIC BUT NOT.
YOU KNOW BOGGED DOWN.
YOU KNOW OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE ENJOYING A TWENTY ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS
THEY'RE ACTUALLY.
LAYING OFF POLICE OFFICERS TO
MAKE THEIR BUDGETS WORKS RIGHT I
WANT TO BE CAREFUL SO TO STRIKE
A GOOD BALANCE AND HAVING SERVED
LOCALLY -- CENTER AYE AYE I AM
VERY SENSITIVE TO MAKING SURE
THAT -- WE DON'T PUT MORE ON TO
CITIES AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THEN WHAT IS NEEDED HOWEVER --
AS YOU FOR MULTIPLE TIMES OVER
OVER WE ARE IN A HOUSING CRISIS.
I WOULD DOES SAY IT'S VERY
POSSIBLE POSSIBLE TO BELIEVE
THAT WITH MUCH OF THE DATA THAT
WE'RE ASKING OR DATA THAT WE'RE
ASKING.
FOR HAD WE HAD IT.
A WHILE BACK AT LEAST A DECADE
AGO I'M NOT SAYING IT WOULD HAVE
ELIMINATED THIS CRISIS BUT IT
SURE WOULD HAVE ALLOWED US TO BE
A LOT MORE PREPARED. FOR THE
DIRECTION WE WERE GOING AND
POSSIBLY TURN THE SHIP BEFORE IT
BECAME A CRISIS.
SO A LOT OF THE STATE AGAIN IF
THE CITY IS NOT COLLECTING IT
THAT COULD POSSIBLY A TRIBUTE TO
WHY THERE IS A SITUATION OR
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE'S NON
PRODUCTIVITY.
BUT IF THE DATA IS THERE I'M
SURE IT'S ABLE TO BE USED TO BE
ABLE TO STREAMLINE PROCESSES. TO
BE ABLE -- TO ADMIN IS -- DO
MINISTER APPROVALS ON CERTAIN
PROJECTS AND THEN ALLOW OTHER
PROJECTS THAT DEFINITELY NEED TO
GO THROUGH A DIFFERENT PROCESS --
ALLOW THE FLEXIBILITY OF THE
CITY TO DO THAT BUT TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE DATA THAT DATA IS
THERE IN MOST CASES ALREADY SO
IF I GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
MAYBE YOU COULD HELP ME.
IF MARIN COUNTY WOULD HAVE
ADOPTED THIS TEN YEARS AGO IT
WOULD HAVE HOW MANY MORE UNITS.
I AM NOT SURE IF I CAN QUANTIFY
THAT FROM THIS PODIUM RIGHT NOW
APOLOGIZE FOR THROWING THAT AT
YOU BUT I'M JUST.
TRY TO UNDERSTAND THE POINT
YOU'RE MAKING OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
AND I THINK IT'S A A A A
TEMPLATE.
OR SOMETHING ALONG THAT LINE TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO REPORT DATA IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE VERY VERY
OPEN.
TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS AS THE
BILL WOULD MOVE FORWARD IF IT
WAS TO DO SO.
I WAS TO START.
THIS ORDER AFTER THAT THAT WHAT
WE HAVE FOUND THE PAST IS THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE MORE DATA FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN AFTER SB THIRTY
FIVE OR STREAMLINING BILL PASSED.
IN THE CITY RELEASED THE DATA
THAT 97% CITIES WERE NOT MEETING
THEIR LOW INCOME.
RENO GOALS AND TWO THIRDS WERE
NOT MANY ANY INCOME CORRECT.
THAT CREATES ITS OWN MOMENTUM IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE HAVING THEIR
EYES OPENED TO WHAT'S REALLY
GOING ON SO IT DOESN'T ATTER BY
ITSELF OBVIOUSLY BUT IT DOES.
CREATE POLITICAL MOMENTUM FOR
CHANGE.
I CENTER DRIVE SEVEN CENTER WHAT
COUNTS.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A MEMBER GRAYSON AYE I DO HAVE.
RELATED QUESTION TO WHAT HAS
JUST BEEN SAID.
AND THAT IS THAT -- THERE ARE AT
LEAST FIVE TOTAL BILLS FOR OTHER
BILLS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH.
DATA COLLECTION -- AND THE SO
WHILE ON THE ONE HAND THERE ARE
BILLS THAT WE ARE HEARING IN
VOTING ON THAT CUT OUT THE STEPS.
IN THE PROCESS SO WE CAN MAKE
SURE WE ACTUALLY FOCUS ON THE
BUILDING AND MAKING IT EASIER --
SO I GUESS MY CONCERN IS HOW DO
WE MAKE SURE OUR FOCUS IN OUR
RESOURCES.
DON'T GET SO CAUGHT UP ON THE
INFORMATION SIDE AND I AGREE I
UNDERSTAND THE POWER OF
INFORMATION BUT HOW DO WE DEAL
WITH FIVE DIFFERENT.
BILLS.
THAT.
IS RELATED THEY'RE NOT
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT SUBJECTS
AND MAYBE DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER
TO THAT BUT I'M I'M CONCERNED
ALL FIVE BILLS GET PAST.
AND SIGNED AND THEN.
THAT'S FIVE DIFFERENT.
WAYS OF COLLECTING THAT DATA --
AND I JUST THINK WE NEED TO BE
MUCH MORE.
HILL FRUGAL ABOUT OUR RESOURCES
AND OUR FOCUS -- BECAUSE WE'RE
CUTTING OUT OTHER STEPS BECAUSE
WE SAY IT'S TOO BURDENSOME I
MEAN WE'RE EVEN SACRIFICING
ELEMENTS OF SEQUEL -- SO I JUST
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT OR MAKE
A SUGGESTION -- SUPPORT OF BUT
I'M CONCERNED THAT ADDRESS A
THANK YOU FOR EXPRESSING THEIR
CONCERN AND WE DID LOOK AT THAT
AND WE ARE AWARE OF THE OTHER
BILLS -- HOWEVER WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE OTHER BILLS AS AS WELL
INTENDED IN AS GOOD AS THEY ARE
AND THEY SORT OF AN INCREDIBLE
PURPOSE FOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
THEY'RE VERY SPECIFIED TO THE
DATA COLLECTION THAT THEY ARE
CALLING FOR FOR INSTANCE A BILL
THAT'S THIS VERY SPECIFIC AND
NARROW TO JUST FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
AND THAT'S THE DATA THE
COLLECTING IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE WE ARE COLLECTING A BROAD
ACROSS THE BOARD THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS FAR AS HOUSING AND HOW IT'S
BEING APPROVED ON A CITY LEVEL
OR A COUNTY LEVEL -- SO IT
COVERS THE WHOLE SPECTRUM HI I
AM VERY SENSITIVE -- TO CENTERED
MORE LOCK AND WHAT HE HAD
SUGGESTED ABOUT TRYING TO GATHER
THE DATA AND WHAT OKAY.
WELL -- AS FAR AS GATHERING THAT
I'M I APPRECIATE THAT IS ALL BUT
GATHERING DATA IN A WAY THAT WE
CAN -- AGGREGATE IT AND BE ABLE
TO DISSEMINATE IN A PRODUCTIVE
WAY RATHER THAN JUST KEEPING
PEOPLE BUSY AND CREATING MORE
WEIGHT AND HEAVY.
HEAVY LOAD AND IF I MAY KNOW WE
ARE AWARE THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE DATA BILLS CAN SOME
OVERLAP AND WE'VE COMMITTED
WE'VE ALERTED ALL THE AUTHORS
THAT OVER THE SUMMER -- WE
INTEND.
TO TRY TO WORK WITH ALL THE
RELEVANT COMMITTEES TO TRY
MISSION ARE HARMONIZED AND THEY
COMPLEMENT EACH OTHER AND DON'T
CREE DUPLICATION.
SIMILAR TO THE E. D. U.
SITUATION THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
EIGHTY YOU BILLS.
I THINK WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
HARMONIZING THEM BEFORE
APPROPRIATIONS AND I'M READY TO
SING HARMONY.
AND I I NEED TO RUN TO VOTE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY IN NUMBERS AND
SYMBOLS ASSEMBLY SO I AM GOING
TO HAND THE GAVEL TO SENATOR
BATES IF SHE'S GOING TO TAKE IT --
AND I WILL RETURN TO THANK YOU.
SENDER ACOSTA.
I GUESS THAT OUR STAFF REPORT.
SAYS THE YEARS IS THE BIGGEST
AND THE **** FROM THE MOST DATA
SO THERE'S THERE'S THAT THE PUT
IN IS FOR TALKING WITH THE OTHER
FOUR AUTHORS ON THE COLLECTION-DATA BUT I WANTED TO FOCUS ON
THE TOWARDS THE END OF THE STAFF
REPORT.
WE GOT.
TALKING ABOUT RESOURCES EIGHT C.
D. N. HOUSING COMMUNITY FELLMAN
HASN'T EVEN HIRED THE PEOPLE
THAT THEY NEED TO HIRE TO WORK
ON THE STREAMLINING AND THE LAND
USE MEASURES IN THIS SEPT
FIFTEEN BILLS WE PASS. TWO YEARS
AGO.
SO WOULD.
IT NOW WITH.
I'VE HEARD TESTIMONY WE WANT
DATA DAT IS GOOD I GOT ALL THAT
BOTH BUT HOW DO YOU RECONCILE.
THE WORKLOAD THAT AT T..
IS PUTTING ON BECAUSE YOU'RE ONE
OF FIVE DATA BILLS.
SO BACK -- TO MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS I'VE BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH A BROAD RANGE OF HOUSING
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING PLANNING
STAFF ADVOCATES DEVELOPERS
RESEARCHERS REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS.
THE BILL'S CURRENT DATA
REQUIREMENTS OF THOSE WHICH
EMERGED FROM STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT AS HAVING THE
STRONGEST JUSTIFICATION THAT
ALSO INCLUDED AIDS EIGHT CITIES
INPUT AS TO WHAT THEY BELIEVE
WOULD BE IMPORTANT DATA.
A CD ALSO RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE CAPACITY A
SENSIBILITY COORDINATION AND
QUALITY OF THEIR DATA FUNCTIONS.
SO IS MY FACT IF I MAY QUOTE
THEM IN FACT -- TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE TWENTY D. REPORT
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING FUTURE THE
DEPARTMENT RECOMMENDED THAT THE
STATE IMPROVE DATA COLLECTION
TRANSPARENCY ANALYSIS AND
ANALYSIS RELATED TO REDUCING
HOUSING COST.
PER UNIT WHERE POSSIBLE IN STATE
HOUSING PROGRAMS SO THIS IS
STATED THAT THEY'RE PREPARED --
TO TAKE ON THAT THEY HAVE
LITERALLY ASK FOR AND ARE TAKING
THE MEASURES -- TO BE ABLE.
TO ACCOMMODATE -- THE REQUEST OF
THIS BILL YES FINGERS QUE OKAY.
I'M OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION I JUST NOW MAKE
A CLOSING COMMENT SINCE WE WON'T
FOR A LONG THINK QUESTIONING I
JUST LIKE THE THE B. I. AID.
TO GIVE US SOME COMFORT LEVEL
THAT THIS ISN'T ANOTHER FEE
THERE'S GOING TO HAVE TO GO ON
ARE THE COST TO HOUSING BECAUSE
THEY SEE THE WITH A REQUIREMENTS
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MORE ON
PERSONNEL YEARS ALL OF THAT
STARTS.
TO BE BUILT IN OUT LOCAL ARE
CERTAINLY AT STATE LEVEL.
COULD YOU GUYS ARE SUPPORTING
AND IT'S KINDA LIKE IS THIS
GOING TO BE ANOTHER.
INCREASE MINOR HOWEVER ON THE
CASA HOUSING.
THANK YOU SENATOR BATES THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD POINT THAT YOU BRING
FOR IT -- WE ARE VERY SENSITIVE
TO ANYTHING THAT INCREASES THE
COST OF HOUSING AND GENERALLY
ARE VERY OPPOSE.
AS FAR AS WE SEE IT THIS IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE A LOT OF
TIME ARE GUYS WHO ARE BUILDING
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THESE FEES
ARE GOING TO BE OR WHAT THEY
HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST BECAUSE
THERE'S N PLACE THAT THIS IS
BEING PUBLICLY DISCLOSED.
IT'S HAPPENING IN OUR GUYS PAID
THE PAID AT A LOCAL LEVEL
THERE'S NEGOTIATIONS A HAPPEN
BUT WHAT THIS WILL DO WITH THIS
BILL WILL DO IS ALLOW FOR THE
INFORMATION TO BE COLLATED AND
PUT INTO A CENTRAL REPOSITORY
FOR PEOPLE TO LOOK AT NOW.
SO **** WHEN THEY DO FUTURE
DEVELOPMENTS THEY CAN HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT THERE WAS
IN THE PAST THAT'S THE IDEA
THAT'S WHY WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IT MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
TRANSPARENT IN TERMS OF WHERE
YOU COULD REDUCE FEES.
RIGHT.
THE WAY WE DO HAVE A MOTION --
MADAM SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL -- YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THEIR FAMILY MEMBER
GRAYSON I RESPECTFULLY IT WILL
FIRST WHILE I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS.
ALL THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAME
TOGETHER TO HELP MAKE THIS
POSSIBLE AND I RISKS AND TO
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL.
AS OTHER MEMBERS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM SECRETARY IN COLORADO AND
THIS ISN'T ABLE FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOME OF THE GRAYSON
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMANDMENTS OF FINANCE SENATOR
WIENER.
MORROW BATES AYE BATES AYE
CAMARO DRAWS OKAY.
DRAWS A AYE MCGUIRE MORLOCK ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER UMBERG.
UNDER I AM A CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I FIVE ZERO THE FIVE
VOTES WOULD THROW OPEN FOR THOSE
WHO ARE HERE.
WHICH IS OUR NEXT.
WHO'S OUT THERE [inaudible]
MR. ONE SEVEN THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAO I BELIEVE YOUR BILL
IS NEXT.
NOW -- ASSEMBLY IN -- BILL ONE
SEVENTY THREE CRAFT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH ESTABLISHED A
TAX ABATEMENT PROGRAM CALLED.
REGISTER YOUR MOBILE HOME
CALIFORNIA.
IT IS A PROGRAM FOR MOBILE HOME
OWNERS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
TRANSFER TITLE OF THEIR HOMES.
INTO THEIR NAMES DUE TO TAX
DELINQUENCIES THAT WERE INCURRED
BY PRIOR OWNERS.
SINCE THE PROGRAM STARTED IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS HAVE SAVED.
OVER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE PROGRAM IS ON
SCHEDULE TO SAVE MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS. TWO MILLION DOLLARS
BY THE TIME IT SUNSETS ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN DESPITE THE
SUCCESS SO THERE ARE STILL TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS WHO
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM.
THISBILL AB ONE SEVENTY THREE
WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THE SUNSET
ON THE PROGRAM FOR ONE YEAR. TO
CONTINUE TO HELP ABOUT MOBILE
HOMEOWNERS SHOT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU A WITNESSES THAT ARE
HERE.
IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON I BROUGH
STANTON CORPORATE COUNSEL FOR
THE GOLDEN STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERS LEAGUE.
WHERE A FIFTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE
ACTUALLY YEAR OLD NONPROFIT
CORPORATION NOW REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS STATEWIDE
AND I'M HERE TO URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE?
THE ENACTMENT OF AB FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN HAS RESULTED IN THE CURE
OF DEFECTIVE TITLE FOR NEARLY
TWO THOUSAND MOBILE HOMEOWNERS.
BUT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF MOBILE
HOMES ARE STILL NOT PROPERLY
TITLED IN THE NAME OF THEIR
OWNERS AND WE DO NEED TO EXTEND
THIS VALUABLE PROGRAM.
THE PROBLEM IS CAUSED BY NO ES
SCREWS BEING USED SOMETIMES NO
PROPER TRANSFER OF TITLE THERE
FOR CURRYING -- STILL OUT OF
BUSINESS LENDERS WHO CAN'T BE
REMOVED FROM TITLE.
OR PARKS SALES PARK OWNER SALES
OF HOMES WITH BAD TITLE FOR THAT
THIS IS THE REQUIREMENTS OF
TRANSFERRED JUST NOT FOLLOWED.
AS A RESULT WE HAVE HOMEOWNERS A
RISK OF LOSING THEIR HOMES IF
THE PARK OWNER SITES VIOLATION
OF RULES FOR HAVING TITLE IN NOT
HAVING TITLE IN THEIR NAMES.
WE HAVE HOMEOWNERS WHO CAN'T GET
LOANS ARE ACCESS HOME EQUITY AND
BUILDING PERMITS FROM THE STATE.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TWO WAYS
OF TITLING A REGISTERING HOMES
ONE IS I. L. T. THEIN LIEU OF
TAX WHICH IS PAID TO H. CD.
THE OTHER IS L. P. T. WHICH IS
LOCAL PROPERTY TAX PAID TO
COUNTY TAX COLLECTOR'S.
THERE'S AT LEAST A FIFTY FIFTY
SPLIT BUT THE L. P. T..
PROPERTY TAX IS BECOMING MORE --
NUMEROUS BECAUSE A NEW HOMES ARE
AUTOMATICALLY L. P. T..
AND HOMES CAN ALSO BE
TRANSFERRED TO A P. T. TO AVOID
SALES USE TAX.
ALTHOUGH THE PENETRATION OF THE
PROGRAM HASN'T BEEN AS GOOD AS
WE DESIRE IN GSM WELL IN OUR
SISTER OF FIVE OH ONE C. THREE
ARE VERY COMMITTED -- TO BETTER
OUT REGION EDUCATION ESPECIALLY
TO HISPANIC AND VIETNAMESE
HOMEOWNERS.
WHO CAN BE VERY WARY AND
DISTRUSTING OF ANY KIND OF
GOVERNMENT -- OR ANYTHING
RELATED TO GOVERNMENT.
BUT WE DO HAVE STATISTICS AS OF
MARCH SHOWING -- ALMOST TWO
THOUSAND COMPLETED APPLICATIONS.
AND I WOULD NOTE THAT ALTHOUGH
THE L. P. T. COUNTY APPLICATIONS
ARE FEWER.
THERE WAS A TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY COMPLETED AS OF MARCH.
THE PERCENTAGE OF WAVES -- COSTS
AND AND TAXES WITH 62%.
SO KEEPING THE LOCAL PROPERTY
TAX UNITS AS PART OF THE PROCESS
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
AND NARROWING THE PROGRAM TO
REMOVE THEM AS THE OPPOSITION
HAD -- SUGGESTED WOULD TAKE AT
LEAST HALF OF THE POPULATION OUT
OF THE PROCESS -- I WOULD JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING SMALL IS NOT A
PRINCIPLE SIZE FROM EQUAL
PROTECTION OF THE STATE'S LAWS
AND POLICIES SO WE URGE AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
SECOND WHEN OF YES GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE IN SENATORS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ROGER JOHNSON ANIMAL
MOBILE HOMEOWNER WHO LIVES IN
LAKE VIEW VILLAGE IN CITRUS
HEIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GOLDEN
STATE MOBILE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION GSMA OIL.
REPRESENTING SENIORS VETERANS
IMMIGRANTS AND OTHER LOW.
MODERATE AND FIXED INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
WHO LIVE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE?
WE WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRAIL FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
IN AB ONE SEVEN THREE WILL HELP
MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS WHO WERE
TRYING TO TRANSFER.
TITLE IN THEIR NAME IN THE STATE
AND COUNTIES.
WHO CAN NOW UPDATE THEIR RECORDS
SO THAT ON COLLECTED TAXES AND
FEES CAN BE COLLECTED FROM THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ACTUALLY -- THEM.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR-SUPPORT IN THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE OTHERS HERE I IN
SUPPORT THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
IF NOT OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CAROLING BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURER'S AND TAX COLLECTORS --
WHEN THE ORIGINAL BILL WAS PUT
THROUGH I HAVE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN WE SPENT AN
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME WITH
THE SPONSORS AT THAT TIME? TO
CRAFT LANGUAGE THAT WE THOUGHT
WOULD NARROWLY.
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE THAT DID NOT KNOW HOW TO
PROCESS THEIR PAPERWORK IN THE
PURCHASE THE HOME.
BUT WE HAD A LOT OF CONCERNS
ABOUT A HOMES I'M MORE THAN ONE
HOME BEING TAKEN TO THE PROCESS
BY A SINGLE OWNER.
SINCE THAT BILL WAS PASSED
WITHOUT OUR SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
WE HAVE LEARNED IN THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS WHEN AB ONE
SENATORS INTRODUCED THAT THAT A
PARK HONOR IN KERN COUNTY HAS
TAKEN THIRTY HOMES THROUGH THE
PROCESSES IN WHAT'S CALLED THE
WAREHOUSE MEANS LEANS FAIL.
SO ESSENTIALLY ABANDONED HOMES
ARE SOLD THROUGH AN AUCTION FOR
A VERY LITTLE AMOUNT OF MONEY
AND THEN THE PARK HONOR OBTAINS
OWNERSHIP OF THAT HOME.
AND GETS TO WIPE AWAY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
PROPERTY TAXES THAT ARE LOW --
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WE HAVE ASKED THE AUTHOR TO
CONSIDER TAILORING THE BILL TO
PROHIBIT THE USE OF OUR HUSBANDS
LEANS.
AS IN AS IN THE SALE IF YOU'VE
GONE THROUGH THAT PROCESS SINCE
THE ENACTMENT OF THE LEGISLATION
THAT YOU WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
TO TAKE THE HOME THROUGH.
THE AMNESTY PROGRAM THAT HAS NOT
BEEN ACCEPTED WERE CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL THAT WAS INITIALLY
PASSED BY THIS LEGISLATURE WAS
INTENDED TO HELP PEOPLE.
WHO DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO PROCESS
PAPERWORK I PROMISE YOU THE PARK
OWNERS KNOW WHAT PAPERWORK NEEDS
TO BE DONE?
BUT THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
USING IT AND FOR THE TWO HUNDRED
OR SO THAT WE'VE SEEN AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL THIRTY IN ONE
COUNTY IS DONE BY THE PARK OWNER.
UP IN SUTTER COUNTY.
ALL THREE ONE PARK HONOR SO
WE'RE ASKING FOR YOU.
TO I TAKE A HOLISTIC LOOK AT THE
PROBLEM.
PARK OWNERS DON'T KNOW WHICH
HOMES ARE UP TO DATE AND WHICH
AREN'T BECAUSE WE GAVE AWAY THE
STICKER PROGRAM IS TO HAVE SO
PARK OWNERS DON'T KNOW WHO'S UP
TODAY AND HE'S NOT.
A WE THINK THERE ARE SYSTEMIC
SOLUTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
BROUGHT TO THIS IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BE GIVING AWAY COUNTY TAX
DOLLARS SO WE'RE OPPOSE UNLESS
THE BILL AS AMENDED TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OTHER SIDE IN OPPOSITION THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
SEEN ON THE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I ANY QUESTIONS.
YES SENATOR ROBB.
THANK CENTER UP PERHAPS OF IF
THE AUTHOR COULD RESPOND TO THE
COMMENTS FROM THE COUNTY TAX
COLLECTOR'S I MEAN OBVIOUSLY.
AS A STATE.
WE HAVE WE HAVE HAD SOME IMPACT
ON COUNTY FINANCES BY VIRTUE OF
THE ACTIONS THAT WE'VE TAKEN UP
HERE AND SOME OTHER THINGS THAT
HAVE OCCURRED.
OUTSIDE OF OUR CONTROL AND SO
I'M STE.
WELL I'M SENSITIVE TO INDIVIDUAL.
HOMEOWNERS I AM ALSO SENSITIVE
TO THE COUNTY CONCERNS ABOUT
[inaudible]
ALLOWING -- INSTITUTIONAL
OPERATORS.
TO IN THIS CASE NOT GAME THE
SYSTEM BUT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE DONE FOR
THEIR OWN IT -- ECONOMIC
ADVANTAGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
QUESTION.
I HAVE NO ISSUES -- ABOUT BOB
PARK OWNERS SELL REALLY USING
THE PROGRAM PER SE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IF THEY ARE INDEED.
OWNERS OF THE UNITS I THINK THE
FOCUS OF THE BILL AND ALSO THIS
PARTICULAR. ONE SEVENTY THREE IS
ON ARE MAKING SURE THAT THESE
UNITS ARE PROPERLY TITLE.
ON YOU KNOW I THINK IN MANY
INSTANCES.
THE UNITS THAT WERE TALKING
ABOUT ARE IN FACT OWNED BY THE
PARK OWNERS. TO OUR YOU KNOW
WHETHER THEY HAVE BEEN ABANDONED
UNITS OR OTHERWISE STATE
NEVERTHELESS THEY STILL ONLY
UNITS AND AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE FOCUS OUGHT TO BE.
A WE WANT TO MAKE SURE EACH ONE
OF THESE UNITS IS PROPERLY
TITLES SO THAT THEY COULD BE
TRANSFERRED ALL LEGALLY
OTHERWISE AS WE HEARD FROM THE
WITNESS.
YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL KINDS OF
ISSUES THAT COULD ARISE FROM MOM
ALL TITLES THAT HAVE CLOUT OF
FOR EXAMPLE THEY GET EVICTED
THEY THEY CAN'T PAY -- TO THEY
CAN'T.
DO ANYTHING WITH IT THEY CAN'T
TRANSFER SO THAT'S THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH AND SO SO THE FOCUS
OUGHT TO BE ON THAT YOU KNOW
THESE UNITS SAW PROPERLY TITLE.
ARE LEGALLY SO THAT THEY COULD
BE TRANSFERRED.
SO I WOULD I WOULD ASSUME A PARK
OWNERS IT HAS ABANDONED --
MOBILE HOMES AND MANUFACTURED
HOMES IN THE PARK AS AN
INCENTIVE.
TO TAKE CARE OF THEM DEAL WITH
THEM APPROPRIATELY BUT MAY NOT
NECESSARILY NEED A PROPERTY TAX --
WE WERE EXEMPTION IN ORDER TO DO
SO I NOTICES BILLS DOUBLE
REFERRED SO PERHAPS OF US
SUPPORTED TODAY OBVIOUSLY
PERHAPS YOU COULD CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE PROCESS I'LL BE HAPPY.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS THEM NOW.
YOU MAY CLOSE SOMEWHERE
CHALLENGE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUT WE DO I I THOUGHT CENTERS
RUSTIN SHOULD MOVE IT DID YOU
HAVE IT.
YES WE DID HAVE A MOTION OKAY.
SENATE CHECK IN.
THIS IS A LEVEL ONE SEVENTY
THREE BY SOMEONE NUMBER CHAU
MOTIONS YOU PASSING REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE SENATOR WINNER.
MORRELL BATES [inaudible]
CARILLO DORADO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE.
MORE LUCK.
MORE LIKE NO ROUGH.
ROUGH I SKINNER UMBERG WHAT
CASKEY [inaudible]
IT'S WONDERFUL.
IT HELPSWHEN VOTE BUT WE HAVE
SEVERAL MEMBERS ABSENT SO WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE NEXT [inaudible]
WHEN?
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF GARCIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES.
THE BILL ESTABLISHES AB THREE
SIX ESTABLISHES THE AGRICULTURE
WORKING POOR ENERGY EFFICIENT
HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND REQUIRES THAT THE PROGRAM BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT.
PROGRAM FOCUS SHOULD BE
WEATHER'S ATION REPLACEMENT OF
ENERGY.
EFFICIENT APPLIANCES REPLACEMENT
OF LIGHTING SUCH AS SALLY DE.
ESCALATION OF FOUR WILL TASTE
SOLAR PANELS AND INSTALLATION OF
BATTERY BACKUPS -- THIS BILL'S
BEEN BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE-BEFORE AB HAPPY TO ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS MICHAEL SATURDAY WITH
LA BUT AT THE WAS HERE ANSWERING
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS SPENT PLANTS
FOR RIVAL.
THIS IS AB.
THREE EIGHTY SIX WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OKAY -- THE HONORABLE MEMBERS --
MY NAME IS MICHAEL IS OUR AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LOCAL BUT IF YOU A COMPASS
ENOUGH.
WE ARE AN ASSOCIATION OF FIVE A
MEMBER AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
DESIGNATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS FARM WORKER
ORGANIZATIONS.
PROVIDING COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
TO THE FARM WORKER POPULATION OF
A STATE.
EDUCATION WORKFORCE TRAINING JOB
PLACEMENT.
WE SERVE OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE
ACROSS THE STATE IN FOR OVER
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND ARE
FARMWORKERS.
WE ARE LOCATED IN EIGHTY TWO
SERVICE CENTERS THROUGHOUT.
THIRTY FOUR OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AGRICULTURAL
COUNTIES OF THE STATE.
THERE ARE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARMWORKERS.
IN ABOUT 18% OF THEM OWN HOME --
AND WE FEEL.
THERE THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD PROGRAMS.
OF THIS NATURE BUT THEY HAVE
BEEN INCREDIBLY CHALLENGE TO
REACH THE FARM WORKERS
COMMUNITIES AND DRAW FARMWORKERS
THEMSELVES.
SO I THINK THIS LEGISLATION THE
LEGISLATION WILL ENSURE THE
FARMWORKERS HOLES WILL RECEIVE
EXTENSIVE WEATHERIZATION.
SOLAR PANELS IN ADDITION TO
BATTERY BACKUPS.
THIS PROGRAM.
WILL GREATLY REDUCE THE CARBON
PRINT.
OF THE FARM WORKER POPULATION
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY.
HEWILL DO SOMETHING ELSE IT
WILL RAISE THEIR DISPOSABLE
INCOME.
WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLE BENEFIT
TO A FARM WORKER POPULATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF THE HUNDRED
VALLEYS ON BEHALF OF COMMUTERS
WHO CLOSE BY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION MANY OF
THEIR ME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
WE DO HAVE A MOTION ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
AND CHIRLA WHAT IS THE FUNDING
SOURCE.
AT THE FUNDING SOURCES THE LG G..
JERRY FUNDS.
AND WHERE THEY COME FROM.
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA OR ANALYSIS SAYS
THAT THIS IS DUPLICATIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT -- ALREADY PROVIDING
SOME WEATHERIZATION COULD YOU
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON THAT AND
ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT AS A
WITNESS HAS HIGHLIGHTED HAVE
BEEN SOME CHALLENGES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ROLLING THIS MONEY
OUT.
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED TO THE
FARM WORKER POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA -- THIS SPECIFICALLY
DIRECTS THEM TO FOCUS ON THIS
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
POPULATION 80% ARE HOMEOWNERS --
TO BE PART OF CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES IN REDUCING EMISSIONS
AS WELL AS INSURING THAT IS DAY
WITNESS SAID HAVE DISPOSABLE
INCOME TO SPEND ON OUR
FARMWORKERS COMMUNITIES.
SO IT'S THE IT'S A BROADER GROUP
TENURE EXPANDING THE GROUP IT'S
ACTUALLY GIVING THAT MUCH MORE A
DIRECTIVE -- IN -- CHALLENGE TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE BEING SPENT ON
THE SPECIFIC POPULATION OKAY.
THERE ARE NO MINIMUM ON
SECRETARY YOU WANT TO CALL THE
ROLE WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
THIS IS A NUMBER THIRTY SIX BY
SOME MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
MOTIONS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY UTILITIES
COMMUNICATIONS.
CENTER WIENER.
MORROW BATES AYE BATES AYE
CAMARO DORADO.
MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
ROUGH ROUGH I SKINNER.
UMBERG CASKEY.
THAT HAS TO VOTE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
[inaudible]
THEN.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
AUTHORS RIGHT NOW.
WAITING FOR AUTHORS AND WAITING
FOR MEMBERS.
LOT OF COMMITTEES GOING ON AT
THE MOMENT SO WE HAVE A FEW
CONFLICTS.
JUST TAKE A THREE MINUTE BREAK
AND SEE WHO SHOWS UP
-- SUMMER
STONE WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB [inaudible]
FOR ELEVEN THANK YOU.
THE CHAIR AND SENATORS.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
BUT WE'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE.
THIS IS A REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
BILL FOR THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
THE SANTA CRUZ.
HAS A VERY GOOD TRACK RECORD OF
ADDRESSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NEEDS TO THE EXCEPT THAT THEY
CAN AFFORD TO DO THAT AND AND
LEVERAGE THEIR REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY WHEN IT EXISTED.
AS IT WRAPPED UP IN THE CITY DID
EVERYTHING IT NEEDED TO DO
WRAPPING UP THE REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCY IT HAS ABOUT NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN OUTSTANDING
BONDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY SITTING
THERE.
UNDER THE THE WRAP UP THAT COULD
BE.
THAT MONEY CAN BE MUCH BETTER
USE RIGHT NOWTHEY HVE EXISTING
PROJECTS THAT THIS MONEY.
HE SHOULD BE FREED UP WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL IS ASKING THAT WE
DO BE APPLIED TO THE EXISTING
READY TO GO PROJECTS IN THE CITY
OF SANTA CRUZ.
SO JUST TRY TO CHECK THIS MONEY
LUCIFER SERIOUS ABOUT ADDRESSING
FOR DOUBLE HOUSING AND WE HAVE
READY POTS OF MONEY THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR PROJECTS THAT ARE.
READY TO GO THIS IS THE BILL
THIS IS THE WAY TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS OR THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WE HAVE.
FROM THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ BODY
LIPSCOMB WHO WAS VERY INVOLVED
WAS THE DIRECTOR OF THE RDA
THEIR REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY THERE
AND HAS BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE --
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BONNIE LIPS
CAM DIRECTOR OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND HOUSING FOR THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ AND WITH ME
TODAY -- FROM SANTA CRUZ ARE
JESSICA TO WET AND JOE HALL.
MY BRIEF COMMENTS WILL TRY TO
CONVEY SOME OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CHALLENGES FACED BY OUR
COMMUNITY OUR PAST EFFORTS IN
THIS AREA FOR FOR DOUBLE HOUSING
AND HOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
QUICKLY IF A BEFORE ELEVEN IS
APPROVED. ONE OF THE KEY
POLICIES THE CITY ADOPTED
FOLLOWING THE NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE LOMA PRIETA EARTHQUAKE WAS
A HOUSING FOR STRATEGY WITH THE
FUNDING PROVIDED TO
REDEVELOPMENT SANTA CRUZ IS ABLE
TO FILL UP OVER TWELVE HUNDRED
UNITS.
OF AFFORDABLE BOTH WORK FORCE IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITY OF APPROXIMATELY AT
THE TIME BETWEEN FIFTY FIVE AND
NOW 650-00 PEOPLE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DISSOLUTION OF
ALREADY A IN TWENTY TWELVE IS
GREATLY ATTACK IMPACTED OUR
CITY'S ABILITY TO CREATE NEW
AFFORDABLE USER UNITS IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
SINCE THEN SANTA CRUZ HAS BEEN
CITED AS ONE OF THE LEAST
AFFORDABLE HOUSING MARKETS IN
THE NATION OUR TEACHERS ARE
PARTICULARLY BEING IMPACTED OUR
GROWING YOU SEE -- UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA CAMPUS IN NEARBY
SILICON VALLEY HAVE ADDITIONAL
INCREASE THE LOCAL HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY PRESSURE IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY MEDIAN
PRICE OF HOMES OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS AT THIS TIME.
WHAT IS ALSO UNIQUE ABOUT OUR
CITY IS IT WE STILL HAVE
AVAILABLE STAFF TO BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH THE
FUNDS PROVIDED THREE BEFORE HE
LEFT?
FOR ELEVEN AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PROJECTS LINED UP IN OUR
DOWNTOWN CORE AND WITH OUR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOULD BE A
BEFORE ELEVEN BE APPROVED
SPECIFICALLY IN OUR DOWNTOWN WE
HAVE A PROJECT THAT WILL CREATE
OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY VERY LOW TO
LOW.
UNITS -- INOUR DOWNTOWN CORE
WITH OUR LOCAL TRANSIT --
DISTRICT AS WELL AS SANTA CRUZ
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER AND D.
ENTERS CREATING LOW COST HEALTH
AND DENTAL CARE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES DISADVANTAGED YOUTH
AND WORKING FAMILIES -- WHAT WE
HOPE FROM EIGHTY FOUR ELEVEN IS
AT THE FUNDING RELEASE BY
APPROVAL OF THIS LEGISLATION
WILL ALLOW US TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THESE PROJECTS THROUGH THESE
PROJECTS WE WERE ABLE TO MEET
ARENA GOALS AND CONTINUE
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
OUR COMMUNITY?
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT
EIGHTY FOUR ELEVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
CASEY NUMBER ABOUT THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
OKAY WERE MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH
AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU MAY CLOSE.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY -- THIS
INJURIES AND I RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SAYS UNABLE FOR ELEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER MARK STONE MOTIONS TO
PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BATES.
CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRAWS A MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORLOCK.
ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
UMBERG CASKEY. THIRTY THREE ZERO
SHE CAN SEE WE HAVE A LITTLE AN
ABSENCE ISSUE TODAY SOME
COMPETING COMMITTEES THEY LIKE
THAT IT'S OF THEIR LIKE THAT SO
WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER -- OKAY NEXT --
YES SO IT'S A MEMBER RIGHT YES --
I JUST PRESENTED HER COMMITTEE
AND NOW WE CAN.
BY CATCHER -- ITEM SEVEN AB.
THREE OH SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I PRESENT TO YOU TODAY AB THREE
OH SEVEN A GRANT PROGRAM.
WHICH WOULD AWARD FUNDS TO NON
PROFITS OR CONTINUUM OF CARE
ADMINISTRATIVE ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS
THE HIGHEST RATE OF YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS IN THE NATION WITH
OVER FIFTY PORT 54% OF THE
NATION'S TOTAL NUMBER OF
HOMELESS YOUTH.
RESIDING RIGHT HERE ON
CALIFORNIA STREETS.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE WERE.
OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
UNACCOMPANIED HOMELESS YOUTH IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT A SAFE PLACE
TO CALL HOME.
AND IN ADDITIONAL ALMOST TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED PARENTING YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
ALONGSIDE THEIR CHILDREN.
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT YOUNG PEOPLE IN THESE
PREDICAMENTS IS WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE WITH ONLY TWENTY OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES HAVING DIRECT SERVICES
FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THREE EIGHTY
THREE OH SEVEN A GRANT PROGRAM
TO BE ADMINISTERED BY THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL.
WE WILL BE ABLE TO HELP SUPPORT
SUCCESSFUL LOCAL PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE APPROPRIATE AND
CULTURALLY INFORMED A WRAPAROUND
SERVICES.
ENHANCING EFFORTS AND
PARTNERSHIPS TO COMBAT YOUTH
HOMELESSNESS.
THERE'S SIMPLY NO REASON.
WHY THIS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY SHOULD HAVE A
HUGE POPULATION OF YOUTH LIVING
ON THE STREETS RATHER THAN
RECEIVING CRITICAL SERVICES?
WELL THE GOVERNOR HAS PROVIDED
SOME FUNDS TO COMBAT HOUSING
ISSUES ACROSS THE STATE IT
DEDICATED FUNDING SUPPORT
PARTICULARLY FOR YOU.
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IS
TRULY WHAT IS NEEDED.
WITH ME TODAY TO DISCUSS THIS
FURTHER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOU ARE JEVON
WILKES AND KIM LUIS.
HI M NAME IS YVONNE WORKS AND
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH.
NOW I WANT YOU ALL TO IMAGINE
WHAT IT WOULD FEEL LIKE TO
WONDER WEEKS OF SLEEPING ON THE
SIDEWALK ALL ALONG.
I DON'T HAVE TO IMAGINE.
THIS IS MY EXPERIENCE AT THE AGE
OF FOURTEEN YEARS OLD BECAUSE I
NO LONGER HAD A SAFE PLACE TO
LIVE.
WHAT UP TO OVERWHELMING AMOUNTS
OF ADVERSITY?
BEN HOLMES YOU COULD'VE BEEN
DETRIMENTAL HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
THE SUPPORT OF A SCHOOL
PSYCHIATRIST.
OR THE OPEN DOORS OF THE
HOMELESS YOUTH SHELTER BY THE
LOS ANGELES YOUTH NETWORK NOW
KNOWN AS YOU THE MERGING STRONG.
THERE I HAD SUPPORTIVE ADULTS
MENTORS.
ACCESS TO MENTAL AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE [inaudible]
FOOD [inaudible]
EDUCATION SUPPORT SHOWERS A BED
AND A ROOF OVER MY HEAD. ONE
WEEKS ON THE STREETS ALONE
HAVING TO FIND WAYS TO EAT STAY
CLEAN GO TO SCHOOL STAY SAFE.
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE AN
UNINTERRUPTED NIGHT.
OF SLEEP DURING THE THANKSGIVING
AND CHRISTMAS HOLIDAYS.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE EXPERIENCED
BY ANYONE ESPECIALLY OUR YOUTH
TODAY.
I'VE SEEN A TIME WHILE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
BADGE DROP IN SHELTERS.
AND YOUTH HOMELESS SHELTERS
DECREASE CAPACITY AND SOME EVEN
CLOSE ALL TOGETHER.
AND DESPAIR IT DISPARITIES AMONG
MY PEERS CONTINUE TO INCREASE.
TODAY I HOPE TO SEE A LIVE IN A
TIME WHERE YOU HOMELESSNESS IS
SHORT LIVED.
WHERE AND NOW RECURRING?
SO THAT THEY HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO REACH THEIR FULL POTENTIAL.
YOUR TIME IS APPRECIATED.
AND THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME
SHERRY SHARE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TRIBAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN LARA'S REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU AND
ONE OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS OF YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE NEED AN ARRAY
OF PROGRAMS.
ACROSS THE STATE AND IN ALL
COUNTIES SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO HEAR ABOUT THE STORIES.
AND THE EXPERIENCES THAT OF ON
JUST SHARED.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE
INTERVENE EARLY WE CAN AND AND
PREVENT YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
AND MAKE A SERIOUS DENT IN
ENDING OUR CHRONIC HOMELESS
NUMBERS.
IT'S NO SURPRISE TO ME AND THAT
THE NUMBER OF CHRONIC
HOMELESSNESS POPULATION HAS BEEN
GOING UP BECAUSE WE HAVE UNDER
INVESTED RESOURCES.
AS POPULATION FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS.
THE ONLY ONE TIME ONGOING
PROGRAM IS THAT -- YES AND HAS
LESS THAN TWO MILLION DOLLARS N
A ONE TIME ON AN ONGOING BASIS
TO SUPPORT FOR PROGRAMS AND FOR
COUNTIES.
THE ONLY OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
THROUGH THE FEDERAL RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH ACT WHICH
PROVIDES GRANTS OF NO MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND ANNUALLY.
SO TO ME IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT
ARE COUNTIES LACK RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT OUR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
AND SO IF WE CAN CREATE A GRANT
PROGRAM THAT'S WORKING IN
COLLABORATION UNDERNEATH THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL WE CAN REALLY
ENSURE THAT THAT YOUR INTENT OF
SB NINE ONE EIGHT THE HOMELESS
YOUTH ACT TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAN BE
MEANT. TO ENSURE THAT WE AND AND
REDUCE.
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS.
I'M WE'VE ONCE WE CREATE THE
GRANT PROGRAM WE CAN REALLY
WORKED ADVOCATE AND ENSURE THAT
THE ON GOING FUNDING IS
APPROPRIATED AND DEDICATED FOR
THIS AND IT ALSO CREATES A
STRUCTURE.
FOR THINGS OF THE MINISTRATION
COULD CONSIDER AND USE OF THE
PROP SIXTY FOUR FUNDS BECAUSE
THIS ALLIANCE WITH CLEARLY THE
YOUTH -- TREATMENT ACCOUNT WHEN
IT CALLED OUT SPECIFICALLY
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATION OUT REGION TREATMENT
OF HOMELESS AND OUT OF SCHOOL
YOUTH EXPERIENCING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
I JUST WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT IF WE INTERVENE ON DAY ONE
FOR OUR YOUTH.
AND WHERE WOULD WE BE TODAY.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PLEASE SAY
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
SAM DASH OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO SHARI'S RUN ON
BEHALF COUNTY BEAVER HELL
TRACTORS A STATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HANNAH BRAG SAID WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MALLORY SPOKE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
SO OBVIOUSLY SHAUN BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT.
MARCUS FEDEX AT THE DIRECTOR
MICHAEL BUT IF YOU AT COMPASS
UNITE AND SUPPORT.
KATHY VAN AUSTIN ON BEHALF OF
JOHN BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
I SING ON IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH -- CENTER
MORE LOOK.
Q. MATTER STRUCTURE I'M JUST.
CURIOUS ABOVE WHERE THE FUNDING
IS COMING FROM SO I'M HEARING
PROP SIXTY FOUR IN HEARING.
USE EDUCATION PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION TREATMENT ACCOUNT
AND GIFTS AND DONATIONS
[inaudible]
SO WE'RE WHERE IS THE MONEY
COMING FROM THE TO FUND THE
YOUTH EDUCATION.
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION ACCOUNT.
I WILL ASK OUR WITNESS TO
RESPOND TO THAT.
IF I MAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR I THINK THE
BILL IS DESIGNED TO SET UP THE
GRANT PROGRAM THEN WE CAN
ADVOCATE FOR AN APPROPRIATION
THE BUDGET NEXT YEAR AS WELL
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PUTS FORWARD OR
NOT -- WE'VE SEEN THIS HAPPEN
AND OTHER -- BILLS OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S BUT FORWARD AND
HAVE PASSED AND IMPLEMENTED AND
THEN BEEN ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY
SECURE THAT APPROPRIATION OUT
YEARS.
SO WE'RE JUST SETTING SOMETHING
UP WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
RESOURCES AT THIS TIME.
NOT ON GOING DEDICATED FOR THE
SPECIFIC PROGRAM IT'S JUST
MINISTERIAL.
NO HOPE FOR ANYTHING IT'S ALWAYS
SO ARE ASKED THERE'S GREAT HOPE.
THIS IS GREAT -- BUT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE SETTING UP THE POLICY
WE ARE.
MAKING THESE.
SB I'M IN FOR THE CURRENT YEAR
NOT.
FOR INDEFINITE POLICYMAKERS
WHERE WE'RE LETTING IT BE KNOWN
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS A
PRIORITY FOR US.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND OFFENDER
CABALLERO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE AT THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND ALSO FOR ON THE
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY.
MINE IS A TECHNICAL ISSUE AND
AND I'M I'M I'M.
I'M GONNA HAVE.
TO MENTION IT A NUMBER OF TIMES
TODAY BECAUSE THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT -- THAT START TO
BUILD -- UPON.
COUNCILS ARE COMMITTEES THAT
WERE SET UP TO DO SOME SOME --
SOME TECHNICAL WORK BUT REALLY
DON'T HAVE ANY -- EXPERIENCE IN
HANDLING GRANT -- APPLICATIONS
IN THE WHOLE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S REQUIRED TO DO REVIEWING
GRANTS -- AND HAVING COME FROM
THE ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE I'M
REALLY SENSITIVE TO THIS BECAUSE
WHEN YOU START BUILDING THE
BUREAUCRACY THEN YOU SPEND MORE
MONEY ON THE BUREAUCRACY THAN
YOU ACTUALLY SPENT.
ON GRANTS TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND SO THIS THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNCIL WAS SET UP
LAST YEAR.
AND AND AND THIS YEAR
EVERYBODY'S THROWING THEM A LOT
OF WORK FOR THEM TO DO AND I'M
JUST CONCERNED WITH GIVING THEM
UP AB FAB.
PROGRAM WHERE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER GRANT
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S A DIFFERENT.
IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT ON
ANIMAL AND THIS THIS IS LOCATED
IN AN AGENCY.
WHICH AT THE AGENCY LEVEL YOU
DON'T DO GRANTS GENERALLY AND SO
I'M JUST I'M A LITTLE BIT
WORRIED ABOUT IT.
FRANKLY I THINK IT GOES BETTER
AT EACH CD OR ANY OF THE HOUSING
AGENCIES THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE
WITH WITH -- CREATING THE
GUIDELINES FOR GRANT. FOR
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS
COMPETITIVE APPLICATIONS THAT
COME IN AND THEN -- FOR DOING
THE GRANT AWARDING AND THEN
MAKING SURE THAT THE AWARD DIS --
ACTUALLY DID WHAT THEY SAID THEY
WERE GOING TO DO AND THAT'S A
WHOLE INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY BUILT IN THAT.
IT'S REALLY DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
THIS AT FINANCING COUNCIL SO I
JUST PUT THAT OUT THERE MINUTES
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT WORK.
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT I JUST
THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S IN THE
WRONG PLACE SO -- A RESERVES THE
RIGHT TO A DIFFERENT DECISION ON
THE FLOOR BUT BUT I I JUST PUT
THAT OUT THERE FOR YOU SO THINK
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
IN MY RESPOND -- STRUCTURE.
WITHIN THE THE THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL IT DOES SPECIFICALLY
STATE THAT THE COUNCIL MAY ENTER
INTO AN INTRA INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT WITH ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT OR AGENCY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE GRANT
PROGRAM.
YOUR POINT IS VERY WELL TAKE AND
IF THEY ARE NOT PREPARED OR DO
NOT HAVE THE CAPACITY OF THE IT
DOES PROVIDE FOR THAT
POSSIBILITY.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
OKAY ROOM MOTION BY A CENTER
OUGHT TO TO THE CITIZENS ARE IN
AYE RECOMMENDATION ON WHAT THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING THIS ON
THIS IS IMPORTANT WORK -- WE'VE
I THINK IT'S BEEN A GROUP EFFORT%
FOR A FEW YEARS AND THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT STOP AND THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS.
OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE COMMENTS
FROM THE QUESTIONS I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE AS THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY INDICATE WHAT
ARE.
WHAT OUR PRIORITIES ARE WHAT THE
POLICY IS THAT WE WANT TO TAKE
FORWARD ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR HOMELESS YOUTH WE ALREADY
KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE?
THE THE ISSUE IN THE FUTURE.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOTION MOTION ROTH WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A MEMBER PHARAOH SEVEN
BY SOME OTHER AREAS MOTIONS TO
PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORALE.
BATES CABALLERO.
CAMARO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER UMBERG CASKEY.
FORTY THE VOTERS FOUR ZERO WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN -- FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE'RE HAVING
COMPETITION FOR WHO WILL ARRIVE
LAST AND WHEN THE MICHAEL I
ORDERED SOME.
WE'LL SEND WITH WHO HUSTLES AND
WHO DOESN'T -- THANK YOU AS A
MEMBER NEXT WE WILL GO -- CALL
UP THE SEVEN RETAIN FOR ITEM
SEVENTEEN A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX I'M AND AND I'M GOING TO
HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO CENTER
MORE LOG HAVE TO GO PRESENT A
BILL.
I DO JUST WANT TO KNOW --
SIMILAR TO THE DATE OF BILLS
FROM BEFORE AND EIGHTY YOU BILLS
FROM A FEW WEEKS AGO -- THERE
ARE MULTIPLE SURPLUS LAND BILLS --
WE'RE AWARE OF THIS AS ARE THE
OTHER RELEVANT COMMITTEES AND
WE'VE COMMITTED OVER THE COURSE
OF THE SUMMER TO WORKING TO MAKE
SURE WE HARMONIZE THEM INTO
THEIR COMPLEMENTARY -- SO
WITHOUT ALL HAND THEM -- GAVEL
TO CENTER MODOC.
THERE GOING TO SHOW A RETAINER
I'M GOOD WITHOUT A GAVEL YOU'RE
WELL MANNERED.
ESPECIALLY ESPECIALLY FOR OF YOU
CENTER -- THANK YOU SENATOR WE
ARE THANK YOU ARE CONTENT TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
WORK ON THE BILL AND WE DO AGAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH YOU
AND ALL THE OTHER COMMITTEES TO
IRON OUT ANY OF THE DETAILS
BETWEEN US AND THE OTHER SURPLUS
LAND ACT BILLS.
WELL WE ARE UPDATING MY BILL
FROM TWENTY FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FIVE FOR STRENGTH IN
THE SURPLUS LAND DOCTOR WE THINK
IT'S A GREAT TOOL. TO SUPPLY
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
COURAGE ALL THE DIFFERENT
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT HAVE
SURPLUS LAND AVAILABLE TO AGAIN
PRIORITIZE OUT FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNFORTUNATELY AFTER
TWENTY FOURTEEN WE SAW.
MANY AGENCIES TRYING TO
CIRCUMVENT THAT LEGISLATION SORE
COMING BACK TO TIGHTEN IT WITH A
COUPLE DIFFERENT PROVISIONS TO
WANT. TO CLARIFY SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROVISIONS INCLUDING
THE DEFINITION OF SURPLUS LAND.
I ALSO CREATING A STATEWIDE
DATABASE OF LOCAL SURPLUS LANDS.
WE WANT TO LEVERAGE.
HOUSING -- IN THE LAW TO PROMOTE
THE USE OF EFFICACY OF THE
SURPLUS LAND THAT WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WHO ARE BE.
MUCH MORE ELOQUENT THAN ME AND
TO ASK THEM TO SPEAK.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERM OR LONG TERM
THANK YOU MY NAME IS PEDRO DAVAO
AND I'M WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE OF AND LONG STANDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION CELEBRATING OUR
FORTIETH ANNIVERSARY THIS YEAR.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO SEE A BAY
AREA WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN
AFFORDABLE AND STABLE PLACE TO
CALL HOME -- AND WE'RE HERE
TODAY AS SPROUT CO SPONSORS OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX AND IT IS
POSSIBLE TO HAVE A CALIFORNIA
WHERE EVERYONE HAS AN AFFORDABLE
AND STABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
AND PUBLICLY OWNED LAND CAN PLAY
A CRITICAL ROLE IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT THOUSANDS OF ACRES
OF PUBLICLY OWNED LAND THAT LIFE
THEY CAN'T OR PARKING LOTS.
CAN BE PRIORITIZE TO BENEFIT LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE WAY
PEOPLE DO THAT IS BY CLARIFYING
AND STRENGTHENING CALIFORNIA
SURPLUS LAND ACT THIS IS A FIFTY
YEAR OLD LAW.
WHOSE PURPOSE IS TO ENSURE THAT
SURPLUS LAND IS USED FOR PUBLIC
GOOD BY PRIORITIZING THE LAND
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
MANY PRACTICAL OBSTACLES EXIST
TO ENFORCING THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT THAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
CORRECT THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TING HAS ALREADY TOUCHED ON BUT
WE WANT TO SAY THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO MAKE
THIS LAW.
IMPLEMENTABLE THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM WITH IT HAS BEEN THAT IT
HASN'T BEEN ENFORCED.
AND THROUGH THAT WORK WE HAVE
TAKEN -- OVER SIXTY AMENDMENTS
BY WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BILL HAS BEEN MADE STRONGER
THROUGH THOSE AMENDMENTS AND NOW
WE ARE HERE TODAY.
TO RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE SO THAT CALIFORNIA CAN
BRING TO LIFE A PROMISE THAT IT
MADE OER FIFTY YEARS AGO THE
PUBLIC LAND OUGHT TO BENEFIT THE
PUBLIC GOOD.
AND WE THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MORE LOCKER HONORABLE
MEMBERS EFFORT GOT A YOU'LL HEAR
WITH BURBANK HOUSING AND
AFFORDABLE NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPER OUT OF CINEMA
AND NAPA COUNTIES. FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS WE HAVE LED THE
NORTH BAY AND PROVIDING IN
CREATING AND MAINTAINING QUALITY.
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE -- DEVELOP A
LAND IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HURDLES AND BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
OFTEN -- NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
AND UP WITH THE PARCELS MOST
DIFFICULT TO DEVELOP AND
FREQUENTLY PASSED ON BY FOR A
FOR PROFIT DEVELOPERS.
BUY MORE EFFICIENTLY
TRANSFORMING UNUSED PUBLIC LANDS
INTO PUBLIC COULD.
NOT PROFIT DEVELOPERS LIKE US I
CAN DO MORE.
WE DO BELIEVE THAT BY CLARIFYING
AND STRENGTHENING THE PROVISIONS
OF THE SURPLUS LAND ACT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO CREATE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOMES FOR A COMMUNITIES.
THIS ISSUE HAS ONLY BECOME A
GREATER -- IN OUR COMMUNITY IN
THE NORTH BAY.
WHERE WE HAVE LOST A THOUSANDS
OF HOMES -- DUE TO THE RECENT
WILDFIRES IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WITH FIFTEEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE CURRENTLY ON A WAIT LIST --
WE MUST LOOK AT ALL AVAILABLE
TOOLS AND PUBLIC LANDS KIAN IN
TO PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN OUR
REBUILDING EFFORTS.
AS A FORMER COUNTY SUPERVISOR IN
CINEMA.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
ON THE COUNTY -- ON THE COUNTIES
HOUSING FOR ALL A STRATEGY THAT
FOCUSED ON RE USING SELECT
COUNTY ON PROPERTIES FOR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
AT THAT IF IMPLEMENTED COULD
BRING UP TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED
UNITS OF A HOUSING IN THE COMING
YEARS.
THERE IS GREAT ALIGNMENT WITH
WHAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ALREADY
DOING THESE ARE COUNTIES CITIES
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ABOUT COLLEGE
AND LOCAL -- TO PROMOTE --
INVOLVING PUBLICLY OWNED PARCELS
I'D LIKE TO IN MY REMARKS THIS
AFTERNOON -- WITH A DEVELOPMENT
THAT OCCURRED TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
AGO AT THE CITY OF SANTA ROSA
OWNED A VACANT ON USE PARCEL.
LATER DONATED TO HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY HABITAT WAS ABLE TO
BUILD ITS FIRST HOME -- IN THE
COUNTY THROUGH THAT PARTNERSHIP
THOUGH I WAS ONLY TEN YEARS OLD
WHEN THAT DEVELOPMENT OCCURRED.
I KNOW IT SO WELL BECAUSE MY
FAMILY HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE TO
LIVE IN THAT HOME. FOR MY
WORKING PARENTS THIS WAS A
PIVOTAL POINT IN REALLY A GAME
CHANGER AND CERTAINLY FOR ME.
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING CHANGES
LIVES I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES -- DILIGENCE ON THIS
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ARE FROM GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN MATH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ERIN EVENTS ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
AND SUPPORT.
ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA U. M. B.
TMZ PARTNERS AND SILICON VALLEY
AT HOME ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MALLORY SPOKE WITH CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ONE OR THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATTHEW ONE WITH WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A SEVENTY I ON BEHALF OF WORKING
PARTNERSHIPS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MARINO I AM AT THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
JULIE SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN OF HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
YEAH I'M STILL KEEPING TRACK OF
EVERYONE THAT.
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS IN OPPOSITION TO
EPHRON [inaudible]
GEN.
IS IT A FORMER SUPERVISOR
CARILLO SIR.
YOU KNOW I I WORE A DODGER TIGHT
TODAY.
BROWN IS IT MYSELF [inaudible]
IT'S FORTY KITCHEN ANGEL TIE.
I'M GONNA HALOS PAN.
NEVER IN OPPOSITION THAT I HAVE
FOR AND BUT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED TO THE
LEGISLATION KYLE PACKING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHOR -- AND HIS
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS FOR THE
ROBUST DIALOGUE THAT HAS BEEN ON
GOING THROUGHOUT THE YEAR -- WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
DO SO WE ALSO WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MCGUIRE AND HIS STAFF IN
THE PRIOR COMMITTEE FOR A LOT OF
THE AMENDMENTS THAT GOT WORKED
OUT -- PREVIOUSLY THAT OUR TEAM
OUR MEMBERS ARE STILL ENGAGED IN
REVIEWING RIGHT NOW GIVEN THAT
THEY WENT TO PRINT ON THURSDAY
SO THEY ARE REVIEWING THOSE
PROVIDING US WITH FEEDBACK.
I WANT TO SAY THAT OUR MEMBERS
DO THAT DEEPLY UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE AND ACTUALLY JOINED
TOGETHER IN THE DESIRE TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CHALLENGE.
THE WAY WE LOOK AT IT OUR
MEMBERS SPECIAL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL LOCAL SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT DEPEND ON THOSE SERVICES
FOR AN AFFORDABLE WAY OF LIVING
SO JUST AS ONE MUST HAVE AN
AFFORDABLE.
JUST PRICE ON A HOME OR RENTAL
PRICE FOR A HOME.
THE AMOUNT THAT ONE PAYS FOR
WATER FOR WASTE WATER FOR FIRE
PROTECTION FOR THESE BASIC
ESSENTIAL SERVICES IS JUST AS A
CENTRAL. TO AFFORDABLE LIVING AS
AN AFFORDABLE PURCHASE PRICE ON
A HOME AND SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
STANCE THAT WE COME HERE WITH
AND WHY WE ARE SO CONCERNED
ABOUT WANTING TO FIND A SOLUTION
THAT.
BOTH PROVIDES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND PROVIDES FOR
AFFORDABLE LIVING -- AND THAT'S
WHT OUR MEMBERS ARE SEEKING TO
DO SO THAT LEADS US TO OUR
CONCERNS WE HAVE THREE MAJOR
CONCERNS -- THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
REMAINING -- AND THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS WITH REGARD TO THE
NEW DEFINITIOS IN THE BILL AND
PARTICULARLY THE WORD.
I USE -- WE BELIEVE THAT THE WAY
THAT IT'S CURRENTLY DEFINED
UNNECESSARILY LIMITS THE LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY -- AND CREATES
UNNECESSARY NEW LEGAL LIABILITY
SO WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR
ADDITIONAL EXEMPTIONS BUT RATHER
SOLUTION THAT PROVIDES THAT
LOCAL FLEXIBILITY.
IN A WAY THAT DE AGENCIES CAN
MEET THEIR MISSION AND WORK
WITHIN THEIR ENABLING ACT TO DO
SO -- ONE EXAMPLE.
OF THE TYPE OF USE THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT WOULD BE AN AGENCY
THAT WANTS.
TO SELL A LAND FOR A SOLAR
PROJECT WHERE BY THE AGENCY
WOULD THEN ENTER INTO A POWER
PURCHASE PURCHASE AGREEMENT FOR
THE OUTPUT.
OF THAT PROJECT SO THAT'S JUST
ONE EXAMPLE I KNOW MISS KING
WITH THE HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS --
WILL HAVE SOME OTHERS SECONDLY
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX RESTRICT
THE ABILITY OF A LOCAL AGENCY TO
PARTICIPATE IN EVEN IN FORMAL
NEGOTIATIONS -- AT AND SO IN IN
THE WORD NEGOTIATION IS NOT
DEFINED AND YOU COULD IMAGINE I
CERTAINLY SENATORS -- YOU'VE
BEEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE
SOMEBODY BRINGS AN IDEA TO YOU --
THAT MIGHT BE OUTSIDE THE
FRAMEWORK.
OF A TRADITIONAL HEARING OR
MAYBE RIGHT BE IT RIGHT HERE AT
THIS HEARING I COME WITH A NEW
IDEA -- MAYBE YOU'RE WE WERE
LIVING SOLICITING THAT IDEA HAVE
YOU JUST ENGAGED IN A
NEGOTIATION -- WHY IS THAT SO
CONCERNING THAT BRINGS US TO OUR
THIRD CONCERN AND THAT IS?
NOT ONLY THE X. WILL IT REALLY
THE EXISTING LIABILITY WITHIN
LAW BUT THE EXPANDED LIABILITY
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
PARTICULARLY WITH THE FINE THAT
IT ESTABLISHES.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THIS IS
BRAND NEW A 50% FIND ON THE
VALUE OF THE LAND IF YOU MAKE A
MISTAKE WITH THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT AND WE DO APPRECIATE THERE
ARE SOME.
SOME SAFE HARBORS AND THINGS
LIKE THAT WITHIN THE WITHIN THE
BILL BUT LET'S REMEMBER THAT
SOME OF THESE AGENCIES THEY'RE
NEGOTIATING THE SALES.
MIGHT BE VERY SMALL AGENCIES WE
HAVE SOME THAT MIGHT HAVE A
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IN SOME
INSTANCES PARTICULAR WITH THE
VALUE OF LAND AS IT IS WE MIGHT
HAVE AN AGENCY SELLING A PLOT OF
LAND THAT MIGHT BE WORTH MORE
THAN THE ANNUAL OPERATING BUDGET.
OF AN AGENCY AND SO A 50% FINE
ON THE VALUE OF THAT LAND COULD
BE DEVASTATING TO AN AGENCY.
THAT'S JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO THEY SELL THIS LAND THE
RIGHT WAY AND THEY CAN'T
NAVIGATE A COMPLICATED SURPLUS
LAND THAT THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE A
IN HOUSE ATTORNEY.
IT'S ASSISTING THEM WITH THIS
PURCHASE OR THE CELL SO THOSE
ARE THE TYPES OF CONCERNS OR
WORKING THROUGH -- I HOPE THAT
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND OUR OUR
DESIRE TO BE PRODUCTIVE AND
CONSTRUCTIVE IN GOOD FAITH.
WITH THAT I WILL -- REST MY CASE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU.
IN WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS ALSO ONE I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR FOR WORKING
WITH THE COALITION AND OUR
OPPOSITION.
HOW WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
HAS REALLY GREAT INTENTIONS BUT
THERE ARE A FEW UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SPECIFICALLY FOR
OUR HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS THAT
ARE SOMEWHAT UNIQUE -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL DOES
APPLY TO OUR DISTRICTS THAT
WOULD SELL HOSPITAL OR CLINIC OR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY THAT
HAS AN EXISTING BUILDING ON IT.
MOST OF THE TIMES ARE DISTRICTS
WILL SELL THOSE AT THEIR IN
FINANCIAL DISTRESS WHERE THEY
WILL LOOK AT LEASING AND MOST OF
THOSE CASES THEY WILL START
NEGOTIATING WITH HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES.
VERY EARLY ON WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT ARE DISTRICTS WOULD NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO DO THAT IF
THIS BILL WERE TO GO FORWARD
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH.
THE INITIAL PROCESS THAT SET UP
IN THE BILL BEFORE THEY CAN
START TALKING TO THEIR DISTRICTS
AND AS MISTER PUTNAM ALREADY
MENTIONED.
THE THREAT OF A LAWSUIT AND THE
THREAT OF THE PENALTIES IN THE
BILL ARE VERY SIGNIFICANT
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF OUR SMALL
RURAL DISTRICTS.
THAT MAY ALREADY BE IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS AND SO WE'RE HOPING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON SOME OF
THOSE ISSUES ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
ALSO CONCERNED WITH THE
DEFINITION OF USE IN THE BILL.
IT I AM DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
RETAIL OR OFFICE DEVELOPMENT A
LOT OF OUR DISTRICTS HAVE OFF
MEDICAL OFFICE BUILDINGS WERE
CONCERNED THAT.
THOSE TYPES OF ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE ENGAGED BY OUR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS WOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED PUBLIC USE AND
THEREFORE THOSE LANDS THAT THE
ACTIVITIES ARE -- THAT ARE
OPERATED ON WITH THEM BECOME
SURPLUS LAND AND SO AND WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE SOME
WORKABLE SOLUTIONS AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF ON SOME OF
THE SOLUTIONS THANK.
pOTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB.
EIGHT FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX HE GOT
A VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL THE REASONS JUST ENUMERATED
BY MY TWO COLLEAGUES AND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION.
AT THAT BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALSO HAS AN
OPPOSED COMMENDED POSITION.
A GOOD AFTERNOON JOE BOSCO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
PATRICK WELL TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES CESSATION
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED BY AQUA
TO A LINER COMMENTS WITH CSTA
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN MARCOS
IN OPPOSITION.
IN THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
MESA WATER DISTRICT OPPOSITION.
YOU ARE NOT TAKING TANA FOR
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT --
POSE FOR THE REASONS OUTLINED BY
THE TWO ASSOCIATIONS.
BOB GARCIA REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICTS OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OPPOSE FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THANK YOU.
CAROLINE ALL OF THE SOLANO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES.
SURE THE CONCERNS OUTLINED BY
CSTA BUT WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE AMENDMENT TO
SECTION THIRTEEN RELATED TO THE
HOUSING ELEMENT REPORTING IN FOR
BETTER LIGHTING THAT.
IN CHRISTY FOR WITH THREE
VALLEY'S MISCIBLE WATER DISTRICT
ALSO OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED BY THE
SPECIAL DISTRICT ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- THAT BRINGS US BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY.
SENATOR ROTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE WHOLE WORLD.
SIR I'VE BEEN CONTACTED BY
SPECIAL DISTRICTS OF WITHIN THE
SENATE DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT --
WAS SOME CONCERNS -- AND I WAS
TRYING.
TO EXPLORE WITH THEM TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTOOD WHAT THOSE
CONCERNS ARE.
SEEMS CLEAR VIEW OF VACANT LAND
AND THEN A SPECIAL DISTRICT IS
GOING TO SELL IT TO SOMEBODY FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ONE SORT OR
ANOTHER THEN THAT'S JUST CLEARLY
FALLS WITHIN WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO WAS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE LAKE.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE ONE
DISTRICT SPECIAL DISTRICT AS A
SANITATION DISTRICT AND THEY
HAVE A COMMERCIAL BUILDING.
THE THING NO LONGER OF USE FOR
THEIR OFFICES BUT THEY LEASE IT
TO VARIOUS NON PROFITS.
SEARCHES OF HISTORICAL SOCIETY
CHURCH GROUP ONE OR TWO IN THE
BUILDING PROVIDES A NEEDED
OFFICE SPACE FOR THESE COMMUNITY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
SO I GUESS MY QUESTION IS THIS
IS THAT USE PROHIBITED UNDER THE
BILL -- FOR PERMITTED UNDER THE
BILL FOR WITH THE AGENCY BE
REQUIRED TO THE DISTRICT BE
REQUIRED TO TERMINATE -- THAT
USE AND MAKE THE PROPERTY THE
BUILDING IN THIS CASE BECAUSE
THE COMMERCIAL BUILDING
AVAILABLE. TO LOW INCOME HOUSING
DEVELOPERS IT'S OKAY IF I COULD.
JUST TO FURTHER MY WITNESS THE
BILL CLUB SELING.
AFTERNOON SENATOR ROBB IS A
CLEAR QUESTION YES -- AND SO TO
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION -- THE
QUESTION OF LEASES ACTUALLY
REMAINS UNANSWERED IN THIS BILL
IT WAS INITIALLY INCLUDED AND
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER TAINTED.
INCORPORATE LANGUAGE INITIALLY
TO ADDRESS THAT QUESTION BUT ONE
OF THE EARLY AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAD TO TAKE IN -- ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT REMOVED THOSE
PROVISIONS AND CALLED FOR THE
FORMATION OF A WORKING GROUP. TO
ADDRESS SPECIFICALLY THE ISSUE
ON LEASES BECAUSE THERE'S MORE
THERE'S DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OF WHETHER OR
NOT LEASES ARE COVERED EVEN
UNDER EXISTING LAW -- IT HAS
BEEN ALWAYS OUR INTENT TO ALLOW
FOR INTERIM SHORT TERM LEASES
THAT DO NOT CREATE ANY PERMANENT
USE ON THE LAND TO REMAIN AT TO
REMAIN UP ALLOWED -- UNDER THE
LINE WOULD NOT BE INTERFERED BY
THIS BUT FOR EXAMPLE WHAT IF THE
LEASING ARRANGEMENT LET'S TAKE
THE HOSPITAL DISTRICT FOR
EXAMPLE WERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE MUCH OF A
HOSPITAL IF YOU DON'T HAVE
PHYSICIANS AND OF COURSE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT HOSPITALS TEND
TO DO IS GROUP PHYSICIANS IN.
MEDICAL PRACTICE GROUPS AROUND.
AND IT'S YOU HAVE A LEASING
ARRANGEMENT TO ALLOW -- A
MEDICAL GROUP PURCHASERS OF THEM
TO LEASE FACILITIES ON YOUR
PROPERTY IN ORDER TO HELP STAFF
YOUR HOSPITAL.
THAT WOULD SEEM TO ME TO BE A A
LEASING ARRANGEMENT IT'S
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL TO THE
EXISTENCE AND MISSION OF THE
HOSPITAL DISTRICT AND AND
LEASING ARRANGEMENT AND MEDICAL
GROUP OPERATIONS CENTER.
ARE INTEGRAL TO THE TO THE
PURPOSE AND AN OPERATION OF THE
DISTRICTS OF IN THAT CASE A
LEASING OPERATION.
LONG TERM SHORT TERM WHATEVER
WOULD SORT OF HE WON A PERMIT
THAT WOULDN'T YOU.
YES AND THE BILL PRESENTLY DOES
ALLOW FOR THAT AS LONG AS THE AS
LONG AS THE LAND.
IS BEING USED TO SUPPORT THE
WORK OR OPERATIONS OF THE LOCAL
AGENCY THERE IS A CLEAR
PROVISION THERE THAT SAYS -- IT
ISN'T IT WOULD NOT TRIGGER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE SURPLUS LAND
OCT.
WELL AND I YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
THEIR CODE SECTIONS THAT DEFINED
THE TERM DISPOSE BUT TO ME
DISPOSE MEANS TO GET RID OF THEM
THAT MAY NOT BE TRUE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- CODES BUT
IF YOU IF YOU ARE STILL THE THE
TITLE OWNER OF THE BUILDING.
YOU HAVE CERTAIN
RESPONSIBILITIES WHAT DO YOU
HAVE A TENANT IN THERE ARE NOT
DE IF THERE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES ON THE PROPERTY MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IS THE
LANDOWNER.
GOVERNMENT OR OTHERWISE YOU HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES FOR CLEAN
UP.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS IF THERE IS
A IF THERE'S PROPERTY DAMAGE
PERSONAL INJURY ON THAT PROPERTY.
AS THE LANDOWNER OF THE BUILDING.
ARE YOU HAVE LIABILITY UNLESS
YOU FIGURE OUT SOME WAY TO SHIFT
THE BURDEN TO TO THE TENANT IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE SO.
YOU MAY HAVE A TENANT BUT YOU
REALLY NOT DISPOSE OF ANYTHING.
OTHER THAN YOUR OCCUPANCY.
SO I I I'M HOPING YOU'RE WORKING
ON THESE ISSUES.
WE ARE AND THE DEFINITION OF THE
SPOILS WAS ALSO ONE OF THE
DEFINITIONS THAT ARE IN QUESTION
AS I MENTIONED.
IN THE INITIAL VERSION OF THE
BILL THAT WAS INTRODUCED WE
DEALT WITH THAT.
ISSUE HEAD ON BUT WE HAD TO TAKE
AN AMENDMENT EARLY TO REMOVE
REFERENCES TO LEE SAYS OTHER
THAN WHAT'S UNDER EXISTING LAW.
PART OF WHY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
INTRODUCED THIS BILL WAS TO
CLARIFY EXACTLY WHEN THE SURPLUS
LAND APPLIED AND WHEN IT DOES
NOT AND SO -- THERE IS A ORKING
GROUP THAT HAD THAT IS BEING
CONVENE IT'S MATT ALREADY ONCE
WHERE YOU WANT TO BE WILL BE
RECONVENING AGAIN DURING RECESS.
TO ADDRESS THESE QUESTIONS ON
LEASES BECAUSE IT IS -- THE LAW
ADMITTEDLY THIS NOT AS IT IS
RIGHT NOW DOES NOT DIRECTLY
ADDRESS THOSE QUESTIONS SEE YOU
EXPECT THIS TO BE CLEANED UP ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY.
THIS COMES TO VOTE ON THE FLOOR.
YES AND THEN I ONE FINAL
QUESTION IF I MAY SIR OF SO IN
THIS CASE THE SPECIAL DISTRICT
WITH THE COMMERCIAL BUILDING.
LET'S SAY THE COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS A FIVE STORY SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
BUILDING THAT THE SPECIAL
DISTRICT NO IT'S A IT'S A WATER
DISTRICT THE WATER DISTRICT IS
NO LONGER USING BECAUSE THEY
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE FACILITY.
AND THEY THEY WANT.
TO DO IN THIS CASE TRULY DISPOSE
OF THE BUILDINGS THROUGH A SALE
OR TRANSFER.
THE MARKET VALUE THE BUILDINGS
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IS LOU IS
THE WATER DISTRICT ENTITLED TO
EXPECT THAT MARKET VALUE. TO BE
RECEIVED FROM ANY LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER YES
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO TAKE LESS
THAN THE MARKET VALUE.
AND I'M SORRY -- AND AND THE LAW
ACTUALLY A THERE IS AN EXISTING
SECTION IN THE LAW THAT SAYS --
YOU BRING SELL IT AT MARKET
VALUE OR YOU MEET DISCOUNTED IT
IS UP TO YOU -- AND IN FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX BE REFERENCE NOT
SECTION SEVERAL TIMES TO MAKE IT
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
THAT YOU ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
SELL THE LAND BELOW MARKET VALUE
PERFECT WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE HOPEFULLY THE REVISED
VERSION WHEN IT HITS THE FLOOR
AND I'LL BE HAPPY.
TO MAKE THE MOTION DEEPER PETER
ANSWER.
THANK YOU.
JUST ADD ONE THING YOU ACTUALLY
DON'T EVEN HAVE TO SELL THE LAND
YOU JUST HAVE TO GIVE THE FOR
THE HOUSING DEVELOPERS THE FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL.
SO IF YOU GIVE THEM THE FIRST
REFUSAL NOBODY COMES FORWARD
THEN YOU CAN AGAIN SO IT TO
WHOMEVER YOU WISH.
WE HAVE A SENATOR CAFIERO THAT
WOULD LIKE TO INTERROGATE I MEAN
ASK YOU SOME QUESTIONS.
NOW I'M JUST TRYING.
TO LET ME SAY THAT I I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO BECAUSE THE THE ISSUE IS
REALLY VERY VERY SIMPLE WHICH IS
SAID IF YOU'RE GOING. TO RELIEVE
YOURSELF.
OF THE OWNERSHIP OF THE PROPERTY
AND YOU'RE IN THEM.
IN GOVERNMENT THAT THAT YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS I THINK
THE KEY HERE GETS BACK TO WHAT.
THE DEFINITION OF SURPLUS IS AND
HOW YOU IDENTIFY IT IS SURPLUS
SO -- I APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY BECAUSE OUR OUR
COMMITTEE REPORT.
HAD NO DETAIL ON THE SPECIFICS
AND YOU MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO BECAUSE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT THERE ARE THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN PEOPLE SHOW UP AND THEY SAY
HEY I'VE GOT AN IDEA FOR THAT
PIECE OF PROPERTY.
AND TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
THAT SHOULDN'T IS IT SHOULDN'T
ABOUT -- IN ORDER TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THEIR SPECIAL
DISTRICT OR THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND SO I THINK IF WE GET A
REALLY GOOD DEFINITION WHICH I
THINK IS WHAT YOU WERE GETTING
TO OF WHAT IS DETERMINED TO BE
SURPLUS -- THEN THAT AND IT'S A
BRIGHT LINE THEN YOU YOU START
TO PROTECT ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS THAT YOU'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT OUR AND ARE NO LONGER OF
CONCERN BECAUSE YOU'VE MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
SOME ACTION THAT IDENTIFIES IT
AS SOMETHING THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO SELL.
OR OR GET RID OF AND AND AND
THEN IT BECAUSE EVERYTHING ELSE
BECOMES A LITTLE BABIES YOURSELF.
THAT I THINK -- I'M PREPARED TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT I DO WANT
TO SEE WHAT THE DEAF AND I WAS
TRYING TO FIND THE DEFINITION OF
OF SURPLUS AND UNFORTUNATELY
REFERS TO SOMETHING ELSE IN THE
BILL AND I I I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT.
THAT -- AND I LOOK AT MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EXPERIENCE AND THERE
WAS THERE WERE MANY MANY YEARS
WHERE WE SAT ON PROPERTY FOR
YEARS AND WE SAT ON IT BECAUSE
WE HAD THIS GREAT IDEA.
THE ECONOMY WENT DOWN THAT THE
TANK AND WE COULDN'T GET ANY
FUNDING FOR IT AND SO IT STAYED
THERE VACANT AND I I DON'T WANT
TO BE IN A SITUATION AT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL WHERE ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU'VE GOT PEOPLE
COMING AND GOING FOR AYE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
WITH THAT PROPERTY AND YOU
HAVEN'T USED IT IN TEN YEARS AND
SO IT'S SURPLUS.
AND WE GET WE GET TO INNER INTER
INTO AN AGO SHE SHOULD BECAUSE
I'VE DECIDED THAT YOU REALLY
SHOULD JUST SELL IT RATHER THAN
HAVE HABITS IN SIT EMPTY AND I
THANK.
YOU MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
EXPERIENCE THERE WE HAVE SOME
PROPERTIES EXPECT ESPECIALLY
AROUND OUR TRAIN STATION WHERE
WE WE HAD A PLAN WE HAD FUNDING
FROM THE STATE THE MONEY
DISAPPEARED AND SO WE WE STILL
HAVE VACANT LAND AND AND AND I
WOULDN'T WANT ANYBODY TO BE ABLE
TO SAY.
THAT SURPLUS BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT
USING IT AND YOU HAVEN'T USED IT.
FOR A LONG TIME FIFTEEN YEARS
TWENTY YEARS SO SO AS LONG AS
YOU GET THAT SURPLUS -- TRIGGER
RIGHT AND THERE'S SOME ACTION
IT'S REQUIRED BY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
IN ORDER TO IDENTIFY THAT THEN
I'M I'M I'M WITH YOU BUT I'LL
SUPPORT YOU TODAY AND HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN GET THEIR THANK YOU SAID
I THINK IT THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU CRYSTALLIZED EXACTLY
THE ESSENCE OF THE BILL WHICH IS.
WHY I DECIDE TO CARRY IT OF
COURSE WHAT YOU SAID TO CARRY
THE BILL YOU REALIZE IT'S A MUCH
MUCH MORE COMPLEX WHICH IS WHY
THERE'S ALL THE SURPLUS LAND
LYING AROUND THAT?
HASN'T BEEN BUILT AND NOT AND
STORE NEAR AS COMPLEX AS WATER
BUT AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE IS
NO.
GOVERNMENT AGENCY OR SPECIAL
DISTRICT THAT EVER THINKS THEIR
LAND A SURPLUS THEY HAVE SOME
VISION OF GRANDEUR.
FOREVER AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THEY'VE HAD
VISIONS OF GRANDEUR OF HOUSING.
FOR TEACHERS.
FOR DECADES I WANT TO SAY THAT
THIS CAN BE A VACANT LAND GOING
ON TWO THREE FOUR DECADES WILL
BE COULD HAVE.
ACTUALLY HAD HOUSING FOR
TEACHERS ON INTO OUR OUR
DEFINITION IS.
AT THAT THE LAND BECOME SURPLUS
WHEN THE AGENCIES DECIDE TO
DISPOSE OF IT -- THE CHALLENGES
YOU HAVE AGENCIES THAT NEVER
EVER GO THROUGH.
THAT CATALOG OF DEFINING WHAT IS
SURPLUS AND WHAT IS NOT SO I
THINK WHAT WE TRY TO DO.
IN THE LEGISLATION IS TO IS TO
TRY.
TO HAVE THAT LINE AND I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING IS FOR A
NUMBER OF DISTRICTS ARE AGENCIES
THAT NEVER WENT THROUGH THAT
DIALOGUE GETS A LITTLE BIT.
CONCERNING BECAUSE THEN IT MIGHT
FORCE THEIR HAND A LITTLE BIT SO
I THINK WE WE ARE TRYING.
TO FIND SOME MIDDLE GROUND ON
WHAT THE OTHER THING IS AN AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT IN IN THE INSTANCE THAT YOU
GIVE THERE MAY BE THERE MAY BE
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN USING THEIR
PROPERTY. FOR FOR HOUSING FOR
YOU KNOW THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE FOR
AFFORDABLE OR FOR WORKFORCE --
BUT THERE MAY BE A HYBRID. TO BE
ABLE TO SAY IN THE INSTANCE
WHERE YOU HAVE PROPERTY THAT
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE --
BILL WERE FOR HOUSING COULD
REASONABLY BE BUILT -- THAT YOU
CAN NEGOTIATE WITH THE NONPROFIT
DEVELOPER FOR THE PROVISION OF
HOUSING.
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY AND SO.
SO YOU MAY HAVE SURPLUS IT YOU
HAVE TO SELL BUT YOU ALSO MAY
HAVE PROPERTY THAT YOU WANT TO
MAKE AVAILABLE AND THAT'S WHAT
WHAT I'M HOPING THE STATE WILL
DO BECAUSE THERE ARE PROPERTIES.
THAT HAVE BEEN AROUND FOR A
REALLY LONG TIME THAT ARE IN.
TIME LOCATIONS WHERE HOUSING
COULD BE BUILT.
AND TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE AS A
PARTNERSHIP WOULD BE ANOTHER
OPTION.
WELL WE WE DO THAT IN MY
DISTRICT WERE ACTUALLY HAD A
BILL -- NOT AROUND PRIME LAND
BUT THESE WERE CALTRANS LANDS
TEN TEN PARCELS IN SAN FRANCISCO
THAT ARE.
THESE TO THE CITY UNDER MARKET --
FOR NAVIGATE FOR HOMELESS
DEDICATION CENTERS OR PARKS NOW
YOU DON'T YOU WOULD NOT SEE THE
SURPLUS LAND BECAUSE FRANKLY THE
FREEWAY ON RAMPS.
SO IF YOU EVER SAW THEM YOU
WOULD NEVER THINK ALL THIS TO BE
A GREAT PLACE FOR A TWO HUNDRED
UNIT DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE IT'S
NOT A BIT.
BUT YOU KNOW WE HAD. TEN
ENCAMPMENTS IN THOSE AREAS TO SO
WE WERE ABLE TO REPLACE THOSE
TEN ENCAMPMENTS.
INPUT -- TEMPERING APPLICATION
SENATOR WE THINK IT'S MUCH
BETTER USE BUT THE I THINK
THAT'S REALLY.
THE ESSENCE OF WHAT WE'RE WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND I THINK
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION WITH THE SPECIAL USED
TO STRIPPING.
CHALLENGE HAS BEEN.
THAT ON HIS NO NO ONE FEELS
COMFORTABLE EVER GIVING ANY.
PIECE OF THEIR LAND TO WHEREVER
SAYING THAT.
THIS IS SURPLUS SOMETHING THAT'S
WHERE WERE THOSE OF THE
DEFINITIONS THAT WE CONTINUE
TRYING TO WORK THROUGH AND WE
WILL TRY.
TO GET GET THROUGH BEFORE WE GET
TO THE CENTER.
FOR SENATOR BATES IS NEXT FALL
BY ME AND THEN WILL RETURN THIS
BACK TO THE CHAIR.
IF THE GAVEL EMPLOYEES.
I JUST WANT TO INNER SCORE --
UNDERSCORE WHAT TO MY COLLEAGUE
GOT TO ROSS SAID ABOUT THE
LEASES ARE.
WE FIND IN MY COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
HAVING SERVED ON THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT WE WERE USING A
LAND.
DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS THAT WOULD
CREATE REVENUE TO MEET THE CORE
MISSION OF THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
A VERY SIGNIFICANT AS WE SEE THE
PENSION LIABILITIES.
GROWING EXPONENTIALLY AND THE
GENERAL FUND HAVE ENOUGH COVER
THOSE THERE FOR THE SERVICES
THAT ARE THERE FOR A PUBLIC
SAFETY PARKS RECREATION.
YOU KNOW OUR TRANSPORTATION
THOSE ARE STARTING TO DIMINISH
SO IT IS EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT THE LEASE ISSUE
BE WORKED ON BECAUSE THAT'S HOW.
ARE THEY ABLE TO MONETIZE THE
LAND FOR THE VERY PURPOSE THEIR
OF THEIR CORE MISSION AND THEIR
GOALS THE RESPONSIBILITIES
ESSENTIALLY ODD.
TO THE TAXPAYER SO I'M GLAD TO
HEAR THAT YOU HAVE THAT THE
WORKING GROUP BUT I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE UNDERSCORED.
IT IS VITAL AND SOME OF THE
COMMUNITY SAID OF MARTY
DESIGNATED AND WE HAVE A HARBOR.
IN -- ORANGE COUNTY THAT CENTER
GOING EVITALIZATION IT'S LEASED
OUT TO A GROUP THAT ARE PUTTING
HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY IN IT BUT
IT WILL GENERATE REVENUE FOR THE
COUNTY WANTS TO ME TO SCHOOLS.
SO LOESER OF THOSE ARE CRITICAL.
THANK YOU ABSOLUTE.
YOU -- YOU'VE YOU'VE BUILT --
WONDERFUL LIST OF AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION.
WE WOULD BE DOING IF IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW.
TELLING YOU.
AND YOU KNEW HOW TO HIT IT --
CINNAMON TANG AND AND SO HOT.
I'M.
I'M STILL WAITING FOR YOU TO
REACH THE SWEDES PART WITH WITH
THESE IMPORTANT OR AGENCIES UC'S
ASSOCIATIONS.
SO I'LL STILL BE OPPOSED BUT I I
WOULD SAY IT'S VERY PERSUASIVE
TO BRING A FRIEND HERE I THAT
WAS.
GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOU KNEW
WHAT WHAT -- MIGHT MIGHT MOVE
YOU.
THANK YOU I ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS COLLEAGUES.
A MOTION BY -- SENATOR ROTH --
TO MOVE THE BILL AND THERE ARE
NO -- OKAY WE LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
DOUBLE THE PUSH IT ALL THE
FEEDBACK THE SENATORS IN
PARTICULAR ON THE LEASES AS WELL
AS THE THE DEFINITION OF SURPLUS
LAND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TOWARD TO REFINE IT TO REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE DIALOGUE
TODAY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT RESPECT RESTAURANT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- WITHOUT --
WE HAVE A MOTION WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS O THE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX BY SEVEN NUMBER TING
MUCH IS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION.
CENTER WINNER.
CLEANER I MORAL.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES NO CARRIER.
CARILLO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE NO ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I CASKEY.
THE VOTERS FORTY THREE WILL PUT
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
IF YOU VERY MUCH.
RECIPE FOR IT THE NEXT ITEM I
JUST WANNA TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- AND THAT IS -- ITEM --
ITEM TO AB.
FIFTY EIGHT ITEM TWELVE AB SIX
CITY FOR ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
NINE FIFTY SEVEN ITEM FOURTEEN
A. B..
TEN TEN ITEM EIGHTEEN AB FIFTEEN
SIXTY OCCUR -- MOTION BY SENATOR
ROTH AND WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL RIGHT MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES I CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE MORE
LOCK.
MORE LIKE I ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER AMBERG.
NUMBER I WHO CASKEY. SEVEN ZERO
EIGHT SEVEN ZERO WILL PUT THAT --
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS --
NEXT -- WILL CALL IN FIVE AB ONE
SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WHY THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON?
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB ONE
SIX EIGHT AIMS TO ENSURE THAT
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
AND SACRED SITES WILL BE
PROTECTED UNDER NEW STREAMLINED
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT LAW.
WE ARE SEEKING TO PROVIDE A
TEMPLATE THAT CAN BE USED IN
FUTURE STREAMLINING LAWS AS WELL.
WE HAVE LOST MUCH OF THE STATE'S
NATIVE HISTORY AND ONCE A
RELIGIOUS OR CULTURAL ARTIFACT
SITE OR BURIAL GROUND IS LOST IT
CANNOT BE REPLACED.
AS A SHOW OF GOOD FAITH I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
TODAY.
HOWEVER WE HAVE NOT HAD A CHANCE
TO VISIT THESE AMENDMENTS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRIBES.
AS WE HAVE DISCUSSED MISTER
CHAIR I ASK FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
THAT WE WORK WITH TRIBAL
ATTORNEYS LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
AND COMMITTEE STAFF UNTIL.
CALIFORNIA'S TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
AGREE THAT WE HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT CAN TRUTH THAT TRULY
PROTECTS TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES.
THAT EFFORT FAILS OVER THE
INTERIM WE WILL STAND DOWN AND
COME BACK NEXT YEAR.
WE'LL RETURN IN UNTIL WE TRULY
HAVE PROTECTED THE CULTURAL AND
RELIGIOUS PLACES AND ARTIFACTS
OF CALIFORNIA'S SOVEREIGN TRIBAL
NATIONS.
TRIBES MUST HAVE ASSURANCES ON
THE ENFORCEABILITY OF THIS
LANGUAGE AND THEY NEED A
GUARANTEE THE TRIBAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES WILL GET THE SAME
PROTECTIONS THAT THEY CURRENTLY
RECEIVE UNDER AB.
FIFTY TWO WITH CONSULTATION
TRIBAL CULTURE RESOURCES CAN BE
PROTECTED OR AVOIDED AND IMPACTS
CAN BE MITIGATED.
DEVELOPMENT CAN ACTUALLY MOVE
FASTER WITH CONSULTATION BECAUSE
LITIGATION IS LESS NECESSARY AS
A MEANS OF PROTECTION FOR TRIBES.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I KNOW WE SHARE
THE SAME GOAL AS THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY TO PRESERVE
THE ABILITY TO INTERACT WITH
LOCAL PROJECT PROPONENTS AND
GOVERNMENTS TO PROTECT TRIBAL
RIGHT.
AS WE HAVE ENGAGE THE LARGER
COMMUNITY OF TRIBAL STAKEHOLDERS
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
TOGETHER AND IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE TRIBES WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
THAT GOAL.
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANKYOU BEFORE WE GET TO WIN A
SAYS I JUST WANT -- TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH US -- WE
HAVE TWO VERY IMPORTANT -- LAWS
AB -- FIFTY TWO TO PROTECT THE
SACRED SITES WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT I'M A SUPPORTER OF AB
FIFTY TWO SB THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINED HOUSING -- CREATION --
AND THE TO BUILD THESE TWO LAWS
ARE IN MY DO NOT IN CONFLICT AND
WE I KNOW I KNOW THAT WE CAN
HARMONIZE THEM WELL -- I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND OUR STAFF AS WELL AS
THE TRIBES FOR WORKING WITH US --
I THINK WE MADE A LOT OF
PROGRESS AND I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THESE.
AMENDMENTS AND YOU HAVE MY FULL
COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL WORK
OVER THE SUMMER -- AND I AM -- I
AM VERY OPTIMISTIC THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE -- A GREAT
RESULT THIS YEAR AND BE ABLE TO
MOVE ON AND HOPPED A TEMPLATE
FOR THE FUTURE SO THANK YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOU AND YOUR
STUFF IS GOING TO HELPING OUT
WITH THAT.
THANK YOU -- TO HAVE WITNESSES
NUMBERLESS.
OKAY.
SO CLOSE ORDER WITH THE WILTON
RANCHERIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EVERITT VARGAS FOR THE DRY CREEK
RANCHERIA AND ALSO TO THE RIVER
TRIBE APPRECIATE THE THE AUTHOR
IN THE CHAIR WORKING TOGETHER
AND ESPECIALLY THANK YOU FOR A
YOUR STAFF SOLUTION WORK -- THE
SUMMER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EMILY HUGHES ON BEHALF OF UPPER
LIKE TRIUMPH IN SUPPORT. TO
LEARN AT THE CANTON OF FOR THE
BROADER BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
IN SUPPORT.
GRAY IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE -- WE WILL --
BRING THIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES WITH ANY QUESTIONS
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING -- NINE AGAIN THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR ON THE
AMENDMENTS WERE CROSSED
YESTERDAY BUT THERE'RE --
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- SO IT
THEM I GUESS THE MOTION AS HOT
AS AMENDED TACTICALLY -- OKAY
GREAT -- SO THIS WILL I GUESS --
BE HURTING TOMORROW AN
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
SO -- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ROTH WE YOU AND WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SOME --
ASSEMBLY US FOR AYE VOTE AND I
THINK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
WORK ON THIS.
A COLLABORATIVELY -- I KNOW WE
HAD A LOT OF STICKING POINTS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITY COMING FORWARD IN
HELPING US WITH THAT THANK YOU.
THIS IS A MEMBER ONE SIXTY A BY
SAMBAR AGUIAR-CURRY MISSION IS
TO PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY SENATOR
WIENER.
WIENER HI MORRELL.
BATES.
BATES I CARREIRO.
CARREIRO AYE DURAZO.
MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
ROCK I ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER.
UMBERG.
NUMBERED BY BECAUSE HE SIX OF
SIX VOTERS ENOUGH TO GET OUT OF
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU CENTERS -- OKAY WHO DO
WE HAVE MAX FLOATS ISSUES FIRST
WHAT.
WITH THE SUIT.
YES YES SO NEXT -- ITEM --
ELEVEN AB FOR THIRTY SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER WOULD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS -- I LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR WORK ON THIS BILL. ONE OF
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT HOUSING
CHALLENGES PEOPLE FACE TO
SECURING AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
OFTEN INDIVIDUALS CAN MEET THE
MONTHLY FRONT IS A BARRIER.
THE RISING DEMAND FOR MORE
HOUSING IS COUPLE WITH THE NEED
TO MAKE HOUSING MORE AFFORDABLE.
WE KNOW THAT RENDON CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY CHECK ALREADY CHALLENGES
ARE TO THE DEFINITION OF
AFFORDABLE.
THE BURDEN OF HIGH RANK COUPLED
WITH THE RISING COST OF
HEALTHCARE STUDENT LOAN DEBT
BURDEN ANOTHER NECESSARY COST OF
LIVING.
LEAVES LITTLE AVAIL INCOME FOR
MANY TO AFFORD THE INITIAL-MOVING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
SECURING HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA.
LIVING COSTS SUCH AS SECURITY
DEPOSITS AND FIRST MONTH'S RENT
SAYS HE WAS SECURING RENTAL
HOUSING CAN COST THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS.
AND THAT AND EIGHT AND THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO HAVE ON HAND
WHICH IS UNAFFORDABLE FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES.
HE BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN WOULD
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT COULD
PROVIDE THAT MUCH NEEDED
ASSISTANCE TO COVER THESE MOVING
COSTS INCREASE IN INCREASE
HOUSING SECURITY AND REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
HERE IN SUPPORT WITH ME TODAY IS
LUIS MARATHI.
FROM CALIFORNIA U. M. B. AND
THAT'S WITH A WHY.
AND IS A MEMBER ID AT LEWIS --
MARTY WITH CALIFORNIA BE -- I'M
HERE -- TO SUPPORT I AB FOR
THIRTY SEVEN BECAUSE AT THIS IS
REALLY AN ISSUE OF FAIRNESS I
THINK -- THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET.
HAS ABOUT SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN IT FOR COLLEGE PHASE
HOME BUYERS DOWN PAYMENT
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM -- BUT
BECAUSE OF THE RISING COST OF
HOUSING WHICH THIS COMMITTEE IS
WELL AWARE OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
INCREASINGLY LOCKED OUT OF
HOMEOWNERSHIP.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDDLE CLASS.
AND WHILE THE STATE FOCUS IS
IMPORTANT ATTENTION ON BRINGING
DOWN THE COST OF HOUSING
CALIFORNIA'S INCREASINGLY LARGE
RENTER COMMUNITY I NEED HELP NOW.
I EVEN FOR QUALIFY RENTERS WAS
STABLE EMPLOYMENT THE START UP
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH RENTING AN
APARTMENT CAN BE LARGE BARRIERS.
I THIS PROGRAM IS ONE STEP
FORWARD ON ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
BALLARD SMOKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
BUT FORGET A YEAR WITH BURBANK
HOUSING HERE IN SUPPORT.
STILL THIS ALISHA ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
COUNTIES OF MENDOCINO AND
HUMBLED AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA THANK YOU.
IN ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION. THREE NUMBER
ABOUT THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CALLING.
MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH -- WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE THE PERFECT -- THE
MOTIONS BY CENTER OFTEN WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AN ABLE FOR THIRTY SEVEN
BY SEVEN NUMBER WOULD MOTIONS
YOU PASS REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER AYE MORRELL.
BATES. EIGHT NO CARRIER.
CARRIER I DRAWS -- MCGUIRE
MORLOCK [inaudible]
ROUGH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER.
BECAUSE HE KIDS THREE ONE WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THE NEXT -- WE
WILL GO TO ITEM TAUGHT US I'M
SORRY.
IT'S FOR NEXT.
LARA.
THIS REPORT.
OKAY NEXT WINTER ITEM TWENTY AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
WHAT I THINK NEED YOU IN THE
OTHERS WHOSE FOR THIS AND
PREVIOUS COMMITTEES HELP KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF WITH THAT IN MIND
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
AUTHORIZES CITY MY DISTRICT TO
TRANSFER RATE.
GOVERNMENTAL PROPERTY FOR LESS
THAN MARKET VALUE TO A LOCAL
NONPROFIT THAT PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR HOMELESS AND LOW
INCOME INDIVIDUALS.
AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLING TO CONFRONT THE
HOMELESS CRISIS MANTECA AND A
LOCAL NONPROFITS ARE DOING ALL
THAT THEY CAN TO ADDRESS THIS.
THIS PROPERTY SEARCH WILL SERVE
WOULD SERVE AS A GREAT CENTRAL
LOCATION FOR THE CITY AND
NONPROFIT PROVIDER.
PARTNER TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES IN OUR LOW INCOME AND
HOMELESS POPULATIONS HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF ALREADY A DISSOLUTION.
THE AGENT PROPERTY MUST BE SOLD
OCT.
AT AUCTION AB SEVENTY THIRTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE MENTAL CAN
OPPORTUNITY UTILIZED A BUILDING
THAT IS OTHERWISE SAT VACANT FOR
NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS. TO PROVIDE
A PROVIDE CRITICAL RESOURCES TO
THE HOMELESS COMMUNITY A FORTUNE
THE LOCAL THAT WERE GOING TO
JOIN ME UP HERE TODAY HAS A
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS AND WERE
UNABLE TO MAKE IT BUT I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE.
WITH RESPECT LAST RIDE OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
ANY OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL.
BACK US IN ROTH MOVES THE BILL
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS --
SING NINE WOULD LIKE TO COOK.
WE'RE SO CLOSE.
BODY LIKE THE CLOSENESS OF YOUR
AFFECT LESTER I'VE -- OKAY AND
WITH THAT WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AN ABLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY
TWO BY SOMEONE NUMBER FLORA
MOTION IS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES.
CENTER WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
GUERRERO. ZERO I DRAWS A MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE AYE ROTH ROTH AYE
SKINNER.
UMBERG CASKEY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT I
AB FIVE DESERVE BETTER VOTERS
FIVE ZERO PUT ON CALL FOR THE
OUT TO MEMBERS THANK YOU
COMMITTEE PROCEED THANK YOU NEXT --
SOME REMEMBER BLOOM ITEMS TWENTY
TWO AJ ARE [inaudible]
FIFTEEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATORS
CALIFORNIA LIKE MOST OF THE
NATION IS EXPERIENCING A GRAIN
OF ITS HOMELESS AND LOW INCOME
POPULATION OVER.
HALF OF ALL HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
IN THE STATE ARE OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE AND ACCORDING TO A
RECENT STUDY RELEASED BY THE
JOINT CENTER. FOR HOUSING
STUDIES AT HARVARD UNIVERSITY.
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF RENTER
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE OLDER ADULT OUTSOLD.
THE NUMBER OF UNITS RENTING FOR
LESS THAN EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
A MONTH HAS FALLEN EVERY YEAR
SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN WHICH IS A
NET DECLINE OF FOUR MILLION
UNITS MAKING MATTERS WORSE.
ACCORDING TO THE JOINT CENTER
FOR HOUSING STUDIES TABULATIONS
AFFORDABILITY RESTRICTIONS COULD
EXPIRE ON APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION RENTAL UNITS
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
NATION WIDE THAT INCLUDES SIX
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND UNITS
THAT ARE ADDED THROUGH THE LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
PROGRAM. THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO THOUSAND UNITS OF SECTION
EIGHT PROJECT BASED HOUSING AND
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS
UNDER OTHER PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT'S.
SECTION -- TO TO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR THE ELDERLY PROGRAM.
AND THAT PROGRAM THE SECTION TWO
OH TWO PROGRAM IS AN EXTREMELY
EFFICIENT PROGRAM THAT IS
PRODUCED MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND AFFORDABLE HOMES ACROSS
THE UNITED STATES.
BUT IS COMMUNITIES HAVE A
LENGTHY WAITING LIST TO GET INTO --
AMIDST RISING HOMELESSNESS
AMONGST OLDER ADULTS.
HR FIFTEEN STATES THE
LEGISLATURE SUPPORT FOR ANNUAL
ANNUAL FEDERAL FUNDING OF THE
SECTION -- TO TO SUPPORT OF
HOUSING FOR ELDERLY PROGRAM AND
CALLS UPON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE SECRETARY
OF HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
TO REINSTATE FUNDING THAT WAS
CUT DURING THE GREAT RECESSION.
IN THE AMOUNT OF SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS EQUAL
TO ABOUT.
POINT 001%.
OF THE TOTAL NON DEFENSE
DISCRETIONARY SPENDING IN THE US
BUDGET.
INVESTING IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ESPECIALLY FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS SAVE THE STATE
MONEY BY IMPROVING HEALTH WELL
BEING AND DIGNITY FOR OLDER
ADULTS WHO MUST SPEND LESS ON
FOOD AND MEDICAL CARE.
WHEN FOR SUSPENDED OUTSIDE SURE
OF THEIR INCOMES ON HOUSING?
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT IS A
SAFETY NET THAT KEEPS OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AWAY FROM
HOMELESSNESS.
A WITH ME AS REBEKAH MARCUS WITH
LEADING H. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
BUT AFTERNOON RECOMMEND GUESTS
REPRESENTING ANY AGE CALIFORNIA
TWO THIRDS OF SENIORS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO NEED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CANNOT ACCESS AT THE
HEAD TO A TO PROGRAM AS A PROVEN
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT HELPS LOW
INCOME SENIORS AGE AND PLACE.
THE SECTION TWO OH TWO PROGRAM
HELPS EXPAND THE SUPPLY OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR THE
ELDERLY.
IT PROVIDES VERY LOW INCOME
ELDERLY WITH OPTIONS THAT ALLOW
THEM TO LIVE INDEPENDENTLY IN AN
ENVIRONMENT THAT PROVIDES
SUPPORT FOR ACTIVITIES SUCH AS
CLEANING COOKING AND
TRANSPORTATION.
WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR NEW
FINDING WERE ASKING CONGRESS TO
REINSTATE FUNDING THAT WAS
ELIMINATED DURING THE LAST
RECESSION WE URGE AND I FELT.
BRITTANY THE SHOW SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
THURMOND BRING ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE MOTION BY SENATOR ROTH
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
THE NUMBER YOU ARE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ARE WE HAVE EMOTIONAL CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS A YEAR FIFTEEN BY SOME
OF MY BLOOM MOTIONS BE ADOPTED.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES AYE CAMARO.
CARRIER I DRAWS A MCGUIRE
MORLOCK.
MORE LIKE A FIVE ROTH.
ROTH AYE SKINNER.
UNDER THE CASKEY. THIRTY SIX
ZERO WILL PUT IT ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY I SEE THAT -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARE RIVAS -- IS HERE AND
SO WE WILL CALL ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WHAT ARE
THE ODDS ARE YOU HAVE.
TO SO WE'LL START WITH YOUR
EARLIER ONE ITEM FIFTEEN AB.
TWELVE FIVE TWELVE FIFTY FIVE SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SENATORS COMMITTEE STAFF SO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
I KNOW I CATCHING MOST OF THE
HEARING IN MY OFFICE AND THIS IS
JUST ANOTHER -- A DATABASE BILL
SO.
BUT HOPEFULLY A SIMPLE ONE THIS
REALLY IS A SIMPLE AND THE IDEA
WAS LANDS YOU COMBINED
EVERYTHING.
THIS REALLY IS A SIMPLE IDEA IT
WAS -- AN IDEA THAT WE GENERATED
FROM THE DISTRICT ACTUALLY.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES SOME
OF THE TOP FIFTY FIVES IT.
BUILDS UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER. TO CREATE A
DIGITIZED INVENTORY OF SURPLUS
STATE PROPERTY THAT COULD BE
USED FOR FORMAL HOUSING
ASSISTANCE YOU WHAT THIS BILL.
IT IT PROPOSES TO CREATE
INVENTORY OF ON YOU CITY AND
COUNTY PROPERTY -- FOR THE
POTENTIAL HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
WHILE LEAVING PAUL LEAVING THESE
DECISIONS ON USED TO LOCAL
CONTROL AND SO BY SIMPLY
IDENTIFYING THESE OVERLOOKED IN
UNDERDEVELOPED AREAS.
THERE'S TREMENDOUS POTENTIAL FOR
LOCAL LEADERS AND DEVELOPERS TO
COLLABORATE AND TO BUILD SMART
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND DANCE.
TRANSIT RICH AREAS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WE BETTER
SERVE THE NEEDS OF OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES OF OF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO THIS BILL IS
NARROW IN SCOPE AND IDENTIFIES
ONLY SITES THAT QUALIFIES IN FOR
HIGH DENSITY.
AND SO IT LEAVES THESE DECISIONS
ON USE.
OF OF LAND -- AND TO LOCAL
CONTROL NOTHING ELSE IS BEING
ASKED OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
WE HAVE WITNESSES HERE THAT CAN
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES -- AND AND
NOT ADD TO THIS -- OPENING BUT
CERTAINLY WHAT THIS IS IS JST
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
REPORTING THIS DATA FOR
UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS AYE
MALLORY SPOKE OR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND SINGLE FAMILY AND
MULTI FAMILY APARTMENT OWNERS
AND PROPERTY MANAGERS.
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR OVER TWO
MILLION AFFORDABLE AND MARKET
RATE RALLY UNITS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA?
WE'RE PLEASED TO COMMUNICATE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL THAT WE
CREATE A PUBLIC SEARCHABLE
ONLINE INVENTORY OF LOCALLY
OWNED PUBLIC PARCELS.
THAT SPECIFICALLY QUALIFY AS
INFILL OR HIGH DENSITY AND ARE
CURRENTLY ON USED IN AN ACCESS
OF LOCAL AGENCIES FORESEEABLE
NEEDS.
THE ANALYSIS AND INTENT LANGUAGE
FOR THIS BILL REALLY DOES SAY AT
ALL I CAN CONFIRM FOR YOU THAT
IDENTIFYING AVAILABLE LAND.
PERMITTING IT AND GETTING FINAL
APPROVAL BEFORE LAND OWNER CAN
EVEN BEGIN THE PROCESS TO BUILD
HOUSING.
CAN TAKE YEARS IN SOME CASES
MORE THAN A DECADE.
AND DOCKS EVEN WHEN THE LAND IS
ALREADY ZONED FOR HIGH DENSITY
HOUSING.
NO OTHER STATE HAS SUCH A
LENGTHY PROCESS OR HURDLES THE
OWNERS MUST OVERCOME.
AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE CAN HELP
TAKE THE TIME OFF HE OVERALL
PROCESS WE BELIEVE THIS BILL
WILL BE HELPFUL. TO OUR HOUSING
CHALLENGES AND WE RESPECTFUL
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
GREAT TO ANY ADDITIONAL --
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE OPPOSITION.
WE FROM SUPPORT [inaudible]
HI.
LAURIE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SALINAS AND SUPPORT.
GREAT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THREE NINE WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
A MOTION BY CENTER ROTH AND
CENTER MORE LOCK THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THE CINNAMON RIVAS KIND OF GOT
ME EXCITED AT THE BEGINNING OF
YOUR PRESENTATION YOU SAID IT
WAS STATE.
SURPLUS LAND BUT THE BILLS TO
CITY AND COUNTY CARESS YES IT'S
JUST SO -- SO WHAT IT DOES IS SO
THE NO I'M I'M TRYING.
TO I KNOW IT DOES STRIKE.
LE TED STATE.
WHAT THE STATE IS ALREADY --
ESSENTIALLY WITH THE EXECUTIVE
ORDER THAT MISTER NEWSOME --
SIGNED I BELIEVE WAS IN JANUARY
INCLUDE STATE SURPLUS PROPERTY
SO THIS ESSENTIALLY WOULD MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THIS AS
WELL WITHIN OUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES WE CAN MAYBE HAVE ALL
THREE ON ONE WEBSITE WE HAVE
MIGHT BE AB APPS THAT MAKES OF
US AND SO I KNOW THAT -- YOU
KNOW THE MESSAGE I HEARD FROM
OUR CHAIRS MAKING SURE THAT WE
COLLABORATE AS MUCH AS WE CAN I
MEAN DOES IT MAKE SENSE TO HAVE
ALL THESE DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW -- THESE DATABASES NO
YOU KNOW ANY WAY THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER I'M ACTUALLY I'M
VERY OPEN TO THAT AND I MEAN
THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE GREAT.
GREAT THEN I'M WITH YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
AN ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL.
DOES ENJOY AND I RECOMMENDATION
AS I'VE SAID EARLIER -- IN THE
SURPLUS LANDS.
BILLS AND THE DATABASE BILLS AS
WELL AS AT YOU BILLS WHICH ARE
NOT ENOUGH SO YOU ISN'T OF
EIGHTY YOU PARK -- WE'RE GOING
TO BE WORKING OVER THE SUMMER
JUST TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE ALL
COMPLIMENTARY AND HARMONIZE SO
WILL -- LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
ON THAT -- BUT THE SO SEVEN AYE
RECOMMENDATION I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE -- JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR EITHER.
MR ARE WE MOTION MY SON ROTH AND
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A LITTLE TWENTY FIVE BY
SOMEONE NUMBER ROBERT RIVAS
MOTIONS TO PASS AND REFER THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER.
HI WIENER I AM MARROW.
MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES I CABRERO.
CABRERO I DORADO.
MCGUIRE MOORLACH.
WARLOCK I ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER
UMBERG CASKEY. SIX SEVENTY SIX
ZERO THAT WILL PUT THAT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WILL NOW GO
TO YOUR SECOND BILL -- I AM
TWENTY ONE AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WELL
AGAIN THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND AND AND
COLLEAGUES IS STAFF I APPRECIATE
THE BILL ANALYSIS -- APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THIS
AFTERNOON.
TO PRESENT THIS BILLS I'M VERY
VERY PROUD -- TO TALK ABOUT THIS
NEXT BILL WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY EIGHT THREE IT'S A BILL.
OF IT'S A A PRIORITY BILL THE
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
IT IS A PRIORITY FOR THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
AND IT CERTAINLY IS A PRIORITY
FOR THE OVER NINETY THOUSAND
FARMWORKERS -- IN IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
AND SO -- IN ADDRESSING OUR
STATE'S ACUTE HOUSING SHORTAGE.
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT WE NEED A
BROAD AND DIVERSE APPROACH.
HELLO AND TO FULLY ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS.
WE MUST ALSO.
ALSO LOOK BEYOND OUR LARGEST
CITIES AND URBAN CENTRES.
BECAUSE WE TWO NEED HOUSING
POLICIES AND SOLUTIONS FOR RURAL
AND AGRICULTURAL REGIONS OF THE
STATE.
AND THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS A
CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING OUR FARM WORKER
HOUSING SHORTAGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY.
TOGETHER WITH OUR FAMILY FARMERS
THEY WORK TO BRING THE FRESHEST
PRODUCE TO MARKET.
AND THEY CERTAINLY DO THEIRPART
IN HELPING FEED THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
YET THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE AND DECENT PLACES FOR
THEM TO LIVE [inaudible]
SUMMER HOMELESS.
OTHERS PAY RENT.
AND THAT RENT EATS UP THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR FAMILIES PAY.
AND THERE HOUSING.
THEIR LIVING SITUATION
[inaudible]
IS DEPLORABLE.
AND OFTEN SUB STANDARD.
WE HAVE FARMWORKERS LIVING IN
GARAGES [inaudible]
INTENSE.
IN THE BANDS.
AND ABANDONED BUILDINGS.
WE HAVE A MULTIPLE FAMILIES
LIVING IN THE SAME ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
IN FACT JUST LAST YEAR.
IN AN ARTICLE FEATURED -- THAT
THAT THAT THAT HIGHLIGHTED THIS
FARMER HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
SALINAS VALLEY.
IT HIGHLIGHTED ONE CASE OR FORTY
PEOPLE FORTY PEOPLE WERE LIVING
IN A THREE BEDROOM HOME.
THAT HAD JUST TWO BATHROOMS.
THERE ARE FARMWORKERS LIVING IN
TRAILERS AND TRAILERS WITH NO
AIR CONDITIONING DURING THE HOT
SUMMER MONTHS.
AND THESE AREN'T JUST FILLED
WORKERS WERE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT AS THEIR CHILDREN.
IT IS THEIR FAMILIES.
IN RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT ONE IN TEN
STUDENTS.
ARE HOMELESS.
AT TWELVE SCHOOLS THAT NUMBER IS
ONE IN.
FIVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THESE KIDS ARE THE CHILDREN OF
FARMWORKERS.
IN THIS SITUATION.
THIS SITUATION IS A HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS RIGHT HERE IN OUR GOLDEN
STATE.
AND I INTRODUCED THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT.
THE MORAL RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
SOMETHING.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE AN OPT IN
PROGRAM.
OPT IN VOLUNTARY.
A PROGRAM THAT IS DESIGNED TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS BY WHICH
DECENT QUALITY FARM WORKER
HOUSING GETS A BILL.
THE DOES NOT ADD ADDITIONAL RED
TAPE FOR FARMERS.
IS THAT HELPS MAKE IT EASIER.
EASIER FOR FARMERS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS TO BUILD DIGNIFIED
FAMILY FRIENDLY.
FAMILY FRIENDLY HOUSING.
HOUSING FOR THE WORKERS TO KEEP
IS FED AND HELP DRIVE OUR
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITIES.
AND CERTAINLY OUR STATE ECONOMY.
NOW THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THREE IS IT A SILVER
BULLET WITH REGARDS TO FORMER
HOUSING.
THERE IS MUCH MORE WORK TO BE
DONE.
BUT IS IMPORTANT STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND AS MANY OF
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT KNOW.
I CAN SPEAK ON THIS ISSUE I CAN
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FORMER HALF OF FORMER HOUSING
FROM FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE.
BECAUSE YOU SEE MY GRANDFATHER
WAS A FARMWORKERS ALMADEN
VINEYARDS AND PISCINE THIS
CALIFORNIA.
HE WITH MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY
MOM WAS A SINGLE PARENT.
THEY RAISED MY BROTHER AND I SO
I GREW UP IN FORMER HOUSING. TEN
MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY AND I LIVED
IN OVERCROWDED CONDITIONS.
OUR FORMER HOUSING UNIT WAS
LOCATED ON THE SAME AGRICULTURAL
FILLED THE SAME VINEYARDS WHEN
MY GRANDFATHER WORKED EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
OUR HOUSING WAS VERY VERY BASIC
BUT IT WAS DECENT.
DECENT HOUSING THAT ROOF OVER
OUR HEADS.
GAVE OUR FAMILY THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR A BETTER LIFE.
BUT MANY FAMILY MANY FARMWORKERS
THEN AND TODAY ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY EACH
AND EVERYONE OF US IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. TO SURE THAT
THE DOOR OF OPPORTUNITY RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
REMAINS OPEN FOR EVERYONE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY EIGHTY
THREE WILL MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THOSE
WHO WORK THE FIELDS LIKE MY
GRANDFATHER DID.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
CURRENT GENERATION FARMWORKERS.
THAT THEIR CHILDREN ALSO HAVE
THE CHANCE AT A BETTER LIFE AND
AT A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
AND THIS BILL IS THE FIRST STEP
IS A BUILDING BLOCK A BUILDING
BLOCK TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
GREAT NEED.
THE BILL FARMER HOUSING IN OUR
STATE AND TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS IN EVERY.
AREA OF THE STATE.
EVERY COMMUNITY NOT JUST WEALTHY
ZIP CODES HAVE ACCESS TO HOUSING.
THIS ON BEHALF OF MY CO AUTHORS
I CERTAINLY ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT --
IN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY.
AND WITH THAT -- WE DO HAVE BILL
SPONSORS HERE.
WHO CAN -- PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS AND I WOULD ASK THAT
THEY INTRODUCE THEMSELVES THANK
YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU.
WITH OVER THREE THREE WITNESSES.
AB SO HAPPY WITH I WE WOULD ASK
EACH TO BE APPROXIMATELY TWO
MINUTES OR SO THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M THAT IS SEVERAL MEADOW
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST QUESTION SHOULD THE
STATE BILL MORE FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
AND DO SO FASTER.
I BELIEVE THE PEOPLE WHO WATER
FOR EACH OF YOU WOULD VOTE YES.
CALIFORNIA IS BEGINNING TO BILL
MORE HOUSING BUT AS USUAL
FARMWORKERS ARE LAST IN LINE.
THESE WILL WOULD SPEED UP THE
LINE FOR DECENT QUALITY FARM
WORKER FAMILY HOUSING.
THE SECOND QUESTION SHOULD STAY
TAXPAYERS PAY FOR OUR TO BILL
HOUSING. FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S EXPANDED GETS
WORK PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW HOW THE PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR YOU WOULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
STATE TAXPAYERS DO NOT WANT
THEIR MONEY TO SPEND TO BE SPENT
ON THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
GIVES WORKER PROGRAM.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE WITH NO HOUSING AT ALL. FOR
THOSE NOT FAMILIAR WITH THE H.
TO A PROGRAM.
IT ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO HARNESS
THE WORKER FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY.
TO THEM SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE
TOTAL CONTROL OF THE WORK FORCE.
THIS IS MY THIRD MARTYR DANE
INDENTURED SERVITUDE.
ENTITIES ARE RAGES.
WE WOULD.
IT IS OUR BRIDGES WE WOULD
DONATE.
STATE PET TAXPAYER MONEY TO
CONTINUE THIS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T BLOCK ANY
FARMER OR DEVELOPER TO BUILD
WHAT THE FROM ONE TO FACILITATE
THE TRUMP PROGRAM.
AS LONG AS THEY SPEND THEIR OWN
MONEY.
NOT OURS.
THE PEOPLE WATER FOR YOU WOULD
VOTE YES IN THIS BILL.
I JOIN THEM IN ASKING THEM.
AND ASKING YOU TO AVOID
YESTERDAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR RAN
LOPEZ FROM THE CENTER FOR OF
FARMWORKER FAMILIES.
I'VE BEEN RESEARCHING AND
WORKING WITH FARMWORKERS FOR
ABOUT TWENTY TWO YEARS.
AND I VISITED MANY OF THEM IN
THEIR PLACES OF RESIDENCE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I'M APPALLED
AT THE LIVING CONDITIONS OF THIS
HIDDEN MOSTLY UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION.
ACCORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHOULD COST
30% OR LESS OF GROSS INCOME.
THE FARM WORKERS THAT I KNOW PAY
UP 280% OF THEIR IMPOVERISHED
WAGES.
ON RENT AND OFTEN HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN PAYING RENT AND
PROVIDING SHELTER FOR THEIR
FAMILIES OR BUYING FOOD.
A FEW FARMWORKER FAMILIES FIND
DECENT HOUSING IN THE STATE'S
SEASONAL MIGRANT CAMPS OR IN THE
MID PENINSULA HOUSING AUTHORITY
APARTMENTS.
HOWEVER BOTH OF THESE OPTIONS
HAVE DRAWBACKS INCLUDING IN THE
MIGRANT CAMPS FAMILIES HAVE TO
MOVE AT LEAST TWICE A YEAR.
AND IN THE IN THE MID PAN
SITUATION THERE IS A WAITING
LIST OF FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS FOR
AN APARTMENT.
MORE COMMON -- FARMWORKERS IN
YEAR ROUND RESIDENTS IN
WATSONVILLE CASTROVILLE IN
SALINAS AND THE WAY THEY LIVE IS
DISGRACEFUL AND A CAUSE FOR
CONCERN.
EXAMPLES SIXTEEN PEOPLE WITH
CHILDREN LIVING IN LESS THAN A
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET WITH ONE
BATHROOM.
AND THEY TELL ME THEY HAVE TO
LINE UP IN THE MORNING TO USE
THE BATHROOM. TO FARM WORKER MEN
RENTED A GARAGE WITH THE SCENT
OF CEMENT FLOOR IN WINTER FOR
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THEY WERE COLD SO THEY ATTEMPTED
THE HEAT THE GARAGE WITH A SMALL
BARBEQUE.
BOTH PERISHED IN THE NIGHT FROM
CARBON MONOXIDE POISONING AND
THERE WERE NO OBITUARIES IN THE
LOCAL NEWSPAPERS ABOUT THEIR
PASSING.
A SINGLE MOTHER FARM WORKER PAYS
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH SHE
WORKS SIX DAYS A WEEK TEN TEN
HOURS A DAY. TO RENT A
DILAPIDATED UNMAINTAINED HOUSE
LACKING ANY SOURCE OF HEAT AND
SHE BROUGHT HER INFANT HALL SON
HOME FROM THE HOSPITAL IN
FEBRUARY TWO A A HOUSE.
IT WITH FREEZING TEMPERATURES.
ALL RENTED APARTMENTS AND HOUSES
I'VE EVER VISITED HAVE NOT BEEN
MAINTAINED.
WHEN THE STOVER REFRIGERATOR
GOES OUT IT IS NOT REPLACED?
OUR ORGANIZATION IS PURCHASE
STOVES AND REFRIGERATORS FOR
MANY FAMILIES WHO OTHERWISE
WOULD HAVE TO LEARN TO LIVE
WITHOUT THEM SINCE THE PROPERTY
OWNERS REFUSED TO REPLACE THESE.
ESSENTIAL APPLIANCES THESE
EXAMPLES ARE UNFORTUNATELY NOT
UNCOMMON THEY ARE HOWEVER.
COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE AND
UNACCEPTABLE AND CERTAINLY NOT
REFLECTIVE OF A MORAL CIVILIZED
SOCIETY AND THEY LARGELY ACCOUNT
FOR FARMWORKERS LIMITED LIFE
EXPECTANCY.
OF ONLY FORTY NINE YEARS THAT'S
THE AVERAGE.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WHEN ONE
CONSIDERS THAT FARMWORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THEY ARE
THE BACKBONE OF THE FIFTY
BILLION DOLLAR CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRIAL AGRICULTURAL.
SYSTEM AND INDIRECTLY SUPPLY
FOOD TO THE NATION AND EVEN WITH
THE EXPORT TO THE WORLD.
THE INDUSTRY IT IN PART ACCOUNTS
FOR CALIFORNIA BEING THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY.
I IMPLORE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
PERVASIVE SUFFERING AND ANGUISH
I OBSERVED DAY AFTER DAY IN FARM
WORKER COMMUNITIES OVER THE
YEARS DUE TO THEIR HORRIFIC
HOUSING SITUATIONS.
MUST BE CORRECTED WE AS A STATE
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA CAN
AND MUST DO BETTER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT.
HE WAS A STATE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION -- MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MARK SHOTS ARE HELD
MY CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION ON ONE
SECOND.
MY APOLOGIES BECAUSE HE SKIPPED
OVER I THOUGHT MAYBE YOU WERE.
IT IS WE HAVE ONE MORE --
SUPPORT WINDOWS BEFORE WE GET TO
THE MICROPHONE I'LL BE BRIEF
CHAIR MEMBERS CHRIS BUTCHER
THOMAS LAW GROUP ON BEHALF OF U.
F. W. I'M HERE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ENTER YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY.
THANK YOU.
WROTE MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PARK SHOCKED OR CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
I COULD AFTERNOON TERM MEMBERS
LUIS MAR I'D SAY WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE SERVICES GO BAY
AREA HOUSING ACTION COMMITTEE I
INSTRUCT SUPPORT TODAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SASHA EARNED HIM
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
LAURA JOHNSON THE BAT ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SALINAS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION OF SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TERM MEMBERS
TAYLOR RUSH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU AND BEHALF.
OF MULTIPLE COUNTY FARM BUREAU'S
WHERE REGRETTABLY OPPOSED AB --
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WE SHARE
THE INTEREST IN THE NEED TO
OFFER AFFORDABLE SAFE AND
HEALTHY HOUSING.
FOR OUR WORK FORCE AND WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE OTHERS ATTENTION
TO FORMER HOUSING -- A SUBSET
THAT OFTEN GETS LOST IN A LARGER
DISCUSSION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GENERALLY -- WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
AND ITS PRACTICALITY.
A PRIMARILY WE HAVE A CONCERN
WITH THE PROVISION THE BILL
WHICH PRECLUDES THE UTILIZATION
OF STATE FUNDING. FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AGE TO A EMPLOYEE
HOUSING.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IT'S PUDENT TO
USE A LEGISLATION AS AN
INDICTMENT ON THE PROGRAM WE
WILL BE ONE OF THE FIRST TO SAY
THAT IT'S NOT PERFECT AND AND
FARM BUREAU WORKS ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL.
DESIGN ADVOCATE FOR ITS
IMPROVEMENT IN ITS APPLICATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- IN THE
INTERIM HOWEVER BECAUSE OF OUR
LABOR SHORTAGES THE STATE'S H.
TO A POPULATION WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW SO RESTRICTING OR LIMITING
THE UTILIZATION OF EXISTING
FUNDS.
AND FUTURE FUNDS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO MEET THAT POPULATIONS
NEEDS -- WILL ACTUALLY
DISCOURAGE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING AND EXACERBATE OUR
EXISTING SHORTAGE --
ADDITIONALLY WE HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE INCENTIVE OFFERED
WITHIN THE BILL -- THE WE CAN
APPRECIATE DODD MYSTERY OF US IN
THE SPONSORS ARE INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO OFFER A TOOL -- THE
CONDITIONS THAT ARE IMPOSED WITH
THE UTILIZATION OF THE TOOL
REALLY MAKE IT UNTENABLE FOR
FARMERS TO ENGAGE -- UNDER THE
CONDITIONS OF THE BILL A FARMER
WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE FOR FUNDING
AND CONSTRUCTING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS.
AND THEN SEATING ALL MANAGEMENT
OVERSIGHT TO A THIRD PARTY FOR
TERM AT FIFTY FIVE YEARS -- THE
LANDHOLDERS EXPRESSLY EXCLUDED
FROM HAVING ANY ROLE IN THAT
HOUSING OPERATION -- BUT HOLDS
ALL OF THE OLD SOME
RESPONSIBILITY AND LIABILITY FOR
THAT.
SO WE HAVE SOME REAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT -- THAT'S
FEASIBLE WHAT TYPES OF
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THE FINANCIAL
WHEREWITHAL TO ACTUALLY DEVELOP
AND MAINTAIN AND SERVICE THAT
INTERIM PARTY -- AND ALSO ABOUT
WHETHER AUDIT PROVIDES OUR
FARMERS THE FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED NOW AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO NEED TO ADAPT TO
DIFFERENT.
LABOR SOURCES -- EVEN IF ALL OF
THESE CONCERNS WERE MANAGED
THERE'S THERE'S OTHER ISSUES
WITHOUT THAT INCENTIVE THAT JUST
REALLY DON'T MAKE AN ACCESSIBLE
TOOL. FOR FARMING COMMUNITIES
AND ONCE AGAIN WHAT WE CAN
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S
ATTENTION TO BE PAID WE THINK
THAT THIS THIS INCENTIVE DANGLE
THE CARROT THAT THAT'S BEYOND
OUR GRASP.
AND WE HAVE SERIOUS PROBLEMS OF
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS FOR A
FORMER COMMUNITIES AND WE NEED
WE NEED SERIES SOLUTIONS -- NO
WE WANT TO SEE TO THAT THAT WE
SHARE THAT SADNESS THAT IT
HAPPENS WITH FARM WORKER
EMPLOYEES.
THAT ARE RESIDING INTENSE AND
LIVING UNDER OVERPASSES THAT
CERTAINLY NOT ANYTHING THAT ARE
WE'D BE HAPPY WITH OUR EMPLOYEES
ENGAGING IN -- BUT WE WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THAT THAT'S NOT
NGUYEN EMPLOYEE PROVIDE
EMPLOYERS PROVIDE THAT HOUSING
THAT'S IN THE ABSENCE OF
EMPLOYER PROVIDED HOUSING.
SO WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE AS MUCH
SIMPLER PROVIDING HOUSING AS
POSSIBLE TO ASSIST WITH THIS
DEVELOPMENT IN THE HADN'T
HOUSING NEED -- SO UNFORTUNATELY
BASED ON THESE CONDITIONS WE
JUST CAN'T FIND.
THE RIGHT OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
THIS BILL.
FORWARD AS A PRODUCTIVE RESPONSE
TO OUR EXISTING NEED AMBER
QUESTION ABOUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW
ON WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION -- I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY -- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE FARM GRL.
YOU KNOW IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT
WE FIND OURSELVES HERE -- TODAY --
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL -- AGAIN WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT EMPLOYEE
PROVIDED HOUSING WE'RE NOT
ARGUING ABOUT THE ZONING ISSUE.
OR FRANKLY EVEN THE CAPITAL PUT
THAT HOUSING AND WE HAVE --
MEMBERS WHO WANT TO ACTUALLY GET
MORE FARMER HOUSING IN BUT THEIR
HANDS ARE BEING TIED -- BY
CONDITIONAL USE FROM ANY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- AND WE WOULD BE
UP SUPPORT OF A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY ALLOWED US TO GO
THROUGH A MINISTERIAL PERMIT.
THROUGH EIGHT CD THE DIN ALSO
TIRE HANDS ON THIS OTHER SIDE
JUST BY SAYING YOU'VE GOT TO
TURN THE KEYS OVER TO A THIRD
PARTY OPERATOR FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEAR CONTRACT.
IN ORDER TO THEY'LL YOURSELVES
OF A FASTER PERMIT WE FIND THAT
COMPLETELY UNTENABLE AND FRANKLY
QUITE AND REASONABLE -- THE AGE
TO A PROGRAM -- TO CORRECT THE
RECORD WAS ESTABLISHED BACK IN --
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX THAT'S A
PROGRAM -- THAT ALLOWS FOR OUR
INDUSTRY -- TO BASICALLY
PETITION FOR AN APPLICATION BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TO
DEMONSTRATE AND SHOW THAT WE
HAVE A LACK OF LABOR AND AG.
AND OUT THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
APPLICATION PROCESS WE HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- THAT WE CANNOT
FIND ANY ADDITIONAL EMPLOYEES.
PART OF THE REQUIREMENT TO HAVE
HIGHER NEEDS TO EMPLOYEE IS THAT
THE EMPLOYER AGREED TO PROVIDE
HOUSING.
WE SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
HOUSING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUCH AN RULE AREAS
WERE AT IS LOCATED -- TO TO MEET
THAT NEED AND SO WHAT IS ALSO
HAPPENING IS ADDITIONAL
PRESSURES BEING UPON UPON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES -- ON APARTMENT
COMPLEXES RENTAL HOMES THAT FROM
LABOR CONTRACTORS AND OTHERS
INDUSRY HAVE TO ACTUALLY FIND
HOUSING. FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES.
WE ARE ASKING TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING ALL ON OUR LAND
ON AG ZONED PROPERTY.
ITS EMPLOYEE.
HOUSING PROVIDED BY THE EMPLOYER
NOT A GENERAL HOUSING
REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE FIND THIS
BILL UNTENABLE FOR US AND WE
REMAIN OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
VALERIE NARRA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS ALREADY
STATED.
MORE NO AND HEY JACK ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE FAR
COMMISSION CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NURSING -- AND
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA STRAWBERRY
COMMISSION UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY FARM
BUREAU WESTERN GROWERS THANK YOU.
IN THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE PEAR GROWERS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY ON BEHALF OF RC RC
THE WORLD COUNTIES WE'RE NOT IN
OPPOSITION BUT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AND
I'LL BE EXTREMELY BRIEF -- FIRST
OF ALL WE HAVE NO OBJECTIONS TO
A TO A PROVISIONS AND THE BILL
OUR CONCERNS ARE WITH THE
STREAMLINED RG SERIAL PERMIT
REVIEW PROCESS NAME NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
OR HAVE A LETTER THAT YOU
SUBMITTED OR ONE ESTIMATE PLEASE
DO SO YES WE HAVE SUBMITTED THE
LETTER TO YOUR COMMITTEE TO THE
AUTHOR AND WORKING EXTENSIVELY
WITH THEM OKAY WE APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
OKAY SITTING NINE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE -- SENATOR
ROSS FALLS OVER CENTER WERE
KELSEY.
YOU KNOW WE CLEARLY HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE IT'S
AS A SERIOUS ADVERSE IMPACT ON
THE THE WORKERS.
BURGER CULTURE WORKERS.
IN THE STATE BUT I HAVE TO SAY
I'M PUZZLED BY THIS AGE TO A
ISSUE AND THE PROHIBITION ON THE
USE OF STATE HOUSING FUNDS.
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING
IS AS THE GENTLEMAN NOTED THIS
PROGRAM.
HAS BEEN AROUND LONG BEFORE THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
WASHINGTON DC.
AND AND GIVEN THE HOUSE SIR
GIVEN THE HOUSING CONDITIONS
THAT YOU OUTLINED IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT IN THE SURGEON.
H. TO A WORKERS WHICH OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS.
AND THE APPARENT SHORTAGE OF
DECENT HOUSING.
IN THESE AREAS WHERE THE WORKERS
ARE EMPLOYED I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY.
WHY WE'RE GOING TO YOU'RE ASKING
US TO PROHIBITIVE SO STATE FUNDS --
FOR HOUSING THESE.
H. TO A WORKERS APPROPRIATELY
NOW I REALIZE IT'S THE
EMPLOYER'S OBLIGATION IN THAT
PARTICULAR PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
HOUSING BUT AND I GET THAT.
BUT IF THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
WORKERS WHY WOULDN'T WE AND
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH HOUSING
WHY WOULDN'T WE USE.
STATE FUNDS TO THE EXTENT
AVAILABLE UNDER WHATEVER
CONDITIONS.
OF THE ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDES.
IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
HOUSING IS THE BEST HOUSING THAT
WE CAN POSSIBLY PROVIDE.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN THIS
UNDER THIS DOME.
RECOGNIZING IN DEALING WITH OUR
OBLIGATION TO CARE FOR ALL OF
THOSE WHO LIVE AND WORK IN THIS
STATE.
REGARDLESS OF WHO THEY ARE WHERE
THEY CAME FROM.
WHAT THEIR STATUS IS?
AND THIS SEEMS TO BE A MOVE.
AWAY FROM THAT FRANKLY SO
HAVEN'T HAVING -- GIVEN MY
SPEECH I GUESS MY QUESTION IS IS
THIS IT WAS THIS A POLITICAL.
ISSUE HERE OR ARE WE DOING THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S A CONCERN FOR
THE AVAILABILITY OF OVER THE
AVAILABILITY OF STATE FUNDS TO
PROVIDE HOUSING AND IF SO.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED THE LATTER
IS THE CASE.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED RESTRICTIONS
ARE MATCHING REQUIREMENTS OR
OTHER -- ELEMENTS -- TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE SUFFICIENT
FUNDS WITH RESPECT TO PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR H. TO A HOUSING IS A
CLEAR QUESTION.
YES I YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S
QUICK QUESTION I DO APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND I THINK YOU
KNOW -- ALL AT THE SPONSORS
WEIGH IN AS WELL AFTER I'M DONE
BUT YOU KNOW -- SO THIS BILL
ATTEMPTS BILL FARMER FAMILY
HOUSING.
H. TWO WAYS A NON FAMILY
ORIENTED PROGRAM THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM.
AND SO THIS BILL HAVE TO
PROHIBIT.
RIGHT USES STATE FUNDING AN H.
AND SO AND SO RIGHT AND SO WITH
THAT OBJECT AND I'LL GET TO THAT
PART OF THE QUESTION IS A
CERTAINLY THIS IS A BILL.
THAT WAS BASED ON DATA LOCAL
DATA AND SO I POINT TO A A LET
ME WE WE GOT MOST OF THE DATA
FROM THIS FARM WORKER HOUSING
STUDY AN ACTION PLAN FOR THE
SALINAS VALLEY IN THE POWER
VALLEY.
WHICH IS PUBLISHED IN JUNE OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND IN
THAT STUDY IDENTIFIES THAT THOSE
OVER NINETY THOUSAND FARMWORKERS
CURRENTLY LIVING IN THIS.
IN THIS.
LABOR SHED.
AND PART OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
WERE ALTHOUGH FREQUENTLY THE
FOCUS HAS BEEN ON PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR TEMPORARY
FARMWORKERS.
THE DATA IS CLEAR THAT THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS FOR PERMANENT
FARM WORKER FAMILY HOUSING.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL ATTEMPTS.
TO EMPHASIZE THAT NEED AND SO TO
GET TO YOU KNOW CLEARLY AGE TO A
IS A FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THAT WE AS A STATE LEGISLATURE
WE CANNOT CONTROL -- BUT YOU
KNOW AND WE CAN'T TELL SOMEONE
OF AN ACT OPERATE OR GROW OR
WHETHER THE WE KNOW WHETHER AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN USE THAT
NO THIS TEMPORARY WORKER PROGRAM
AND THIS BILL LEAVES THAT
DECISION FULLY UP TO THE GROWER.
FULLY UP TO THE GROW.
IN THIS DAY THESE ARE MY FIRST
FEW MONTHS HERE SACRAMENTO WE
JUST WANT TO THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND IT'S THROUGH THAT BUDGET
PROCESS THAT I NOW UNDERSTAND
THAT HOW OUR STATE SPENDS OUR
MONEY.
IS A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES.
AND SO CERTAINLY.
WE DO HAVE A CHOICE AS A STATE
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT TO
SUBSIDIZE -- THIS FEDERAL
PROGRAM AND SO I SAY THAT
BECAUSE THIS BILL.
FOCUSES ON OUR STATE FUNDING ARE
LIMITED STATE FUNDING TO THE JOE
SRNA FIND.
ON HOUSING THAT COULD HELP FARM
WORKING FAMILIES AN H. TWO A.
INHERENTLY DOES NOT.
IS NOT A FARM WORKER FAMILY
PROGRAM.
AND SO THIS BILL IS IS IS NOT
ONLY CONSISTENT WITH OUR VALUES
MY PERSONAL VALUES.
BUT IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
VISION.
OF OF STATE PROGRAMS IN THE
SPACE IN IN NAMELY AS I MENTION
THE JOE SORT OF FIND IS A
PROGRAM THAT CLEAR IF YOU LOOK
AT YOU KNOW THE JOKES IN A
PROGRAM UNDER UNDER CALIFORNIA
CODE IT REFERENCES A FAMILIES.
THAT THIS THESE ARE FUNDS
INTENDED TO BE FOR AGRICULTURE
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AND SO THE COMMUNITY BLOCK GRANT
PROGRAM ALSO IN THE STATE IS
DESIGNED TO HELP ALLEVIATE
POVERTY NOT PROVIDE CORPORATE
SUBSIDIES.
SPECIALLY FOR AGRICULTURE FOR
BIG HACK.
AND SO A YOU KNOW AGAIN IT WE AS
A STATE LEGISLATURE WE HAVE NO
CONTROL OVER GROWERS ON THEIR
DECISION TO USE OR NOT USE THIS
PROGRAM H. AWAY.
SOMEWHERE USES SO IF YOU IF YOU
WERE WHEN FACED WITH.
LESS THAN SATISFACTORY HOUSING
FOR WORKERS WHO IMPORT EMPLOYED
IN H. TO A PROGRAM THAT WE DO
NOT CONTROL.
ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH THAT WELL
OF COURSE THE POINT WHERE YOU
PROHIBIT THE USE OF HOUSING
FUNDS. TO CONSTRUCT HOUSING FOR
THE H. TO A WORKERS.
SO WHAT WAS WHAT HAS BEEN
CONVEYED TO ME I HAVE WE HAVE
MYSELF MY STAFF WE HAVE WORKED
EXTENSIVELY WITH AGRICULTURE ON
THIS ISSUE.
THE MESSAGE THAT HAS BEEN TOLD
TO US REPEATEDLY.
IS THAT THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR
A HANDOUT WHEN IT COMES TO AGE
TO A PROJECTS.
THAT THEY ARE MOST INTERESTED IN
STREAMLINING.
THE CONSTRUCTION I HAVE EXAMPLE
I CAN POINT TO EXAMPLES WHERE
YOU HAVE AG COMPANIES THAT HAVE
COME TOGETHER. TO BUILD STATE OF
THE ART.
STATE THE ART.
YOU KNOW HOUSING PROJECTS
RACEWAY WORKERS IS THE GOLD
STANDARD IN THE SALINAS VALLEY.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SAME CAN'T BE
SAID THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE --
BUT CERTAINLY THE FOCUS AGAIN
HERE LOOKING AT JOE CERTAIN OF
THE LIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
JOE SORT OF FIND HAS -- THE
INTENTION FOR ME THE INTENTION
HAS ALWAYS BEEN [inaudible]
THAT.
AGAIN WE CAN'T CONTROL WHAT A
GROWERS GONNA DO WHETHER THEY
OPT INTO AGE TO OR NOT -- BUT
FOR ME IT'S IT'S THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DIRECT AND FOCUS
OUR LIMITED STATE RESOURCES ON
HOUSING THAT WILL WILL RESULT IN
PROJECTS TO PROVIDE DIGNIFIED
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKERS FAMILIES
USERS IS THERE IS SOME EVIDENCE
TO SUGGEST THAT THE CERNER FROM
SORT OF FUN IS INADEQUATE. TO TO
COVER THE FAMILY HOUSING NEED
THAT YOU WERE INTERESTED IN AND
PROVIDE SOME.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF HOUSING FOR EACH
TO A WORKERS THAT I CANNOT
ANSWER -- BUT I WHAT WHAT WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT WITH THE LIMITED
DOLLARS THAT GOING TO JOE SORT
OF FIND THE FOCUS YOU KNOW OUR
EFFORT THE FOCUS IS TO DIRECT
THOSE FUNDS.
AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
CONSTRUCTED IN DEVELOPING
SUPPORTING EXISTING FARMWORKER
FAMILIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSING AS A STABILIZING FORCE
FOR ALL EMPLOYMENT AND CERTAINLY
THIS IT WILL BE A STABILIZING
FORCE FOR AGRICULTURE.
WELL.
I'M OBVIOUSLY -- SUPPORTIVE
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE OF
PROVIDING WHATEVER MONEY IS
NEEDED TO PROVIDE FAMILY HOUSING
FOR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
THE BEST WE CAN POSSIBLY AFFORD.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE FAILURE TO ADDRESS.
THE POTENTIAL FOR LESS THAN
SATISFACTORY HOUSING FOR WORKERS
WHO ARE WORKING IN EMPLOYED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
PROGRAM THAT WE DON'T CONTROL
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE ANY CONTROL
OVER HOW MANY ARE HERE.
AND HOW MANY ARE WORKING YET
THEY'RE HERE.
AND IT IS OUR JOB AS LEGISLATORS
TO PROVIDE FOR THOSE AS I SAID
BEFORE IN MY OPINION.
WHO LIVE AND WORK HERE?
REGARDLESS OF STATUS WHO THEY
ARE WHERE THEY CAME FROM.
SO -- MISTER CHAIR WHILE I HAVE
SOME OF IS VERY VERY SERIOUS
CONCERNS. TO THE EXTENT THAT
THIS IS A CLOSE VOTE I WILL BE
SUPPORTING AS A COURTESY OF THIS
BILL TODAY TO MOVE IT OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT I CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT SOMEONE ADDRESSES MY
CONCERNS BEFORE IT GETS TO THE
SENATE [inaudible]
FOR QUESTION CENTER.
A CENTER LIKE HEALTHY.
NICE TO HEAR FROM THE FORMER.
CHAIR OF SUB -- TO FOUR IN THE
SENATE THE DEALS WITH BUDGETING
FOR HOUSING I SIT IS THE CHAIR
OF SUB TO WHICH HAS RESOURCES SO
MY QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO GO TO
YOUR CRITERIA THAT YOU'VE SET
OUT.
IN IN OUR STAFF REPORTS ON PAGE
THREE ONE OF THE MISSIONS THAT I
SEE WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT WETLANDS
AND COASTAL ZONES.
THERE'S NO MENTION OF THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES BOARD LET ME BE
VERY PARTICULAR I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE CONSTRUCTION OF THESE
THIS HOUSING AND HOOK HOOK UPS
TO FEELING WATER SYSTEMS OR
GROUND WATER A WELL.
THAT THAT MAY BE A WELL INTENDED.
AGRICULTURAL HOUSING THAT MAY
EXACERBATE THE GROUNDWATER TRONG
OR MAY ACTUALLY BE TIED UP TO A
SYSTEM THAT'S THAT'S FEELING.
SO THERE'S NOTHING IN HERE THAT
REQUIRES THE HOOK UP OF THESE
THESE NEW UNITS TO SUCCEEDING.
OUR SYSTEM NO PROOF NONE OF THE
CRITERIA THAT STARES AT THAT
JUMPED OUT AT ME. TO THE COMMENT
SO ALL THE FOR TO ARE.
OUR SPONSOR FOR THE TECHNICAL
QUESTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- THAT THAT IS
ADDRESSED IN THE BILL -- SECTION
SEVENTEEN OH TWO ONE BE ONE AND
TWO PROVIDES THE CITY YOUR CAT
HAVE HAVEN'T TEAM -- TWO ONE BE.
ONE INTO.
THOSE PROVISIONS PROVIDE THE
CITY OR COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT
MAY DENY A REQUEST FOR OPERATION
CONSTRUCTION OR REPAIR OF WATER
SYSTEM OR WASTE DISPOSAL SYSTEM
SERVICING AGRICULTURAL EMPLOYEE
HOUSING.
BASED ON PROCEDURAL OR
SUBSTANTIVE DEFECTS IN THE
APPLICATION.
IF THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
DENIES THE APPLICATION -- BASED
ON WATER CONCERNS THE APPLICANT
CAN REQUEST EACH CD REVIEW THAT
DENIAL AND EIGHT CD HAS THE
RIGHT TO OVERRIDE IT.
IF AND THIS IS A QUOTE FROM THE
STATUTE.
THE PLANS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
THE ALL UP OF COOL BUILDING
CODES AND HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS.
THEREFORE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THROUGH EIGHTY THREE AS PROVIDED
PROVIDES BOTH A LOCAL CHECK IN A
STATE DOUBLE CHECK. TO ENSURE
THAT FORMER HOUSING PROJECTS
BUILD PURSUANT TO THE BILL WILL
RESULT WILL NOT RESULT IN WATER
RELATED ISSUES.
INCLUDING WELL WATER
[inaudible]
YES.
OKAY -- MY NEXT QUESTION IS ON
THE FIFTY FIVE YEAR PROVISION.
WITH THE CHANGING FACE OF
AGRICULTURE.
YOU ELIMINATE THE H. TWO
INDIVIDUALS YOU ELIMINATE.
LOW INCOME WORKERS FROM LIVING
IN THIS HOUSING IF.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE THE
AGRICULTURE TRAINS CAN LOOK LIKE
BUT WHAT MECHANIZATION IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT THAT'S POSSIBLE
WITHIN THE NEXT FIFTY FIVE YEARS
FOR A JURISDICTION TO BE
COMPLETELY PLANTED WITH.
WITH CROPS THAT NO LONGER HAVE
THE INTENSE.
FARMWORKERS.
NEEDS THAT I GREW UP WITH.
AND THIS WOULD PROHIBIT AT LEAST
THE WAY I READ IT WOULD PROHIBIT
ANYBODY ELSE FROM LIVING IN THAT
LOW INCOME HOUSING.
JUST PUTTING THE ISSUE AND I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S YOUR
INTENTION THAT IT'S ONLY GONNA
BE THESE PEOPLE WHO THIS IS THE
BUT THERE WILL BE THERE MAY BE
OTHER FAMILIES THAT AREN'T.
CONNECTED WITH AGRICULTURE IN
WITHIN FIFTY FIVE YEARS THAT
WOULD LIVE IN THIS.
IN THIS HOUSING JUST.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
YOUR GOAL.
SO -- THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT
STATUTES ALREADY THAT REQUIRE A
FIFTY FIVE YEAR A REQUIREMENT
FOR LOW INCOME HOUSING WE
BELIEVE IT WAS APPROPRIATE TO
REQUIRE A FIFTY FIVE YEAR --
REQUIREMENT FOR FARMWORKERS
HOUSING AS WELL TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THOSE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BILLS SUCH AS PUBLIC RESOURCES
CODE SECTION TWO ONE ONE FIVE
FIVE POINT. ONE THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY BILLS SO IF A PROPERTY
OWNER IF A FARM OWNER DOES NOT
BELIEVE THAT THERE AREAS GONNA
SUPPORT FARMING FOR FIFTY FIVE
YEARS AND DOES NOT HAVE.
ENOUGH FARMWORKERS TO NEED THE
HOUSING THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
USE THIS PROGRAM THEY CAN BUILD
THE HOUSING UNDER EXISTING LAW
WHERE THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
BUILD HOUSING.
THIS IS YOU KNOW IS ONLY A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM FOR THOSE THAT
BELIEVE IT FITS THEIR NEEDS.
THAT'S RIGHT BECAUSE FARMERS
HAVE NVER MADE A PREDICTION
MISTAKE AS WHAT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE I WOULD
JUST SUGGEST THAT I DON'T SEE
THERE'S ANY.
DO WHICH ONE BUT THERE'S NO --
PROBLEM OF SEEING IF THERE'S NOT
AVAILABLE FARMWORKERS THERE THAT
THE AGENCY COULD LOOK AT OTHER
LOW INCOME PEOPLE WE DO THAT.
AND OTHER RESTRICTIONS THAT
PEOPLE TRY TO PUT ON
PARTICULARLY -- LOW INCOME
HOUSING BUT THOSE ARE MY
OBSERVATIONS AND CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS CENTER THERE
ALSO.
A YES -- JUST ON THE ISSUE THE
H. H. TO A CLEARLY THAT'S A
FEDERAL PROGRAM AND I I THINK
ONE OF THE SPEAKERS.
ADDRESS THIS.
WELL ONE OF THE WITNESSES IS
IT'S A PROGRAM THAT REQUIRES THE
EMPLOYER. TO PROVIDE A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
THERE'S A BACK AND FORTH HERE
THAT IF OF WORKERS ARE BROUGHT
IN FROM OUT OF COUNTRY.
THEN THEY HAVE TO BE PROVIDED
WITH CERTAIN THINGS.
MEALS TRANSPORTATION.
HOUSING -- I CAN IMAGINE THE THE
STATE GOVERNMENT THEN WOULD STEP
IN TO PROVIDE ALL THESE THINGS
WHICH ARE ALREADY A REQUIREMENT
OF THIS OF THE FEDERAL PROGRAM.
SO I AND THERE IS.
I WANT FORMER HOUSING FOR
ANYBODY H. TWO EIGHT OR NOT.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT WERE DRAW
THE LINE IS THAT SINCE IT'S
ALREADY REQUIRED OF THE EMPLOYER.
THROUGH THE FEDERAL PROGRAM WHY
WOULD WE STEP IN AND PROVIDE
THAT HOUSING AND PAY FOR IT WHAT
PIC PAY FOR THAT HOUSING -- WHEN
IT'S ALREADY REQUIRED?
IF YOU IF YOU APPLY AND SAY YOU
WANT AGE TO A WORKERS YOU DO
THAT ITH THE INTENTION THAT YOU
CAN PROVIDE ALL THE THINGS THAT
ARE REQUIRED OF YOU.
PERIOD.
SO THIS HOUSING THAT WE WITH OUR
STATE DOLLARS WOULD.
HELP -- IN A NUMBER OF WAYS WHAT
IS STREAMLINING OR FUNDING
WHATEVER IT SEEMS TO BE OUT OF
BE FOUR US THE OTHER FARMWORKERS --
IN BETTER THEY'RE WORKING IN THE
FIELDS -- I DO THINK THAT THERE
ILL.
ALWAYS BE FARMWORKERS THAT ARE
NEEDED -- REGARDLESS -- TO MY
COLLEAGUE OVER THERE -- THE FACT
THAT.
THERE IS.
THAT THERE ARE AGE TO A WORKERS
BEING RECRUITED HERE MEANS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE'S
GOING TO BE A NEED SO -- I JUST
THINK THAT THIS IS IT HAS THE
RIGHT ELEMENT. TO INCENTIVIZE OF
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKER FAMILIES
BUT ALSO DRAWS THE LINE AS TO
HOW FAR WE'RE WILLING TO GO TO
USE OUR TAX DOLLARS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS UP.
AND I'M GLAD TO BE.
SUPPORTIVE [inaudible]
SENATOR BATES.
JUST A QUICK COMMENT MAYBE A
QUESTION WITH THAT.
IT SEEMS TO ME YOU'VE ALMOST DE
INCENTIVIZE THE VOLUNTARY
PROGRAM.
BY REQUIRING THIS THIRD PARTY TO
MANAGE SOMEONE ELSE'S LAND.
AND THEY RETAIN THE LIABILITY
RESPONSIBILITY OF ALL OF THAT.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT A LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND NON PROFITS
GENERALLY I KNOW IN THE COUNTY
OF ORANGE.
MANAGE THOSE ORIGINALLY
DEDICATED LOW INCOME UNITS THAT
THIS IS SOMEBODY'S PRIVATE LAND
PROVIDING FOR WORKERS THAT YOU
KNOW MADE ON COMING GOAL
DEPENDING ON THE SEASON AND THE
CROPS AND ALL OF THAT.
A IDEA THAT PERSON IS GOING TO
BEAR THE LIABILITY FOR ALL OF
THAT -- AND MAYBE WE VERY
WILLINGLY IF THEY HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE IS BEING MANAGED IN THE
PROPER WAY AND ALSO MEETING THE
THE STANDARDS THAT CERTAINLY ARE
LACKING NOW.
SO I WOULD THINK IF YOU'RE OPEN
TO A CONSIDERATION OF AMENDING
THAT.
I THINK IT'S GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I THINK IT REALLY
INCENTIVIZE HIS PARTICIPATION.
BUT WITH THAT PROVISION A VERY
DIFFICULT THING WE'VE SEEN AND
NOT WORK WELL -- WITH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND NOW THE COUNTY THAT
YOU KNOW PUT IT IN WHERE I MANY
YEARS AGO AND THEY THEY TURNED
OVER WITHIN A SHORTER PERIOD OF
TIME BY GETTING SOME LEGISLATION
THAT ALLOWED THAT.
SO I'D I'D LIKE TO SEE YOU
COMMENT ON THAT MAYBE RECONSIDER
THAT PROVISION NOTHING SURE SO I
DO APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND
ALL DEFERRED -- TO OUR SPONSOR --
BUT IT BUT YOU KNOW THE QUESTION
OF LIABILITY THAT WAS RAISED BY
THIS BILL'S OPPONENTS I THINK
IT'S SOMETHING THAT -- WE'VE
CONSIDERED IT -- ALREADY YOU
KNOW AS FAR AS YOU KNOW WHO WILL
ASSUME THAT LIABILITY AND THEN --
THE ISSUE OF THE INSURANCE AS
WELL SO MAYBE THE SPONSOR GOOD --
MAKE THAT COMMENT.
YEAH -- THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
WHEN YOU HAVE AN EMPLOYER?
HOUSING SOMEONE IT CAN OFTEN
CREATE PROBLEMS AND THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS -- SECOND TIER
OF MANAGEMENT -- ARE.
OUR THINKING AND SORRY I LAST
WINTER BUT IN LATE -- IT SINCE
IT IS A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM -- WE
WANTED TO CREATE A STANDARD THAT
WE BELIEVE WILL PROVIDE THE THE
BEST CARE FOR THE TENANTS OF THE
THE THE HOUSING WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT.
BY CREATING RULES LIKE THIS THE
NUMBER OF UNITS THAT MIGHT BE
BUILT MAY BE LESS BUT THAT'S WHY
A PROGRAM LIKE THIS OF PASSING
THE LAW WILL BE MONITORED
CLOSELY AND IF CHANGES NEED TO
BE MADE THEY CAN BE MADE BUT IF.
IT HOUSING LIKE THIS CAN BE
DEVELOPED IN HOUSE LIKE THIS IS
DEVELOPED IT WILL BE THE BEST
HOUSING FOR FARMWORKER FAMILIES
AND AND THAT'S WHY THIS THIS --
PORTION THE BILL IS IN THERE
WOULD SEEM TO ME YOU NEED TO AN
INDEMNIFICATION ON COMPONENT OF
IT.
I I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE PEOPLE
HAVING HOUSING ON THE LAND THAT
THEY OWN IN YONGE THEY HAVE NO
AUTHORITY OVER WHATSOEVER.
WITHOUT DOUBTS YOU KNOW JUST
INCOMPREHENSIBLE TO ME AND YOU
KNOW THINKING AND ON MY OWN
PROPERTY IF I PUT IN EIGHTY YOU.
I WOULD STILL HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
MAINTENANCE AND JOB.
MAKING SURE THAT WAS MEETING A
STANDARD THAT IF I GAVE IT OVER
TO SOMEONE ELSE AND AND THEY GOT
TO MANAGE MY EIGHTY YOU ON MY
YOU KNOW BACKYARD DOUBTS THAT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE AT ALL TO
ME EXCUSE ME BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM.
BUT I THINK YOU BUILT A POISON
PILL INTO IT.
SO THAT I WOULD BE.
THE BILL DOES NOT.
REQUIRE ANY NEGOTIATION TO
HAPPEN BETWEEN THE MANAGEMENT --
NONPROFT AND THE OWNER SO THEY
CAN STRUCTURE THEIR CONTRACT OF
HOW THE NONPROFIT MANAGES IT
INCLUDING WHO HAS LIABILITY FOR
DIFFERENT ISSUES.
BASED ON NEGOTIATION BETWEEN THE
LANDOWNER AND THE NONPROFIT IF
THEY DON'T REACH AN AGREEMENT
THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO USE THE
PROGRAM BUT WE BELIEVE THAT
THROUGH NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE
NONPROFIT IN A LANDOWNER THEY
COULD.
REACH AGREEMENT ON HOW MAY IN
ITS LIABILITY OTHER ISSUES LIKE
THAT WOULD BE HANDLED SO WE DO
THINK THAT.
THOSE ISSUES CAN BE ADDRESSED
THROUGH THAT [inaudible]
NEGOTIATION PROCESS.
OKAY I SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS ARE.
SO -- SOME MEMBER THANK YOU.
FOR THE MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO --
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I AM PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR.
OF THE BILL AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT -- TO TEENS IS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT.
I MEAN WE HAVE TO BACK UP AND
LOOK AT WHY THIS IS NECESSARY
I'M A SUPPORTER OF STREAMLINING
AND I'VE YOU KNOW I AUTHORED.
BIG STREAMLINING BILL A COUPLE
YEARS AGO AND I I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US -- TO TO MOVE
TO EXPEDITE HOUSING APPROVALS
AND CONSTRUCTION -- AND TO TRIED
TO REMOVE SOME OF THE LOCAL
OBSTRUCTION TO HOUSING AND WE
SEE A CLOUT IN NUMBER WAYS AND
IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS IN THE
BAY AREA -- WE YOU KNOW ZONE OUR
LAND TO BAN APARTMENT BUILDINGS
WE MAKE A REALLY HARD TO BUILD
ANYTHING.
AND THEN PEOPLE WONDER WHY
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN THEIR IN
THEIR CARS -- AND EIGHT
SOMETIMES DON'T CONNECTED TO AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE DO
THAT AND IN OUR CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES -- WE HAVE -- AND
IT'S VERY HARD TO GET APPROVAL
TO BUILD FARMWORKERS HOUSING AND
YOU WONDER WONDER WHY
FARMWORKERS ARE LIVING IN SUCH.
DEPLORABLE -- CONDITIONS -- AND
FARMWORKERS ARE FUELING THESE
LOCAL ECONOMIES HELPING FUEL THE
ECONOMY OF STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I THINK WE NEED TO MAKE IT
EASIER.
I'M FASTER OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD -- THIS HOUSING -- IN
TERMS OF THE AGE TO A ISSUE AND
I HAVE NO OBJECTION TO AND
ANOTHER BILL.
TO MAKE IT EASIER TO ENSURE THAT
EACH WAY WORKERS WHO ARE HERE
CAN BE HOUSE.
BUT THIS BILL IS ABOUT PROJECTS
AS A CENTER THERE ALSO SET A
RECEIVING A PUBLIC FUNDS -- AND
ONE PUBLIC FUNDS OR ISSUE -- I
THINK IT IS PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE TO FOCUS THOSE FUNDS --
ON HOUSING -- FOR FAMILIES YOU
KNOW WHO WERE WHO ERE REALLY OR
CALIFORNIA -- FARMWORKER
FAMILIES AND WHO ARE -- YOU KNOW
WHO WHO WERE -- NOT THE AS
OPPOSED TO THE H. TO A AND MAYBE
SOME OF THOSE A TO A WORKERS
WILL ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW AS FOR
HIM AS WE KNOW HAPPENS MOST
PEOPLE STAY IN.
AND UP INTEGRATING INTO OUR
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING -- BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC FUNDS I THINK IT'S
PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE AND I
THINK IT'S A GOOD THING -- TO
FOCUS A ON THESE FAMILIES -- SO
I I SUPPORT THAT ASPECT OF THE
BILL -- AS WELL -- I ALSO SAW A
COMMENT ON THE ISSUE OF WHO IS
MANAGING THE PROPERTIES AND I OF
COURSE RUN -- AN ILL FATED A
FORMER FOR HOUSING BILL LAST
YEAR ON I LEARNED A LOT DURING
THE PROCESS AND I'M GLAD THIS
BILL IS MOVING FORWARD -- IN A
STRONG WAY -- BUT THE IDEA OF
HAVING SOMEONE BE BOTH YOUR
LANDLORD AND YOUR BOSS IS IS
PROBLEMATIC -- IN A LOT OF WAYS --
AND HAVING A THIRD PARTY AND WE
HAVE MANY VERY REPUTABLE --
NONPROFIT -- AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN VERY
RESPONSIBLY MANAGE -- THESE
PROPERTIES -- AND SO AGAIN.
PUBLIC FUNDS ARE BEING USED HERE
SO I DON'T THINK IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS -- TO SAY THAT IT
SHOULD BE STRUCTURED -- THIS WAY --
AND AS WAS NOTED THE AGREEMENTS
CAN BE STRUCTURED AND NEGOTIATED --
SO THIS IS A GOOD BILL -- I
SUPPORTED -- I AM RECOMMENDING
THAT THE COMMITTEE PASS -- THIS
BILL OUT.
AND FINALLY ON THE H. TO A ISSUE
I DO JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT THAT
ISSUE -- DISSECTION OFTHE BILL --
RELATES -- TO THE DEPARTMENTOF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT GOD IS AN AREA YOU
SEE THE THAT IS WITHIN THE
EXCLUSIVE JURISDICTION OF OF THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE.
AND HAD THAT BEEN THE ONLY THING
IN THE BILL -- THE BILL WOULD
HAVE BEEN SINGLE REFERRED TO THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE -- SO
OUR HOUSING COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
AWFULLY BAD AT THE AGE TO A
RESTRICTION -- AND ANALYZED IT
AND THIS -- WE SUPPORT IT -- SO
WITH THAT -- IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS -- YOU MAY YOU
MAY CLOSE.
AND SO WITH THAT I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTIONS -- AND THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS BY -- OUR CHAIRMAN AND
RESPECT ASPEN ABOUT.
THANK YOU OKAY THERE'S A MOTION
BY SENATOR DROSS SO AND WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS AN EVIL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SEPTEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
MOTIONS TO PASS REFER THE
COMMAND GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
SIR WIENER.
WIENER I AM AROUND.
MORRELL NO BATES.
BATES SNOW CAMARO.
CAMARO I DRUGS SO.
DRUGS SO I MCGUIRE MORLOCK.
BROKE NO ROUGH.
SKINNER.
UMBERG.
I'M BURKE AYE CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE I THE VOTERS FIVE TO
THREE WILL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
OKAY DO WE HAVE AN AUTHOR.
WELL WE ARE DONE.
OKAY WE HAVE ACTUALLY MADE IT
THROUGH ALL THE BILLS MOVIE
WAITING HERE A LONG TIME FOR
ANOTHER AUTHOR -- SO WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT WELL WE'RE GONNA
WAIT.
LET'S SEE ALONG TO TAPER OFF THE
NUMBERS TO GET HERE.
IT'S GONNA TAKE AWHILE WILL OF
CALLS TO GET EVERYONE OUT --
OTHERWISE WE'LL WAIT A FEW
MINUTES.
WE ARE AT ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT WERE
MISSING SKINNER MCGUIRE.
AND OKAY WELL WILL OPEN THE ROLE
NOW WE'LL.
GO BACK LATER.
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB.
TEN LET'S -- CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
HELLO YOU'RE RIGHT WE NEVER DID
LET'S MAKE A MOTION ON A BATON.
OKAY MOVE BY SENATOR BATES.
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS A NEW MEMBER TEN BY
SOMEONE NUMBER TWO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS REFER THE COMMAND
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE CENTER
WIENER.
WIENER I AM GROW BY BROWN I
BATES BATES AYE CABRERO.
CARREIRO I DRAWS OKAY.
DRAWS A LINE MCGUIRE BARLACH
[inaudible]
ROUGH SKINNER.
I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT UNDER THE
CASKEY.
BECAUSE THE I OKAY THE VOTED
SEVEN ZERO AND WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
WE WILL -- WE WILL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ON THE COUNTERS CONSISTS OF ALL
ITEMS TO TWELVE THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN AND EIGHTEEN SENATOR
ALSO.
DRESSEL I AM A CHOIR.
SKINNER BECAUSE HE S. CI. NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO KEEP THAT ON CALL --
AND ACTUALLY -- FOR LET'S GO
BACK TO ONE AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS IN CENTER OFFICE
WASHINGTON.
THIS IS AN WRITTEN BY SOME
MEMBER TO MOTIONS YOU PASS AND
REFER THE CANADIAN GOVERNMENTS
AND FINANCE.
THE REQUIRE MORE LOCK ROTH
[inaudible]
I SKINNER. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
PUT IT BACK ON CALL WE NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER -- THREE AB SIXTY
SEVEN WE WILL NEED A MOTION ON
AN EMOTIONAL.
YES WE NEED A MOTION ON THAT IS
OUR MOTION SIR THERE ALSO MOVES
A ITEM THREE AB SIXTY SEVEN WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE FINAL SIXTY SEVEN BY
SOME NUMBER THREE OF US MUCH AS
YOU PASS AS AMENDED EVERY FOR
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL WELL I BATES
[inaudible]
GUERRERO.
CARE BY DRAWS -- DOESN'T AYE
MCGUIRE.
MORLOCK.
MARK NO ROTH.
PROF I SKINNER.
AMBERG.
NUMBER FIVE LOOK ASKING.
BECAUSE HE I I DON'T KNOW.
MORRELL I DON'T KNOW.
YES THE VOTE OF SIXTY TWO WILL
PUT THAT ON CALL -- NEXT ITEM
FOR AB ONE THIRTY NINE ON A
WALKING CENTER SKINNER THAT
MEANS A SENATOR MCGUIRE WINS A
MIKE MCGUIRE OR THIS WEEK.
SO SOMEONE CAN PRESENT IN THAT
AWARD -- ONCE HE ARRIVES OKAY
ITEM FOR AB ONE THIRTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA WILL
NEED A MOTION.
MOTION BY CENTER MORE LOCKING
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE THREE
NINE BY SOME NUMBER QUIRK SILVA
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER THE COMMAND APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER AYE MORRELL.
MORRELL AYE BATES.
BATES AYE CAMARO.
CAMARO NINE DRAWS -- MCGUIRE.
MOORLACH.
OR LOG BY ROTH PROF AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE AMBERG.
NUMBERED BY THE CASKEY.
CASSIE I OF ABSENT MEMBERS WILL
HAVE TO MEMBERS OF THE ADDRESS
SO.
BROTHER I AM A BUYER.
HI ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
EVERYONE. SEVEN EIGHT WE'RE ALL
HERE OKAY SO WITH A VOTE. ELEVEN
ELEVEN ELEVEN TO ZERO AND ITEM
FOR THAT BILL IS ADULTS -- ONE
SIXTY EIGHT AS THEIR IT'S
ALREADY BEEN IN MOTION SO OPEN
THE ROLE.
THIS IS A NOBLE ONE SIX EIGHT BY
SOME NUMBER AGUIAR-CURRY MOTIONS
YOU PASS AND RE REFER THE
COMMITTEE ENVIRONMENT QUALITY.
CENTER TOMORROW.
THERE WAS IF THIS WERE CROSSED
ALREADY SO.
UNTIL TOMORROW.
BROWN I DORADO [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
THIS IS THE TRIBES WILL.
REQUIRE REQUIRE I SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE BECAUSE HE BECAUSE
THE I BROWSE SO I ELEVEN ZERO
ELEVEN ZERO AB ONE SIXTY EIGHT
IS AL'S.
WHEN EXTRA ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
ONE SEVENTY THREE BY SOME
MEMBERS SHALL WE NEED A MOTION
ON THAT?
THE MOTION OF THE GUN.
WE GOT A MYSTERY.
THAT'S ON CALL OKAY.
THAT WAS WHEN I WAS NOT HERE.
OKAY WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER.
SIX SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER
AYE AMARO.
MORRELL AYE BATES [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
TORONTO.
DORADO AYE MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER I WOULD HAVE.
BECAUSE HE AYE. SEVEN TO ONE
OKAY [inaudible]
SKINNER AYE.
THE VOTE IS.
EIGHT TO ONE AND THAT BILLS OUT.
RESEARCHER.
YES DISTILLING COULD COME IN
THERE'S GOING TO BE THREE BILLS --
THAT ARE COMING TOGETHER AND
FIGHT DISTANCE WERE IN
NEGOTIATIONS ON EACH OF THE
THREE IS GONNA BE OF STANDING UP
FOR NOW BUT I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT.
THANK ON THE THIRD.
OKAY WERE MEXICO TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB THREE OH SEVEN BY SOME
NUMBER RAMOS AND IS ALREADY BEEN
IN MOTION AND WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE [inaudible]
THE GENERAL.
MORRELL AYE BATES BATES I DORADO.
BRAZIL I AM MCGUIRE [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER I NUMBER BUT AMBERG BY
CASKEY.
CASKEY I TEN IN HERE.
LIKE THE RIVER.
THE SALES ORDER.
OKAY SO -- TEN THE NOTHING AB
THREE OH SEVEN INSULTS -- ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB THREE SIX TO
REMOVE.
OKAY -- WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON A.
B. THREE EIGHTY SIX BY -- OF OR
THE GARCIA. NINE TO ONE THE VOTE
IS NINE TO ONE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIXES OUT -- NEXT WILL
REOPEN THE ROLE IN ITEM NINE A
BEFORE [inaudible]
ELEVEN SENATOR MORALE.
BROWN'S KNOWN STATES
[inaudible]
DORADO.
BROTHER I AM A CHOIR.
MCGUIRE AYE MORLOCK [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I AM BURKE.
NUMBER FIVE THE CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE.
HE TO ONE THE VOTERS -- EIGHT TO
ONE AND SO AB FOUR ONE ONE IS
ADULTS.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO ITEM ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD AND WILL RE
OPEN -- THE ROLE.
SENATOR MORROW.
NO MORRELL NO DRUGS SO.
DRUGS SO I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI MARLON.
RIGHT SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I AM A CASKEY AYE.
BATES NO TWO I NINE THE VOTE IS --
NINE TWO ONE AB FOUR THREE SEVEN
IS OUT.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO ITEM FIFTEEN
AB TWELVE FIVE FIVE BY SOME OF
THEM ROBERT RIVAS.
AND WE WILL OPEN THE ROLE FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR ALSO.
ALSO I MCGUIRE.
SKINNER RIGHT SKINNER I AM BURKE.
NUMBER I WHO CASKEY.
BECAUSE HE AYE. ZERO TEN TO ZERO
IS THE VOTE AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
IS OUT -- NEXT TO WILL GO TO
ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY THREE AND WE WILL OPEN
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
MORRELL.
BROWN I CABALLERO.
CARRIER I MCGUIRE.
MORE LOCK.
MY LUCK I SKINNER [inaudible]
SKINNER I OKAY THE VOTERS TEND
TO ZERO AND AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IS OUT -- NEXT IS ITEM
SEVENTEEN A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WE
WILL OPEN THE WRONG CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR RAZA.
TORONTO I REQUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER FIVE BECAUSE HE BECAUSE
THE I EIGHTY THREE VOTERS EIGHTY
THREE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIXES
OUT -- NEXT FOOD ITEM NINETEEN
AB SEVENTY NO TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS RIVAS.
WE NEED A MOTION ON ITEM --
NINETEEN BY SENATOR ROSS AND
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
AMARO.
HI MORRELL I ONE NINETEEN
NINETEEN ON A BATES.
BATES AYE CAMARO.
CAMARO KNOWN DORADO.
DRAWS -- AYE MCGUIRE.
FIRE I AM MOORLACH.
ROTH ROTH AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER HI I'M BURKE.
NUMBER FIVE A CASKEY.
HI BUT CASSIE I NINE TO ONE THE
VOTE IS NINE TWO ONE AB
SEVENTEEN OH TWO IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM TWENTY AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLOOR WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
SENATOR MORROW HI MORRELL HI
DORADO.
TORONTO HI MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER AYE AMBERG.
ALL RIGHT NUMBER I WOULD CASKEY.
CASKEY AYE LIMóN IS THERE FOR
TH VOTERS ELEVEN ZERO AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO IS OUT --
NEXT ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS WHO
OPENED THE ROLE FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
SENATE MCGUIRE.
ROUGH ROAD.
ROTH AYE SKINNER [inaudible]
I SEVEN THREE THE VOTERS SEVENTY
THREE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
OUT -- NEXT IS ITEM TWENTY TWO
AJ ARE FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM WILL OPEN THE WRONG
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
SENATOR ALSO -- ALSO I AM A
CHOIR.
FIRE I SKINNER.
I NUMBER.
NUMBER FIVE A CASKEY.
CASKEY I THE VOTERS ELEVEN ZERO
AJ ARE FIFTEEN IS OUT WILL NOW
GO BACK -- TO THE BEGINNING OF
THE AGENDA.
TIME WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
ONE A. B. [inaudible]
TEN SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE MOORLACH SKINNER
[inaudible]
SKINNER I TEN ZERO ZERO TO TEN
ZERO A. B. TEN IS OUT -- WE WILL
NEXT I GO TO THE CONSENT AGENDA
AND OPEN THE ROLE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER SKINNER AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT AGENDA
IS PASSED -- AND THEN ITEM THREE
AB SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUIS RIVAS.
SENATOR BATES MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER.
SKINNER I EIGHTY TWO OKAY THE
VOTERS EIGHTY TWO AB SIXTY SEVEN
IS OUT AND I BELIEVE THAT.
OKAY THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE.
IT WAS A OKAY WE ARE ADJOURNED